THE COMMITTEE BUT SOMEONE
PRESENTING A BILL THAT SENATOR
STERN WHO IS A BILL UP IN OUR
COMMITTEE- AND- CENTERS STERN-
WE ASK THAT IF YOU HAVE A STAFF
PERSON WITH YOU IDENTIFY THAT
SET UP FOR NOW. OKAY I'M SORRY
THE SCRIPT IS SO. OKAY WE WILL
HAVE HIM DO SO AT THE TIME- BUT
WE HAVE NO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY- TODAY- TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
PEOPLE WHO WISH TESTIFIED TODAY
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS NINE NINE NINE TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE- COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL.
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THIS IS ONLY ONE
pOPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER- THIS CAN HOPEFULLY BE A
SHORT WAIT- ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST TO MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. BEFORE YOU GIVE
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
OTHERWISE WE MAY HAVE TROUBLE
HEARING YOU- ALL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING. ON
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE HEARING MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
I CAN DOCTOR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE.
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD- I WANT TO
KNOW A FEW THINGS FIRST. BY
SENATOR RUBIO WILL PRESENT HER
BILL SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT A
LITTLE EARLIER THAN IS LISTED
ON. THE AGENDA SO IF ANYONE IS-
WANTS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT WE WILL BE TAKING THAT
UP. THIRD TODAY- WE HAVE ELEVEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA WHICH
OTHER THAN SENATOR RUBIO'S BILL
WILL BE HEARD. AND FILE ORDER-
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE.
THREE BILLS ON THE FIVE CONSENT
AGENDA THAT'S SB FIVE EIGHTY
ONE SB FOUR THIRTY TWO. SB TWO
THIRTY FOUR- I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW REGARDING SB 675% OR
STERN. AYE HE WILL BE
PRESENTING A BILL AND WE WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON IT BUT
WE WILL NOT BE VOTING ON THAT
BILL TODAYIT WILL BECOME A TO
YOUR BILL. AFTER TODAY'S
HEARING THAT'S SB SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE FOR ANYONE. WHO IS WISHING
TO PARTICIPATE. REGARDING BILL-
SO- LOW ESTABLISH A CORE. I'M
NOT A CONSOLE IF YOU PLEASE-
THE SUBSEQUENT. YEAH I GOT
ANOTHER. I THINK WE NEED A
MICROPHONE THING TESTING OKAY
SENATOR WIENER PRESIDENT WINNER
PRESENT BATES. BATES PRESENT
CORTESE. CORTESE PRESENT
CABALLERO PRESIDENT OF YOUR
PRESENCE MCGUIRE. IT SHOWED
YEAH. UNTIL THE PRESENCE. THERE
SKINNER PRO NUMBER. NUMBER
PRESS WHAT KASKY HERE BECAUSE
COOPER. OKAY OF HAVE A QUORUM.
AND FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY- DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS WILL BE AN ISSUE
TODAY- BUT- WE MAY NEED TO
INSTITUTE HIGH LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY WHICH WILL BE AN
EQUAL AMOUNT ON BOTH SIDES
AGAIN HOPEFULLY NOT AN ISSUE
TODAY- FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- WE WILL PERMIT
EACH SIDE HAVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES WHO EACH HAVE UP TO
TWO MINUTES EACH. BOB ALL OTHER
WITH WITH ALL OTHER- ALL OTHERS
WHICH YOU TESTIFIED- MUST LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE- AND- SO THANK
YOU LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR NOW ITEM NUMBER ONE- S.
B. NINE SENATOR ATKINS. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. MISTER CHAIRMAN
DAY YOU SO- I AM PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT. THIS
BILL AND SO TO YOU AD MY
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO ON
SB NINE. FOR MANY OF YOU THIS
BILL WILL LOOK VERY FAMILIAR OR
SIMILAR TO A BILL I AUTHORED
LAST YEAR S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY.
AND I WOULD REMINDED MY
COLLEAGUES THAT- THAT BILL SB
ELEVEN TWENTY PASSED BOTH
HOUSES. BUT DIDN'T GET BACK TO
OUR HOUSE LAST YEAR BY THE
MIDNIGHT DEADLINE. SO THIS- SB
NINE IS VERY SIMILAR TO SB
ELEVEN TWENTY. SB NINE PROMOTES
NEIGHBORHOOD SCALE RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT BY STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS FOR A HOMEOWNER TO
CREATE A DUPLEX. OR SUBDIVIDE
IN EXISTING LOT IN RESIDENTIAL
AREAS. THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONJECTURE ABOUT HOW MANY UNITS
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SO I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE BILL
WOULD ONLY ALLOW UP TO FOUR
UNITS ON A SINGLE FAMILY
PARCELS AS A RESULT OF THE LOT
SPLIT PROVISIONS. IN THIS
MEASURE. SB NINE STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL AND
CREATING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PRODUCTION
OF SMALL SCALE DEVELOPMENT.
THAT WE SO BADLY NEED TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
OUR STATE. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A SPECIFIC LIST OF
QUALIFICATIONS THAT MUST BE MET
AND PROTECTS EXISTING TENANTS
HISTORIC DISTRICTS
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY IN
COASTAL REQUIREMENTS. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT SB NINE
GUARDS AGAINST SPECULATION AND
GENTRIFICATION THE BILL LIMITS
INDIVIDUALS FROM RECEIVING
MINISTERIAL LOT SPLITS ON
ADJACENT PARCELS TO PREVENT
INVESTOR SPECULATION. IT'S
PROFITEERS FROM EVICTING OR
DISPLACING TENANTS BY EXCLUDING
PROPERTIES FOR A TENANT HAS
RESIDED IN THE PAST THREE YEARS.
IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS I
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATE HOUSING LEAD GROUP TO
IMPROVE THE BILL THIS BILL NOW
PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
AUTHORITY TO ENACT AN OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS. ALONG
WITH THE SAFEGUARDS IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES FOR FAMILIES OPTIONS
FOR BUILDING MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSING AND ASSETS.
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH IS A
CURRENCY WE KNOW IS CRUCIAL TO
COMBATING IN EQUITY AND
CREATING SOCIAL MOBILITY
ESPECIALLY NEIGHBORHOOD HOODS
OR OUTDATED ZONING LAWS HAVE
CREATED BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE
HOME OWNERSHIP AND LEAD TO
OVERCROWDING. THIS BILL GIVES
HOMEOWNERS THE OPTIONS TO
PROVIDE RENTAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
OTHER WORKING FAMILIES WHO MAY
BE STRUGGLING TO FIND A HOME IN
THEIR PRICE RANGE. OR WHO MAY
BE LOOKING FOR THEIR OWN PATH
TO MORE AFFORDABLE HOME
OWNERSHIP. THE BILL IS AN
EXPANSION OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERYONE HOMEOWNERS RENTERS AND
FAMILIES ALIKE. WE KNOW THAT
THE HOUSING CRISIS IS AN ISSUE
SO LARGE THAT THERE IS NO
SINGLE SOLUTION. AND THAT'S WHY
SB NINE AS PART OF THE SENATE
HOUSING PACKAGE BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL. I WANT
TO THANK SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THEIR TIME
AND COMMITMENT TO THIS MULTI
YEAR PROCESS. MISTER CHAIR WHO
HAS AUTHORED KEY PIECES OF
LEGISLATION IN THE HOUSING
PACKAGE AND WHO OF COURSE HAS
LED THE WAY ON SO MANY OTHER.
ISSUES RELATED TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND AFFORDABILITY. I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SENATOR CABALLERO I THANK
SENATOR CORTESE AND SENATOR
MCGUIRE FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
OUR STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS. AND
WORKING ARE WITH THIS GROUP.
I'M PROUD TO OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE TOGETHER ON THIS
BILL A MULTI YEAR EFFORT AND I
AM PROUD OF THE SENATE HOUSING
PACKAGE AS A WHOLE. TOGETHER WE
CAN MAKE MORE HOUSING
PRODUCTION POSSIBLE EVEN WHILE
WE CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THE
NEW REALITIES. AND UNCERTAIN
TIMES CALLS BY A PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. THIS ISN'T
JUST A BILL ARE SENATE HOUSING
PACKAGE ISN'T JUST A BUNDLE OF
LEGISLATION. THESE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE REAL
POSITIVE PROGRESSIVE CHANGES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. TO STRENGTHEN
THE FABRIC OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
WITH EQUITY INCLUSIVITY AND
AFFORDABILITY. WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND THE VALUABLE FOR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM PRO TEM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES- I BELIEVE WE
HAVE- TO LEAD SUPPORTERS NOT A
PRO TIME IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
I'M ERIC PHILLIPS FOR NUMERIC
PLANNING ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND A LEASE- BURKE-
SUIT IF I MISPRONOUNCE THAT
FROM UNITED WAY OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES THE CORRECT GREAT- SO
WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM ERIC
PHILLIPS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- THANK YOU FOR THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE THIS IS ERIC
PHILLIPS AND YOU JUST MENTIONED
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION. AND WE
ARE PLEASED TO JOIN HIM SENATE
PRO TEM ACTIONS IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE TODAY AND THANK HER FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THE SENATE
HOUSING PACKAGE AND ALL OF YOU
FOR THE GOOD WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE TODAY. HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
CONTINUE TO BE AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRESSING
ISSUES ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY
CAUSES OF THE HOUSING CRISIS I
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS SOME OF
WHICH WIENER SAID CREATED PLAY
A PART. UNDER CURRENT LAW A
MAJORITY OF RESIDENTIAL AREAS
CAN ONLY BE USED FOR SINGLE
FAMILY DWELLING. THIS LIMITED
HOUSING SUPPLY AND EXCLUDES
LOWER INCOME HOUSING HOUSEHOLDS
FROM HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND SB
NINE CAN BE PART OF THE EFFORT
TO EXPAND HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL. SB NINE DOES NOT
PROHIBIT SINGLE FAMILY HOMES OR
ZONING IT SIMPLY PROVIDES THAT
IN SUCH AREAS PROPERTY OWNERS
MUST ALSO BE ALLOWED TO CREATE
SMALL MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
OPTIONS. SB NINE CREATES THE BY
RIGHT MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR THE CREATION OF TWO
TO FOUR HOMES AND SINGLE FAMILY
ZONES IT ALLOWS PARCEL MAPS THE
CREATURE STREAMLINED. AND
PERMIT UP TO TWO HOMES. FOR A
LOT. TO LOG. WITH Q. U. S. EACH
THAT THAT. EIGHTY YOU LAWS- UP
TO THREE YOU KNOW FROM. OF THIS
IS IN IN TO. BUT THE PART MAPS.
ALLOW HOMES BE SOLD. WHICH WILL
HELP CREE OWNERS OFFER. THAT
ARE NOT AVAILABLE UNDER OTHER
HOUSING PRODUCTION BILLS. AND
ALTHOUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS
IS MINISTERIAL THE MAJORITY OF
OBJECTIVE PLANNING STANDARDS
WILL CONTINUE TO APPLY TO NEW
DEVELOPMENT. EVEN A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR THE ADOPTION OF
NEW IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS.
THIS APPROACH HELPS BALANCE THE
STATE AND LOCAL INTEREST. SB
NINE DEFINES MINIMUM
PERFORMANCE TARGETS OF TWO TO
FOUR UNITS STATEWIDE. BUT IT
LEAVES ROOM FOR LOCAL PLANNERS
TO DEFINE AND APPLY CONTEXT
SPECIFIC STANDARDS. FINALLY OUR
HOPE IS THAT INCREASING HOUSING
CHOICE AND SINGLE FAMILY ZONES
WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES MORE INCLUSIVE. BUT
THIS SHOULD NOT COME AT THE
COST OF DESTABILISING EXISTING
NEIGHBORHOODS. THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL SAFEGUARDS
THAT PREVENT THE LOSS OF
EXISTING HOUSING OR THE
DISPLACEMENT OF VULNERABLE
TENANTS. WE SUPPORT ZONING
REFORM TO END THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING ONLY SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES ON A MAJORITY OF
RESIDENTIAL LAND. THAT'S WHY WE
ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB NINE
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WHAT HERE- LEASE
UP WORKS UNITED WAY GREATER LOS
ANGELES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M SO PLEASED TO BE HERE AND
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR SB
NINE. WE KNOW THAT LAND USE
POLICIES ESPECIALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE DRIVEN RACIAL
SEGREGATION AND WEALTH
DISPARITIES FOR DECADES. WHAT
YOU MAY NOT KNOW IS AN L. A.
COUNTY THE AVERAGE BLACK FAMILY
HAS ONE NINETIETH OF THE WEALTH
AT AN AVERAGE WHITE FAMILY HAS
LARGELY DRIVEN THROUGH
HOMEOWNERSHIP. WE KNOW THAT OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IS DRIVING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING THE
BURDEN. AND IT MAKES THEM MORE
VULNERABLE AT THE SAME FOR THE
PANDEMIC. WE TRULY BELIEVE THAT
SB NINE WILL HELP TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO HOUSING ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED BRACKET
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES. AND
HAVE DRIVEN THE DISPARITIES
BETWEEN WHITE HOUSEHOLDS AND
BLACK AROUND HOUSEHOLDS. WE
OFTEN FEEL THAT SB NINE STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL AND
CREATING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SMALL SCALE NEIGHBORHOOD
DEVELOPMENT THAT WILL BENEFIT
THE BROADER COMMUNITY. AND
CREATE MORE SPACES FOR OUR
WORKERS HAVE HOUSING. SB NINE
ONE SOLVE OUR TOTAL HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS ON ITS OWN
SO WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE TO
URGE THAT WE CONTINUE TO PUSH
FORWARD ON ALL FRONTS.
INCREASING RENTER PROTECTIONS
AND INCREASING PUBLIC FUNDS TO
SEND- SUBSIDIZED HOUSING FOR
PROUD TO BE WORKING ON THE
DISHES WITH MANY OF YOU ON THE
COMMITTEE. UNITED WAY OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES STANDS WITH
COALITION PARTNERS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE WILLING TO
REJECT THE STATUS QUO. AND
REALLY ENVISION A FUTURE WHERE
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA HAS A
STATE SAFE AND STABLE HOME WITH
THE ABILITY TO THRIVE. SO IN
CLOSING WE DESPERATELY NEED
THESE UNITS AND THE TIME TO ACT
IS NOW AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK ESPECIALLY SENATE PRETEND
TONI ATKINS. FOR YOUR COURAGE
AND INTRODUCING THE BILL AND
THANKS TO EACH OF YOU ON THE
COMMITTEE. WHO IS WILLING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY ONE L. TO-
PUBLIC COMMENTS WHERE PEOPLE
WILL BE LIMITED TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL- WILL
START HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS. OR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO COMMENT ON S. B. NINE IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NINE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY- I DO
NOT SEE ANYONE STEPPING UP IN
TWENTY FORTY. I'M WITHOUT
PROCEED TO THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR KEY PLEASE TO PEOPLE
UP FOR SUPPORT PRESS THREE NINE-
CERTAINLY WAS SURELY THE
GENTLEMAN TO QUEUE UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT- PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. NUMBER
TO GET YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
SHOULD BE A LINE NUMBER TO BE
CALLED THE CHILDREN FROM. ONE
MOMENT TO ENSURE WE ARE HAVING
PEOPLE QUEUING UP. JUST ONE
SECOND. IT WOULD ALIGN OUT NOW
TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY THREE LINE
FIFTY THREE GO AHEAD STE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MORE ROOFTOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
BEFORE. ONE MOMENT OF
EXCELLENCE. ONE NUMBER TEN
BEAUDEN. SANTA MONICA CITY
COUNCIL UNANIMOUSLY OPPOSES SB
NINE AT THE STATE ASSAULT ON
OUR LOCAL DEMOCRACY. AS A
REMINDER THIS IS ONLY SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL HAVE THAT
AFTERWARDS SO PLEASE ONLY
SUPPORT FOR THIS SEGMENT OF THE
HEARING. BUT IN A LIMITED THE
TABLE TO CUBA BY MISTAKE AND IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION MAYBE YOU
KNOW IF YOU SAW MY PRESSING ONE
ZERO AGAIN. NEXT WITH A LONG
NUMBER FIFTY THREE PLEASE. ONE
FIFTY THREE LINES OPEN GOING IN.
WE ARE NOT A LINE NUMBER
FIFTEEN ONE FIFTEEN MINUTES
PLEASE. YES THIS IS RECALL WITH
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA SB NINE IS
NOT A DUPLEX BILL SIX OR MORE-UNITS INCLUDING THE MANSIONS
WHERE ONE HOME USED TO BE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY LATERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FIRST OF ALL THIS IS- THIS IS
FOR GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT
NAME. FILIATION. AND YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE ARE NOT
ALLOWED NUMBER TWENTY ONE
TWENTY GO AHEAD PLEASE SALARY
HARKNESS WITH GLOBAL
CALIFORNIAN UNITED NEIGHBORS
STRONGLY OPPOSE. BUT ONCE AGAIN
FOR EVERYONE WHO IS LISTENING
NOW THIS IS FOR SUPPORT ONLY IF
YOU WERE OPPOSED THERE WILL BE
A SECTION FOR OPPOSITION
AFTERWARDS. BUT IF YOU HAVE
QUEUED UP TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO DINNER GROUP
ITSELF FROM Q. WILL GO NOT A
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE ONE
TWENTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE ONE
POINT FIVE HAS. REMOVED ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE THIRTY TWO-
OPEN GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TO
PROTECT ME FAN ON THE OPERA
TRADE HOUSING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT YOU TO THE NEXT
ONE UP. ONE FIFTY SIX GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- MY NAME IS
DON GRAHAM ADVANCING ALLEY AND
I IN SUPPORT. HAVE AN ONLINE
TWENTY FIVE IS BACK ONLINE
TWENTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
WHAT WE'LL GET SOME MORE.
RICHARD PATIENTS WITH MAJOR
MEDICAL MORE MOMENT.
IT'S A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER IN THE IN
THE QUEUE IN A QUEUE TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
MISTER MODERATORS ARE
PROBLEMS. THERE MAY BE MORE NOT
SHOWING THAT WE'RE SHOWING
PEOPLE IN CUBA WE'RE NOT
SHOWING NY OF THEM RESPONDED
DRAWING FROM TO GET ONE LONG
BEACH.
OKAY THERE WE GO
COLLEGES FOR THAT WE'RE GETTING
A LITTLE BIT CAUGHT UP HERE A
LITTLE UNDER SIXTY TWO. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GET THEM- BACK
IN THE QUEUE HERE. ONE SIXTY
TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI IN THE
SYSTEM CHARGING WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THANK YOU. MARTYROLOGIUM MISTER
CHAIR WITH A LARGE VOLUME OF
RESPONDENTS OKAY WHICH THAT HAS
JAMMED UP TO KEEP JUST A LITTLE
BIT AND IT'S BEEN SLOW TO
RESPOND HERE I UNDERSTAND THIS
IS MOVERS AND EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE PLEASE. WORKING ON A
SERVER RIGHT NOW WOULD BE FOR
THE NEXT ONE TO KEEP. WE DO
HAVE ONE COMPLETED ONE ONE
SECOND. ONE THIRTY FIVE IS
COMING UP JUST A MOMENT SINCE
THEOPERATOR BRINGS THEM BACK
TO US. COULD NOT ALLOW ME TO
OPEN ONE THIRTY FIVE ONE MOMENT.
EIGHT ONE THIRTY FIVE YOU'RE
NOT OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. THE
MORNING I'M AT A BOOKBINDER
CITY CAMPBELL IT LOOKS AND
ACCEPT THE UNION I SUPPORTED
THREE NINE. THANK YOU WAITING
FOR THE NEXT ONE TO Q. WELL I
NINETY FIVE- OAKLAND. ONE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE. HI NEIL
PARKER BUT TAKE THAT WITH
CUPERTINO FROM CHAIRED AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MAYBE OUT A LINE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN. SHE LIVES IN THE
LINE EIGHTY SEVEN ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YEAR OPEN GOING ON. MY
NAME IS CAROLINE WITH MANTA FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
ABOUT THE NINE. LINE SEVENTY
FIVE YEAR OPEN GLORIA. HI MY
NAME IS TOM ATLEE- IN THAT OUT
OF LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
AN INSTRUCTOR FOR TO BE NINE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. LOUIS
NOT A LINE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
BILLION. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KOBE EVAN CALLING FROM
HELL ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
REACTION IN CONFLICT EVERYONE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY FUNDING.
HI MY NAME IS JOAN JONES FROM
SEAMY VALLEY AND I'M SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE. THANK YOU. LINE
TENURE OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ONE TENURE OPEN PLEASE. WILL BE
ON THE LINE ONE THIRTEEN ONE
THIRTEEN THOUGH AND. GOOD
MORNING ERIC PAYNE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
URBAN INSTITUTE- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE. ONE ONE
TWENTY THREE OPEN GOLDEN. I AM
PAULSON FROM LOS ALTOS SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE FIFTEEN
YEAR OPEN WILL. LINE. FIFTEEN
I'M ON HOLD THE OPPOSE MOVE OUR-
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY YOUR AND
YOUR LINES OPEN. HOLLY FOR ME
THEY HAD THIS WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIR CALLING AT THE
PORT OF SB NINE ON BEHALF OF-
THE COMPANYTHAT COALITION TEAM
HE PARTNERS THE GREENBELT
ALLIANCE AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
ROGER DICKINSON GOOD MORNING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT. BLIND
EIGHTY THREE YEAR OLD URBAN
GOING TO PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
HELLO WITH ABUNDANT HOUSING LOS
ANGELES CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT.
ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR OPEN
GLORIA. HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN
ADDRESSED I MEAN I LIVE IN
HILLSBORO CALIFORNIA I REMEMBER
AND IN FLIP FOR EVERYONE AT AND
I SUPPORT SB NINE. AN ONLINE
NUMBER NINETY NINE YOU'RE OPEN.
ZACKS DENNIS RESIDENT OF OXFORD
CALLING ON BEHALF OF VENTURA
COUNTY SB AND STRONG SUPPORT.
BUT LINE AB AEROPLAN. SERRA
WILL BE REGIONAL ORGANIZER WITH
SAN FRANCISCO UNITY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE IN THE
NORTHERN NEIGHBORS ST PAUL AND
URBAN ENVIRONMENTALISTS. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK
YOU. THE LINE SIXTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. I'M ON HOLD TO
CERTAIN TO OPPOSE. ONCE AGAIN
REFERRAL HOLDING TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM QUEUE- WE'RE
GOING TO GO NOW TO LINE ONE-
I'M SORRY ALLIANCE THIRTY FIVE
WILL TRY THEM AGAIN SEE IF THE
FACT. ONE MOMENT. ONE EIGHTY
FOUR YEAR OLD FROM GOING ON. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. B. HELLO. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU GO HEAD- MY
NAME IS EMILY AND- I'M CALLING
FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW GIMME AND
WE'RE CALLING WITH STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
OPERATORS ARE. THE LION ONE
TWENTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ONE ONE TWENTY FIVE. HI MY NAME
IS AMY HINDSIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK WE'RE EXPECTING A
STRONG SUPPORT EQUIPMENT
AMENDED PETITION AND YOU
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT THE L.
T. MODEL. NOT. ONE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROCK PROBABLY ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE THANKS. LINE SEVENTY
ONE YEAR OPEN WILL HAVE TO USE.
THIS IS BOB NAYLOR ON BEHALF OF
FIELDS. TOWARDS COUNTY BUSINESS
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
YIMBY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. NINE. THE LINE SEVENTY FOUR
GO AHEAD. HI KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. BY NINETY SIX
OLYMPICS. HI MY NAME IS ARGHA
BOTTLE I'M FROM UP AND-
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN.
ONE ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THE PHILADELPHIA
CLAIMS ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY AND HOLD ITS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
TWENTY TO GO AHEAD PLEASE. FOR
I'M IN THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION.
REMOVING FROM THE QUEUE PLEASE
REGION WITH OPPOSITION FROM. A
LINE NUMBER ONE ZERO EIGHT FOUR
WEEKS. HI MY NAME IS BRIAN
PRESCOTT CALLING FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA THE NUMBER OF SOUTH
BAY IN THE AND I OFFER MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB NINE.
LINE ONE TWENTY TO GO IN. ONE
TWENTY TWO LINES OPEN. WITH THE
LINE ONE FORTY SIX POINT PLEASE
ONE FORTY SIX PRODUCT. LINE
FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. I
THIS IS C<c.cyan>G REPRESENTING</c>
INDIA ACTION IN ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE STRONG REPORTER THAT
HE NINE THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT CORRECT PLEASE. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT- OPEN. MY NAME IS
CONSTANTIN HATCHER PROUD
LIFELONG ANGELENO ONE RESIDENT
OF THE DISTRICT TWENTY FOUR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES CREATED BY SB
NINE THANK YOU. ONE ONE FORTY
FIVE- OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO THIS IS TIMOTHY MILLER
FROM LOS ANGELES I'M CALLING TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT. CHAMBER OF SB.
NINE ONE ONE THIRTY ONE BILLION.
IT IS DIFFICULT IN YOUR CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT. IN
LINE ONE ELEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO. IF YOU WANT TO OPEN YES
MY NAME IS MARCY GAVEL FROM
THAT SOUTH BAY WE IS STRONGLY
AND I REPEAT WE STRONGLY.
RADICAL HOUSE INTO S. B. NINE.
IN A LINE ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE FORTY NINE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS WITH
MANTE- CALLING IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS THANK
YOU. ONE ONE TWENTY ONE GUNS
OPENS IS GOING ON. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS HENRY OCCUR I'M REPRESENTING
SANTA CRUZ GMB IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ESPIONAGE THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FORTY SEVEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING RICHARD LONGER
CHAIR A LITTLE FUNNY ABSOLUTELY
NO RELATION TO LITTLE BIT
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS SB NINE THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER ONE FIFTY
NINETY ONE ZERO PEOPLE INCLUDES.
IT'S INSURANCE AGENCY WITH SAN
FRANCISCO I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE LINE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI BOTH OF YOUR BACK
ALL CONCEIVABLY REPRESENTING
VENTURA COUNTY GETTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE. ONE NINETY
GO AND FIX. YEAH THIS IS MARCUS
LEVINE OF A CALLING FROM
ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE. AND LINE
NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE OPEN LARA.
IT HAS TO BE IN THE OPPOSITION
TO. RE QUEUEING AROUND THE NAY
CALL PROPOSITION PLEASE. I'M
NINETY TWO BUT IF YOU WANT TO
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
DECKER I UP CAPITAL AND- AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
ONE FORTY SIX YEAR OLD WILLIAMS
I'M SORRY ONE ONE FORTY SIX IS
STILL ON THE LINE ONE SIXTY
FOUR. YEAR OLD WILL AT LEAST-
MY COMMENTED OPPOSITION ARE WE
STILL ON SUPPORT. YOU WILL BE
Q. WILL RECALL PROPOSITION
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT WE'RE
PUTTING SOME MORE. ONE SECOND
GET TO COME IN WELL- BUT
RESPONDED. ONE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YEAR OPEN GOING TO. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE. ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINES OPEN. THREE THANK
YOU SIR. YEAH MY NAME IS FOR
HIM REPRESENTING- RECALL
COLLECTED UNITS SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL DEMOCRATS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE. YES I'M
CALLING FROM THE SENATE
DISTRICT NUMBER SIXTY SIX IS A
RETIRED TORRANCE RESIDENT AND
WITH TO THAT WHICH DESTROYS
THEIR SINGLE FAMILY LIVING
THANK YOU. PLEASE RE QUEUE WHEN
THEY CALL PROPOSITIONS. WELL TO
ALIGN SIXTY NINE NINE SIX NINE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI THERE MY
NAME IS THE POSSIBLE AND I'M
CALLING FROM WHAT KIND OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT HE
NINE R. MINDRE ALTHOUGH CALLING
OPPOSITION PARTIES ON TO
YOURSELF THAT WE MAKE THE THANK
YOU. WELL WE'VE GOT A FEW LEFT
COULD NOT BE LINGERING FROM
BEFORE BUT WE'LL TRY AT ONE
SIXTY FOUR. YOUR OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY FOUR NO
RESPONSE ONE FIFTEEN GO HEAD.
SORRY CARRY ON I'M OPPOSITION.
ADELINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY. ONE TWENTY FIVE
OAKLAND OAKLAND PLEASE. ON.
TWENTY FIVE. AT ONE THIRTY
EIGHT- OPEN ONE PLEASE. YES ROB
NIELSEN COLORADO CONCERT FOR
EVERYONE AND CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE THANK YOU. THE LINE
TENURE LINES OPEN. BLANTON GO
AHEAD PLEASE. I THINK ANY
OPPOSITION LINE PLEASE PLEASE
RE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION. ONE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX YEAR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD OF. ONE ONE
TWENTY SIX. OPPOSITION OKAY
MOVING ON THE LINE ONE SIXTY
NINE IS OUR LAST ONE IN Q. ONE
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH THIS IS OUR OFFICE
ON PHONE WITH SANTA CRUZ
BECAUSE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN THE CHERNOBYL THE
Q. CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL NOW GO. TO OPT TO SB NINE-
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPONENTS LISTED SO WE WILL NOW
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION TO- SB
NINE SAYING NINE- WE WILL THEN
GO TO AND I SAID TWENTY FORTY
EARLIER I THINK IT IS ROOM ONE
TWELVE CORRECT ONE TWELVE- I
SEE NO ONE- THERE WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE ASK
OPPONENTS OF SB NINE TO QUEUE
UP AND AGAIN PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND YOUR
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL. HELLO
TO THE GERMAN ONCE AGAIN TO OF
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AT THIS
POINT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. THERE WILL NOT A
LINE NUMBER. EIGHT BILLION YOUR
OPENING WILL HAVE TO USE. YEAH
ARE RECALL WITH LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA SB NINE IS NOT A
DUPLEX WILL SIX OR MORE UNITS
BY INCLUDING EIGHT MANSIONS
WERE ONE HOME USED TO BE
SPECULATOR DURING THE WILL
DISPLAYED STABLE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WE OPPOSE SB NINE. THANK
YOU. PUT ME ON A LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO CATHERINE EUREKA THE
WOODLAND BLACK HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND WITH UNITED
NEIGHBORS. STRONGLY OPPOSE FOR
THE REASONS MENTIONED BY THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY LINES OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE VALERIE HIGHLIGHTED WITH
LITTLE CALIFORNIAN UNITED ARAB
NEIGHBORS STRONGLY OPPOSE. THE
LINE TWENTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ALL ONE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINES OPEN. HELLO IN. TO
ALLOW. TWENTY FIVE. I EIGHT CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
AHEAD PLEASE OKAY I WASN'T SURE
ABOUT MY NUMBER OKAY HIGH AND
FROM LOS ANGELES AND GEOGHEGAN
I'M WITH FRANKLIN COURT OF
COMMUNITIES- WE SUPPORT THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT LOS ANGELES
CHIEF LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
SENATOR BEN ALLEN UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN THE REPUBLIC
CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER FOUR DOUBLE
IN THIS BILL IT WILL BE DO
NOTHING TO HELP OUR EXTREMELY.
DESPERATE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESS CRISIS IT
WILL CAUSE MORE DISPLACEMENT
AND GENTRIFICATION THE WHOLE
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA RIGHT NOW. ONE
NUMBER THIRTY YEAR OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS TERRY
DIPPEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE LOS FORGIVENESS MALIBU
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. THE LINE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GOING ON. THIRTY
NINE YEAR OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
OF. BUT WITH THE LINE NUMBER
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN BUT
POLICE. ARE NOT ONE MILLION SO
THIS BILL THIS BILL ACTUALLY
WILL EXASPERATED ARE ISSUED
WITH NATURAL RESOURCES AND DOES
NOTHING TO HELP PEOPLE AT HOME
OWNERSHIP. THE LINE THIRTEEN
YEAR OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
MY NAME IS AMY GET THEM THINK
I'M PRESIDENT OF THE L. O. BY A
AND LOS ANGELES AND ALSO PART
OF THE UNITED NEIGHBORS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY FOUR WELL INCLUDES.
I'M SURE OKAY TO REPRESENTING
THE CITY OF RANCHO SANTA
MARGARITA CALIFORNIA AND ITS
CITY COUNCIL A FIFTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB NINE. ONE ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY LINES OPEN WANNA
PLEASE THIS IS DAN NORDBERG
FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR
SUCCESSFUL COMMUNITIES AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS. THE LINE
ONE OWN NINE YEAR OLD CANNELLA.
ERICA DAHLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY'S. STANTON AND HALF MOON
BAY IN OPPOSING AMENDED
POSITION AS OUTLINED LETTER AS
WELL AS SHOULD BE JAILED WHERE
CHINO HILLS WITH BEACH MISSION
VIEJO AND OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE TEN. COLLEGES
UNDERLYING ALTERING YOUR OPEN
WHERE. I'M GOING TO ALL
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
FRANKLIN ONE OF THE TOP HOUSING
PRODUCERS IN THE STATE AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE.
LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY SHOT BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
OPPOSITION AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA
THEY HAVE AN APPROACH
ATTRIBUTES. OF THE SHIP THANK
YOU. BLIND NUMBER ONE FORTY
EIGHT WEEKS. OKAY- HELLO YES
YOU OPEN YOUR MIND MORE HAVING
VERY GOOD THANK YOU CONSERVE
ENERGY GELS PRIVATE CITIZENS
AND HOMEOWNER FROM US AND YOU
CALIFORNIA GOING TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE TACKLE LOCAL
DEMOCRACY. AND SELF GOVERNMENT
THANK YOU. HELLO LITTLE AND
ONES FOUR BIT PLEASE. ONE SIXTY
FOUR. BUT. ONE SIXTY FOUR LINES
OPEN- IN. GOING ON A LOT OF THE
ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE ONE SIXTY
FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO.
HELLO I WAS TRYING TO SPEAK UP
AND SAY THAT I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THAT BELONG TO GREATER FAIRFAX
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION PLUS
ABOUT EIGHT OTHER GROUPS THAT.
OPPOSE THIS BUILD UP WITH NOT
BOUGHT OUT AND DOES NOT HELP
THE MIDDLE CLASS SUCCESSFUL
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET RID OF AND
HAS NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
THERE IS NO ONE FOUR SMITH FOR
THE FEW HOUSING THAT THEY HAVE
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING. ONE NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR YOUR OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI I'M CORALLINE
FIREBOX BELMONT CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE BEFORE
YOU BOTH TODAY STOP AND THINK
ABOUT THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS YOU
WILL HAVE ON ALL THE CITY'S-YOUR PARTICULAR DISTRICT
REPRESENTS IN PARTICULAR
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE BEAUTIFUL
CITY OF HEALDSBURG CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. WELL NUMBER ONE-
CAREER OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN FLANAGAN
PRESIDENT OF REDWOOD TO
HOMEOWNERS LISTED AT THE
STATION ALL THE MEMBERS UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA. WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE LEGISLATION AND NOW WHERE
THE DATA IS THAT THE COURT HAS
TRICKLE DOWN THEORY. HELLO
ALLOWED TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS BARBARA BRADY REPRESENTING
WHAT WITHOUT THE NUMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO IT BEING NINE AND
WISH THAT THE LEGISLATORS WOULD
STOP THROWING SPAGHETTI ON THE
WALL TO SEE WHAT STICKS INSTEAD
TRULY LOOK AT THE ROOT CAUSE OF
THE NEEDS FOR AFFORDABLE AND
WORKFORCE HOUSING INSTEAD OF
GIVING DEVELOPERS GIVEAWAYS OF
LAND. THANK YOU. MISTER
MODERATOR. ON YES SIR MISTER I
HAVE BEEN A FLEXIBLE WITH THE
OPPONENTS AND MAKING STATEMENTS
SO FAR BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
LEAD WITNESS- AND SO I'VE ALLOW
THEM A LITTLE MORE LATITUDE BUT
I THINK WE'RE AT THE FOUR
MINUTE MARK IN TERMS OF. SOME
OF THESE LONGER STATEMENTS AND
SO GOING FORWARD- AND I DID
THAT TRIP TO TRY TO JUST BE
FAIR AND EQUITABLE- GOING
FORWARD- I DO WANT TO ENFORCE-
NAME AFFILIATION AND-
OPPOSITION. THE TERM. YES SIR
MR SURELY THE GERMAN WHEN YOUR
NUMBER IS CALLED STATE YOUR
NAME POLLUTION FOR LEGISLATIVE
RECORD PROCEED WITH YOUR
COMMENT PLEASE WILL MOVE ON THE
HELPLINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY THREE
WE ARE OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
HOLDEN I AM A MEMBER OF LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA UNITED NEIGHBORS AND
I'M ALSO IN THE ARMENIAN PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA- PLEASE-
DO NOT VOTE FOR SB NINE. THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR THANK YOU YOUR
OPPOSITION IS NOTED. GO ONLINE
FORTY SEVEN GOING AT LEAST
FORTY SEVEN. ONE FORTY SEVEN
YEAR OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
BROWN CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE THE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE
FOR THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED SB NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CERTAINLY
BUT I LINE FIFTY FOUR YEAR OPEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. FIFTY FOUR GO
AHEAD HI GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BALKANS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY TWENTY ONE CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WON'T WITH
THE CITY BUT I WILL SAY THEY'RE
ALL LISTED IN THE COMMITTEE NOT
THIS EXCEPT FOR- ONE WHICH IS
THE CITY OF LAMESA AND THEY'RE
ALL OPPOSE. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER ONE NINETEEN PLEASE. ONE
NINETEEN YEAR OLD LAWYER PLEASE.
WE WOULD LINE SIXTY THREE LINE
SIXTY THREE YEAR OLD VOTER
PLEASE. HI CHRISTINE GUERRERO
WITH THAT LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DIVISION OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO A MUCH NEEDED AND WE
ARE WORKING WITH OUR- FROM THE
COMMANDMENT THANK YOU. NUMBER
SIXTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
CANISTOTA CHECK WITH
CALIFORNIAN VISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY ONE YEAR OLD GOING ON.
THIS IS RAY LAW GROUP WITH
CATALYST AND I OPPOSE SB NINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TO
ONE THIRTY TO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
SAN BERNARDINO THIRTIETH IN
HIGH FIRE COUNTRY OPPOSE. ONE
ONE THIRTY SIX BILLION. I
DIDN'T BEYOND THAT'S DOOR I
REPRESENT THE ALLIANCE FOR A
BETTER BRAND GOOD I AM FROM
BRENTWOOD NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. NINE
ONE ONE SEVENTY TWO GO AHEAD
PLEASE JOIN OPEN. ONE SEVEN TWO
PLEASE. WE ARE NOT ALONE NUMBER.
ONE SEVENTY SIX ONE SEVENTY SIX
YEAR OLD WOMAN PLEADS. GOOD
MORNING THAT ROBERTS DID A CALL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE OF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
ON SB NINE. THE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SIX Gí
SIX FAILED BOB ONE NUMBER.
EIGHTY SIX YOUR OPEN WATER
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CARE
MEMBERS HUTCHINGS REPRESENTING
THE CITY TO BELMONT FOSTER CITY
USED FAILING CORONA IN
OPPOSITION. ONE NINETY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. JOSEPH HAVE BEEN
ON BEHALF OF THE GRANT WOULD
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION THIS IS
AN AREA OF WEST LOS ANGELES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- STRONGLY
OPPOSE FROM THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY NOTED PLUS WE DO NOT
AGREE AND ACROSS THE BOARD
ZONING. FROM THE SENATE. LINE
NINETY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE
YOU WANT OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS
MIKE STRESS CAN THE BOARD
PRESIDENT OF TROPICAL ISLAND
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
CONSISTING OF EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETEEN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY OUR BOARD
IS TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE. THANK
YOU. ONE ONE FORTY THREE WEEKS
A MAJOR SETBACK RIVIERA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND IT'S
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED HOMEOWNERS
AND MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS
ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL IN A
STATE OF THIS SIZE AND
DIVERSITY TRYING A FEW CITIES
INTO A PETRI DISH BEFORE
FORCING THIS ON THE ENTIRE
STATE AND PLEASE PEOPLE READ
THE LANGUAGE THERE IS NO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL WHATSOEVER THANK YOU
PLEASE OPPOSE STRONGLY. ONE ONE
NINETEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOING ON. HELLO BUT YOU GO
AHEAD YES KYLE THIS YEAR'S
GENERAL CONTRACTORS STUDIO CITY
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB NINE BASED ON INFRASTRUCTURE
AVAILABILITY AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE OWNING SHOULD REMAIN LOCAL.
NUMBER TWO ONE ONE TWENTY ONE
ONE TWENTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
IT'S A SHERIN MEMBERS REMAINED
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE ONE
SEVENTY THREE OPEN GOING ON.
FIVE SEVEN CANDLE FROM THE CITY
OF LAFAYETTE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EVEN AFTER AMENDMENT IT
IS A SIX UNIT NOT A DUPLEX BILL
WITHOUT ANY AFFORDABLE
COMPONENTS AND WE OPPOSE. ONE
ONE SEVENTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ONE SEVEN NINE RUNS
OPEN. LINDA LINE ONE. SEVENTY
ONE SEVENTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO THIS IS PATRICIA MATTHEWS
FROM WESTLAKE VILLAGE
CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT OF THE
FIRST NEIGHBORHOOD HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE I WOULD REQUEST TO CARVE
OUT FOR C. I. D. THANK YOU. AND
THAT'S WHERE THE LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN. ONE MOMENT WORLD
THREE ONE EIGHTEEN NINE
EIGHTEEN YOU'RE NOT OPEN GOING
T BECOME. YEAH IT IS IT JUST
ME. THIS IS YOU THIS BOB HOLLY
OSBORNE A RESIDENT OF REDONDO
BEACH I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
NINE THANK YOU. EXCELLENT. ONE
EIGHTY ONE ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE
YEAR OLD VEHICLES. GOOD MORNING
CHRIS POWER ACTIVITY BARGES
REPRESENTING FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SIXTY EIGHT OKLAHOMA.
HI MY NAME IS MARCY. GORDON
FROM HIS HOUSE TODAY WE IS THE
ONLY AND I REPEAT WOOD MISTER
O'NEILL FOR THE TRACK BECAUSE
HOUSING BILLS IT'S NOT THAT IT
IS IT IS IT WAS. AND AN INSULT
THAT FOR THE UNFAMILIAR I'M
INCOME HOMEOWNERS WORE GREEN
REALLY HARD BLOW FOR ITS FAMILY
HOME PLEASE VOTE ALL OF THIS
THE NINE THANK YOU. I'LL GO
ONLINE NUMBER FIFTY LINE COULD
NORTH. MISTER CHAIRMAN ON THE I
MEAN A NUMBER OF THE ABOUT CITY
DOUBLE LIVERMORE PLEASANTON CA
RAMON AND THE TOWN OF DAM AS
WELL AS THE CITY OF LOS AT HOW
WELL THOUGH AND TO IN. OF THE
THANK. WE ON THE LINE FORTY TWO
WE WILL PLEASE. THANK YOU THIS
IS YOUR TO WORK ON THE BOARD
AND FOR TREES. BUT WE STRONG
OPPOSE BECAUSE IT. EASY OUR
SCREEN. AND ALL OF OUR OTHER
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURES. NOW
LINEUP SIX SO ONE SIXTY SIX BOB
ONE NUMBER ONE TWO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE AB YEAR OLD LOW AT
SIX. HELLO MY PEOPLE BY FROM
CAL- WITH A MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR A BETTER PLAN
WOOD- WE DO NOT WANT TO ONE
SIDE BOB PLEASE THE PUBLIC
THANK YOU. JUST I'M NOT GOING
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX YEAR OLD
BOY. PEOPLE FRIDAY MATTHEW THEN
FINALLY OUT WITH THEM ON A GO
FORWARD WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING. THE REAL ONE
SIZE FITS ALL THANK YOU. ONE
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN ONE HUNDRED
ONE IS OPEN. YEAH DALY CAN TANA
WOULD BE PROUD COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PARK IN OPPOSITION.
THEN WE HAVE ONE LAST ONE
QUEUING AND BE JUST A QUICK
MOMENT HERE. WHAT IS A COUPLE
OF CANNELLA AND WE ARE GOING TO
GO. AND TRYLINE ONE SIXTY FOUR
YEAR OLD ONE SIXTY FOUR BUT WE
HAD TO USE. HELLO. THIS YEAR
OPENED. OKAY THANK YOU SORRY
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
NOT PLAQUES AND I'M A MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE DIRECTOR FOR THE
LARGE MADERA RANCH MAINTENANCE
CORPORATION EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
HUNDRED HOME H. AWAY IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND I RESPECTFULLY BUT
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE UNLESS
MANDATE TO CARVE OUT AN
EXCEPTION FOR HOAS. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR NEXT
YEAR OPEN BUT SINCE. ALL. ONE
ONE SIXTY A GO AHEAD PLEASE. WE
WILL ALIGN ONE SEVENTY NINE ONE
SEVENTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE ATTITUDE MATT REGAN
CALLING FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL APOLOGIES FOR SPEAKING
OUT OF ORDER FOR SOME REASON I
WASN'T CALLED DURING SUPPORT
BUT THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB NINE THANK
YOU. ONE THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD
GOOGLE INCLUDES. ONE THIRTY
NINE BILLION. THE LINE SIXTY
SIX SIXTY SIX KEEPS FAILING.
ONE SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING RECALL ON BEHALF
OF THE PEOPLE OF ONTARIO
OPPOSITION SB NINE THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FOURTEEN MILLION
BELIEVES. SAN MARCOS AND RUN
COUNTY COUNCIL. MEMBERS. THIS I
APOLOGIZE FOR SPEAKING OUT OF
ORDER I WAS UNABLE TO JOIN
EARLIER I'M CALLING AT THE PORT
ON BEHALF OF WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE TO ENJOY MY NAME IS TO
BE MARSHON. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
NINETY SIX EUROPEN GONNA. JERRY
WILLIAMS WHAT THAT NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL AND ONE STANDS ONE
SENTRY BLAND H. AWAY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. NINE ONE
ONE NINETY NINE YEAR OLD GO
AHEAD PLEASE. FOR CALLING IN
LATE THIS IS ROBERT PROGRAMS
HAPPENS EMB AND THANK YOU.
LITERATURE REVIEW OF A COUPLE
AT A LATE ONE SECURING WOMAN
PLEASE. NUMBER TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU SO WE CAN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TRICIA CRANE I'M CHAIR OF
NORTHEAST NEIGHBORS AND
REPRESENTING SEVERAL
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATIONS PROUD
THAT SANTA MONICA CITY COUNCIL
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY. TO OPPOSE SB
NINE BECAUSE IT DOES NOT HELP
WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU YOUR OPPOSITION IS NOTED.
THE LION TO PULL ONE OF YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS
NORMAL BECAUSE MONTH FROM NASA
I AM WITH NAPA FOR NEW
NEIGHBORS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT PLEASE VOTE YES. ON SB
NINE THANK YOU. I'M NOT A LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
TWO OR THREE YEAR OLD IS GONNA.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THIS IS. AN I WASN'T ABLE TO
GET ONLINE NUMBER. I'M WEBER ST.
HE AND WE ARE SUPPORTERS THANK
THANK YOU THISFOR ALL THANK
YOU. WHY THAT THANK YOU. SORRY
ABOUT THAT WERE CUT OFF LINE
FOR EIGHT YEAR OLD WHO WAS
PLEASE. I AM THROUGH THE NOT
AND I IN GRAHAM WAITING BECAUSE
CON COSTA CAN. AND I AM VERY
MUCH OF TO NINE THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO MORE THAN A FIVE LINES IN Q.
PROPOSITIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
BRING US THREE NINE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- COLLEAGUES ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON S.
B. NINE SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU QUESTIONS OF FOR A SENATOR.
ATKINS IT APPEARS THAT THE
OPPOSITION TO. THE BILL MIGHT
BE BETTER ADDRESSED WITH SOME
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ASKED FOR AND I'D LIKE TO.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES I CAN
SORRY TO HAVE MY BACK TO YOU
BUT- IT'S OKAY CIRCUMSTANCES
HERE BUT- I'D LIKE TO JUST PULL
UP A FEW THESE AMENDMENTS AND
SEE IF YOU'RE WORKING ON THEM-
ONE IS TO CLARIFY THAT A
PROPERTY OWNER SING SB NINE IS
LIMITED TO CONSTRUCTING TO
RESIDENTIAL UNIFIED THINK
THERE'S AN INTERPRETATION THAT.
AND WE HEARD THAT WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND MANY MORE COULD
ACTUALLY BEGIN BE CONSTRUCTED.
ON RESIDENTIAL ALL LOTS
DEPENDING ON HOW THE SPLIT
GOES. UP A LEVEL OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REQUIRE ATTIC AT
ADEQUATE ACCESS FOR POLICE FIRE
AND OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
VEHICLES AND EQUIPMENT. THAT IS
OF PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE TO ME
BECAUSE I WAS VERY MUCH A PART
OF. DEVELOPMENT IN SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY- IN MY EARLY DAYS ON. IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAND TO- AS
WE CAME THROUGH THAT PERIOD OF
THE COUNTY GOVERNMENT REQUIRED
INCLUSIONARY ZONING AND
AFFORDABLE UNITS TO BE PART OF
A PLANNED COMMUNITY PLANS. IN
IN DOING THAT TO THE LOT SIZES
FOR THE SINGLE FAMILIES. WERE
REDUCED TO- AND THE- HOUSING
WAS DEVELOPED ON CUL DE SACS.
WITH NO PARKING REQUIREMENT
WHICH IS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I
THINK I'VE RAISED ON ALL THE
DENSIFICATION OF. LEGISLATION
HAS BEEN PRESENTED YOU HAVE.
PARKING ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
STREET OUR SAFETY VEHICLES BE
THAT. FOR POLICE FIRE AND OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY VEHICLES WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF FLOODS. THEY
COULDN'T GET DOWN THE STREET.
SO IT'S ALWAYS. HEY A
RESTRICTED PARKING HONEST IN A
YOU HAVE A BUILDING FOR NOW.
DUPLEX WHERE YOU ONE PARKING
SPACE THIS EVEN A GARAGE IF
YOU'VE ENTERED SOME SIGNIFICANT
SAFETY ISSUES INTO EXISTING
COMMUNITIES- THEY'VE ALSO.
FOCUSED ON ALLOWING CITIES TO
DETERMINE THE RANGE OF LOT
SIZES THERE'S UNDEVELOPED LAND.
MUCH CONVERSION GOING ON
BECAUSE OF THE DOWN. TURN IN
THE ECONOMY AND SOME OF THE
ROOM THE- COMMERCIAL AREAS ARE
NOW BEING CITED FOR-
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT IN THE
CITY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT BEFORE THIS IS A
MANDATE. ON EVERY SINGLE FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL. PROJECT IN IN
THEIR CITY IT SAYS- ALSO- WILL
THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION CREDIT BEING GIVEN
TO THE PRODUCTION OF S. B. NINE
UNITS I THINK THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IF WE ARE TRYING TO
MEET. HOUSING GOALS- ONE ONE
FIFTY AN ORANGE COUNTY IS
EXECTED TO ALMOST DOUBLE THE
SIZE OF THEIR CITY. BASED ON
THE READING ALLOCATIONS THAT
CAME OUT AS GAY. THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT ARE NOT BEING.
LOOKED AT VERY CAREFULLY SHOULD
BE BEFORE THIS FINALLY YOU KNOW
BILLS FOR A FINAL APPROVAL. I
THINK THAT MOST IMPORTANT TO ME
AND I MENTIONED IT EVERY TIME
AND I'LL. GO BACK TO IT-
PROBABLY MISS AND- THE TIME I
SPOKE ABOUT SAN. INCOME ARE
ESSENTIAL. OF DEPOSED WITH THE
GREATEST AGGRAVATION AND I
THINK IMPACT TO SAFETY THAT WE
SEE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND IF
YOU SAT ON THE CITY COUNCIL. OR
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
I HAVE AS I HAVE. MANY MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE BROUGHT TO
US BY CONSTITUENTS HAVE A LOT
TO DO WITH PEOPLE WHO ABUSE THE
PARKING. PARKING PEOPLE'S
SPACES THEY PARK IN FRONT OF
THEIR DRIVEWAYS AND THEY ALSO
PARK MANY THE STREETS LEAD TO
OUR SCHOOLS AT THE PARK- AND
KIDS ARE MOVING. BACK AND FORTH.
OUR STREETS AS WE KNOW NOT
ALWAYS FOLLOWING THE CROSSING
GUARDS AND- THAT IS RESULTING
IN A COUPLE TRAGEDY SO. FAR
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS TO BE LOOKING
AT WHEN WE ARE DOWN TO FIND. IN
A RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES SO I
HOPE YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE A
LOOK A THAT- AND- WITHOUT. YOU
KNOW OF SERIOUS CONSIDERATION
ABOUT I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT I WILL
LEAVE THAT TO YOU. SENATOR
ATKINS TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT NUMBER
THEM THANK YOU- WE'VE HAD. OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS-
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS ON THE
NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES AND HAVE
TAKEN. OF COURSE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS- A NUMBER OF THEM IN
PARTICULAR. I I'VE TRIED TO BE
CLEAR HI IT WAS IN THE
PREVIOUS- BILL. SB ELEVEN
TWENTY WE HAVE RE CLARIFIED IT
WITH AN AMENDMENT IN THIS BILL.
WHICH SAYS FOUR UNITS. FOUR
UNITS AT. A PARCEL SPLIT. A
DUPLEX AND END THE SPLIT. TWO
UNITS ON THE OTHER SPLIT. SO
FOR WE HAVE CLARIFIED THAT
FURTHER- IN TERMS OF PARKING AS
SOMEONE WHO ALSO COMES OUT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVE SPENT.
WAY HE- MANY MANY HOURS AT
COMMUNITY PLANNING COMMITTEES
AND PLANNING COMMISSIONS AND AS
A COUNCIL MEMBER- I UNDERSTAND
THE ISSUE OF PARKING WE HAVE WE
HAVE CERTAINLY WORKED. OUT TO
CREATE A BALANCE THERE IS ONE A
PARKING UNIT R. ONE PARKING
SPACE PER UNIT. SO IF YOU'RE
TALKING FOUR UNITS- A DUPLEX
THAT YOU KNOW FOUR UNITS TOTAL
YOU'VE GOT FOR PARKING SPACES.
UNLESS YOU ARE NEAR HIGH
TRANSIT AREAS IN WHICH- YOU CAN
GET- OUT LESS PARKING BECAUSE
OF THE PROXIMITY. OF TRANSIT-
SO THIS- PIECE OF LEGISLATION
REALLY FOCUSES ON URBANIZED
AREAS TO CREATE- DENSITY TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING PRODUCTION
ISSUE- YOU MENTIONED FIRE
ACCESS I WOULD SAY. I JUST
WANNA POINT OUT THE OTHER ISSUE
WHICH IS OUTLINED NOT ONLY IN
THE BILL BUT OF COURSE IN THE
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. IS
HIGH FIRE ZONES- SO THOSE ARE
DID THE DEVELOPMENT IS
PROHIBITED PROHIBITED AND HI
FIRESTONE'S UNLESS A LOCAL
JURISDICTION WAYS AND- SO THIS
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
INTENDED. TO BE A PARTNER
COLLABORATIVE WITH. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND TO STRIKE THAT
BALANCE SO WE CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT ISSUES- ANY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS. IS GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE- A
CONVERSATION WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE THAT SPOKE IN SUPPORT
AND IN OPPOSITION. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK- AS WE DID
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR- AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD SO I DO
APPRECIATE. THE CONTEXT AND THE
EXPERIENCE FROM WHICH HE
QUESTIONS COM. I THINK AND HOPE
I ADDRESSED BY AS MUCH OF THAT
AS I COULD. THANK YOU I CENTERS
SKINNER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR PRO
TEM ATKINS FOR HER WORK ON THIS
BILL HER WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENTS THE AMENDMENTS THAT
SHE HAS MADE IT NOT ONLY. LAST
YEAR- BUT AGAIN NOW THAT IT'S
COME BEFORE US THE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
AND THAT SHE USED FOR HER
WILLINGNESS TO BRING IT BACK TO
US TO ME THIS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT POLICY. AND I
APPRECIATE THE HOUSING
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS WHICH GAVE
I THINK SOME OF THE REALLY
SALIENT POINTS- FOR EXAMPLE
INDICATING THAT. WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ADD. UP TO EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW UNITS JUST
BY NEW HOUSING UNITS JUST BY.
ALLOWING ADDITIONAL UNITS ON
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND NOW
DESTINATION IS NOT BASED ON
PUTTING IN YOU KNOW BIG
APARTMENT COMPLEXES AT ON THE
LOTS OF MULTI FAMILY HOMES BUT
RATHER FOR THE TYPE OF VERY
MODERATELY DENSE HOUSING THAT
THIS BILL IS RECOMMENDING. WE
KNOW THAT WE ARE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION UNITS AT MINIMUM SHORT
IN CALIFORNIA MEETINGS THAT WE
HAVE THAT'S HOW MANY UNITS WE
NEED TO NOT BE IN THIS HOUSING
CRISIS- THE OTHER THING THAT
THE ANALYSIS POINTED OUT IS
THAT MORE MODERATELY DENSE
HOUSING OF THE TYPE THAT WOULD
BE PUT FORWARD IN THIS BILL WAS
THE NORM IT WAS THE NORM THAT
WAS OUR NORMAL HOUSING PATTERN
UP UNTIL THE FIFTIES AND
SIXTIES IT BEGAN TO SLOW DOWN
THEN IN THE SEVENTIES TO THE
POINT. WHERE SINCE THE
SEVENTIES WE HAVE DONE VERY
LITTLE. CONSTRUCTION OF THIS
SORT. AND IT IS PARTLY THOSE
FOR DECADES. THAT ARE WHY WE'RE
IN THIS CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN
TODAY. NOW ADDITIONALLY I THINK
MOST OF US UNDERSTAND MUCH
BETTER. WHY WHAT WAS THE ORIGIN
OF SINGLE FAMILY ZONING AND HOW
ITS ORIGINS REALLY NOT
SOMETHING WE CAN GREATLY BE
PROUD OF AND I SEE THAT AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE BERKELEY MY
HOMETOWN. WHERE WE WERE THE
FIRST CITY TO REVIEW OR THE
VERY VERY FIRST CITY IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS TO
DEVELOP THIS CONCEPT OF SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING AND ARE PLANNING
DOCUMENTS ARE CITY'S OWN
DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT IT WAS
EXPLICITLY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
RACIAL EXCLUSION. SO WHILE IT
MAY NO LONGER BE THAT
INTENTIONAL. IT IS STILL THE
RESULT AND WHEN WE LOOK AT MAPS
ARE SINGLE FAMILY ZONES NOW
EQUAL THE SAME. DATE IN TERMS
OFDEMOGRAPHICS LOOK JUST LIKE
IF WE PUT A REDLINING MAP SO
THIS IS ONE WAY TO CORRECT THAT
IT MAY NOT BUT AT LEAST IT
WOULD ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
SHORTAGE. ADDITIONAL THING IT
WOULD DO IS THAT WE'RE RIGHT
NOW AT THE LOWER LOWEST RATE
OWNER OCCUPIED HOME OWNERSHIP
CALIFORNIA'S AT SLOWEST RATE
SINCE THE NINETEEN FORTIES AND
OF COURSE OUR HOMEOWNERSHIP WAS
GREATLY REDUCED DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION. AND IT IS VERY
POSSIBLE THAT IN THE SEARCH IN.
SUCH CONSTRUCTION LIKE THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW THE UNITS
WOULD BE MORE AFFORDABLE. THAN
BRAND NEW UNITS IN BRAND NEW-
DEVELOPMENTS EXTERNAL TO AN
URBAN AREA THAT NEED WHERE YOU
NEED TO BUILD IN THE COST OF
ALL NEW INFRASTRUCTURE AND
LARGE THERE WOULD MOST LIKELY
BE FAR LARGER SQUARE FOOTAGE
INSECTS. SO IT'S VERY POSSIBLE
THAT THIS COULD ALSO EXPAND
HOME OWNERSHIP BECAUSE THESE
UNITS MAY BE. AT A LOWER PRICE
POINT PER SQUARE FOOT THAN SOME
OTHER UNITS- I THINK THE LAST
THING I WANTED TO RACE IS THE-
THEY'RE BOTH SOME OF THE
SPEAKERS WHO CALLED BUT ALSO
THE ANALYSIS AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. QUALITY
COMMITTEES- RESPONSE AROUND THE
SEAPORT ISSUE. AND I GIVEN THE
MODEST NATURE OF WHAT THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS PROPOSING. I
THINK THE MUCH MORE GREATER.
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE TO WAY ARE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPLICATIONS ARE
REFUSAL TO BUILD HOUSING IN ALL
THESE YEARS ESPECIALLY OUR
REFUSAL TO BUILD MORE HOUSING.
IN THOSE PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE THE CLOSEST TO THAT
ARE THE JOB CENTERS THE HELP
DESK SERVICES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SCHOOLS AND
AS A RESULT BECAUSE WE'VE NOT
ALLOWED. THE PROPRIOCEPTION OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND
HOUSING NOW IS FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY FROM JOB CENTERS
WE'VE SEEN ANY CREDIBLE
INCREASE IN THE GREENHOUSE
GASES FROM TRANSPORTATION AND
EVEN WITH OUR COMMITMENT TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES IT'S
GOING TO BE SOME TIME BEFORE WE
ACHIEVE THAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN
FARMLAND AND HABITAT HABITAT
LAST. IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE FAR GREATER
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS BEEN
ADDING A MODEST NUMBER OF UNITS
TO EXISTING NEIGHBORHOODS- SO
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE PRO
TEM FOR BRINGING THIS BILL. AND
I WOULD NOTE THE ANALYSIS SHOWS
THAT THERE'S A COUPLE OF-
COMMUNITIES MOSTLY IT
REFERENCES MINNEAPOLIS BUT WE
NOW HAVE A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES THAT ARE BEGINNING TO RE
LOOKING QUESTION THEIR OWN
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING INCLUDING
MY OWN CITY OF BERKELEY WHICH
IS RECENTLY PASSED. A
RESOLUTION TO REZONING TO ALLOW
SOMETHING VERY COMPARABLE TO
WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED HERE-
ENTITY PROPRIA TIME. I'M HAPPY
TO MOVE THIS- OF THIS BILL.
WILL TAKE A AS A MOTION A
CALLER SENATOR QUESTIONS OR.
OKAY SCENE NINE- SO I WANT TO
THANK- THE PRO TEM FOR
PERSEVERING ON THIS BILL AFTER
THE- THERE WAS A BUMP IN THE
ROAD AT THE END OF SESSION.
LAST YEAR THIS IS A VERY.
IMPORTANT BILL- IN- IN HELPING
US TO SOLVE CALIFORNIA'S
DRAMATIC HOUSING CRISIS.
HOUSING SHORTAGE THAT IS
PUSHING PEOPLE INTO
HOMELESSNESS AND POVERTY
PUSHING YOUNG FAMILIES AND
WORKING FAMILIES OUT. AND THIS
WILL BE A GOOD STOP- IN THE
DIRECTION SOLVING THE CRISIS-
WE KNOW THAT HYPER RESTRICTIVE-
WALKED DOWN ZONING- REDUCES
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. IT
INCREASES RACIAL SEGREGATION
AND IT INCREASES CLIMATE CHANGE
BY PUSHING PEOPLE IN THE LONG
COMMUTES- IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
S. THIS MORNING THERE WAS A
GREAT ARTICLE IN USA TODAY.
THAT TALKS ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN
THE CONTEXT OF PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S- HOUSING- PROPOSAL. AND
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
ZONING REFORM IS THAT IT IS NOT
A PARTISAN ISSUE. FIVE IN THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE IN THIS
BODY WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD- A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
BIPARTISAN OPPOSITION THAT
DOESN'T SPLIT ALONG PARTY
LINES. PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
ADVOCATING FOR ZONING REFORM
PRESIDENT OBAMA ADVOCATED FOR
ZONING REFORM. AND BEFORE I GOT
TO AN ELECTION YEAR PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS ADVOCATING. FOR
ZONING REFORM- THIS IS GOOD
GOVERNMENT IT'S OVERDUE- AND I
AM RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE ON
SB NINE- MADAM CONSULTED CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. G. MY
APOLOGIES TIME THANK YOU I WILL
BE VERY QUICK LOOK I THINK THIS
ABOUT HOUSING FOR AND
AFFORDABILITY AND NOW MORE AND
MORE A DISCUSSION OF LOOKING AT
IT THROUGH A AND EQUITY LANDS
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO
WOR THEIR WAY INTO- THE DREAM
OF HOME OWNERSHIP. THIS IS ONE
OF THE DIALOGUES OF OUR DAY IT
WAS THAT WAY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC- THE PANDEMIC HAS
FURTHER EXACERBATED ISSUES
AROUND THE NEED TO BE HOUSED
APPROPRIATELY AND SO THIS
REALLY IS A VERY RELEVANT
DIALOGUE THAT WE ARE ALL
ENGAGED IN AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
CONTINUED TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. THIS BILL MAY HAVE MY
NAME ON IT BUT IT HAS BEEN THE
PRODUCT OF NUMEROUS
DISCUSSIONS- OBVIOUSLY WITH
INPUT FROM A NUMBER OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AT SIT ON THIS VERY
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS- IT COMES
OFF OF THE WORK DONE ON SB
THIRTY FIVE AS WE LOOK AT HOW
TO PROTECT- A CERTAIN AREAS-
HIGH FIRE ECCENTRIC IT BUILDS
OFF OF THE SUCCESS OF EIGHTY
USE. AND THE THOUGHTFULNESS AND
THE DATA COLLECTION AND THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING TO SEE
WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF THOSE
POLICIES ALREADY WE KNOW THAT
CITIES HAVE MOVED FORWARD OF
SEATED IN MY VERY NEIGHBORHOOD
VERY INCREDIBLE DEVELOPMENT SO
THIS IS A VERY MEAGER BILL I
KNOW THAT PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF. MISINFORMATION ABOUT
THIS BILL- AND IT COMES FROM
THE FEAR OF THE UNKNOWN AND
CHANGE BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE THOUGHTFUL IN THE MEANTIME
LET ME THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
LET ME THANK ALL OF THE PEOPLE
WHO CALLED IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND ASK
FOR RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
MADAM FOR TIME AND WE WILL NOT
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS CENTER
BILL NYE BY SOME AT. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WINNER. WINNER HI BATES WELL
BATES NO CABALLERO HI
CABALLERO. CORTESE CORTESE I'D
MCGUIRE- CHILUBA. SKINNER HI
SKINNER FIVE NUMBER NUMBER HI
KELSEY HI WOOD CASKEY I. SIX
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET UP WE'LL PUT OUR OWN
CORPORATE SOME NUMBERS THANK
YOU. OKAY WE WILL NOW. PROCEED
WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO CENTER
RUBIO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT. I WAS FOR TAKING
OUT OF ORDER I'M HAPPY TO DO
SO. ON AND SO- SENATOR RUBIO-
YOU MAY PRESENT SB SIX SEVEN
YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT. SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO FOCUS ON
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
UNACCOMPANIED. WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THIS
GROUP AS DEFINED BY FEDERAL
RULES AS A SINGLE WOMAN WITHOUT
CHILDREN OR DEPENDENTS DESPITE
MAKING UP NEARLY ONE THIRD OF
HOMELESS ADULTS STATEWIDE.
SORRY NATIONWIDE THERE ARE NO
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON THEIR
NEEDS. INSAS ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL DATA UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WILL. WAIT AN AVERAGE OF TEN
YEARS TO ACCESS STABLE HOUSING
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
80% OF THIS GROUP REPORTED
TRAUMA OR ABUSE. AS THE CAUSE
OF THEIR HOMELESSNESS SO WHEN
PEOPLE OFTEN ASK WHY DID IN THE
VICTIM LEAVE AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP. THIS IS PART OF
THE ANSWER. THEY EITHER
CONTINUE TO GET ABUSE GO OUT ON
THE STREET AND BECOME HOMELESS
THAT'S NOT MUCH OF A CHOICE SO
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP TO
SOLVING OUR HOMELESS PROBLEM IN
HAVING ACCURATE DATA ABOUT WHO
IS ON HEALTH AND WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE THIS BILL DOES
EXACTLY THAT. SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT WILL REQUIRE THE STATE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCIAL COUNSEL TO COLLECT
DATA ABOUT THIS GROUP FROM
LOCAL CONTINUANCE OF CARE AND
USE THIS DATA TO HELP SET
SPECIFIC MEASURABLE GOALS TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS
FOR THIS FORGOTTEN GROUP OF
WOMEN. FINALLY THIS BILL
COMPLIMENTS A RECENT AUDIT OF
THE HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL THAT STATES
THAT THE COUNCIL COULD BE MORE
STRATEGIC AND MORE. THE BILL IS
CO AUTHORED BY SENATOR THAT I
GET ALL SENATOR DURACELL AND A
FAMILY MEMBER SANTIAGO BY THE
SPONSOR IS DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER A HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDER LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES
GET ROAD AREA AND THIS IS A
PRIORITY BILL FOR THE L. A.
COUNTY DELEGATION. IT'S ALSO
SUPPORTED BY FORTY HOMELESS
PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND SENATE HUMAN
SERVICE COMMITTEE PASSED THIS
BILL WITH UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT TODAY WITH ME I HAVE TO
WITNESSES SUSAN COLD COLE WITH
THE FORMER UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
AMY TURK THE CEO OF DOWNTOWN'S
WOMEN'S CENTER. IF I AM I THINK
MAYBE ALLOW TO SPEAK THEY YOU
MISTER TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS RUBIO WILL NOT TO THE- LEAD
WITH- AND START WITH A METER
FROM DOWNTOWN WOMEN SO. AFTER
SENATOR- AS BEEN MENTIONING
METER KEEP EXECUTIVE ON OF THE
DOWNTOWN CENTER. WE WERE IN
NINETEEN EIGHT. AND WE STILL
REMAIN THE ONLY ORGANIZED
EXCLUDES THAT TO ENDING HOMER
AMONG WOMEN IN LOS ANGELES. THE
NATION'S FIRST PROVIDE OF
SUPPORT HOUSING FOR WOMEN DOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER A- OVER FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE WOMEN. THROUGH A
VARIETY OF. AND PERMANENT HOW.
A DROP IN ACCESS CENTER HEALTH
CLINIC HE MANAGED WORKFORCE.
THE SOCIAL. AND ONE OF THE
FIFTY TRONG RECOVERY CENTERS
THE STATE. AT THE ADVOCACY
YEARS HEALTH DOWNTOWN CENTER
MISSION TO BUILD YOU ASK THE
SIX EIGHT IS THAT. OF YEARS OF
WORK. WITH THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
ANNIKA WOMEN WHO ARE YOU. HOME
WITHOUT OR- THAT HAVE HAVE BEEN
IGNORE. BY POLICYMAKERS IN
MAINE ON OF SERVICE PROVISION.
I WOMEN BECAUSE NEARLY ONE IN
THREE OF ALL ON HOW IT ADULTS
NOW. AND THE PAST FIVE YEARS
HAVE SEEN A STAGGER TWENTY PER
AND- IN THE RATE OF HOMELESS.
YOU WILL STUDENTS POWER TESTING
ABOUT THE BARRIERS THAT ON
ACCOUNT WOMEN AS- ESPECIALLY
THE- OF DRAMATIC X. THAT THE
POPULAR PROPER FROM
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH RATES.
BY APPROVING A STORY
LEGISLATION CALPERS WILL BE
ADOPTED A POWER GENDER LINE AND
IT EFFORTS TO END. AND WE THANK
STUDENT SENATOR RUBIO FOR HER
CAMPAIGN OF THIS AND I URGE
YOUR BILL IN OF AT LEAST SEVEN
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL GO TO SEE
CALL COURTS. ALSO DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S. HELLO SENATORS- MY
NAME IS. CORRECTLY IS THE
RESULT OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ALMOST FINISHED WITH IT
INDESCRIBABLE FRIGHTENING AND
HUMILIATING EXPERIENCE AS A
WOMAN BY HERSELF I STRUGGLED
WITH ACTIVELY HOUSING IN THE
IMPORTANT SERVICES I DON'T COME
WHEN EXPERIENCE ALMOST WITHOUT
A PARTNER OR CHILD. OFTEN
FAULTED CRACKS IN OUR- IN PART
BE THEY ARE NOT ONLY PROGRAMS
AT HIM. YOU AS A SURVIVOR TO BY
I CAME UP THE HARD TRUTH AND
EXISTED NO PRO. FOR STUDENTS
SERVICES FOR WOMEN SHE THAT WE
ARE TO EXACTLY THE SAME AS MANY
THOUGH OUR- REQUIRE DIFFERENT.
THE RALLY IS THAT UNDER. WOMEN
IN IS BEAR GOOD TO FIND ANY SAY.
QUALITY HOMELESSNESS I WE HAVE
TO MAKE. DIFFERENT CHOICES
DECLINE EVEN AMONG. OF SAFETY.
SOMETIMES MEANS MAKE SURE TO
STAY WITH THEM. CAMERA IN ORDER
TO GET HIS. FROM OTHER. IN
CANDOR IS. THAT WASN'T. CHOICE
MAY. I WANT TO BE A BE. I HAD
TO MAKE IT AND DIFFERENT CHOI.
ALONG THE OF DO I SHOULD THE
DEVIL. SO IMPORTANT I
RECOGNIZING WHEN A COMPANY
WOMEN IS A UNIQUE COLLECTION
POPULATION. AND THEN USING THE
DATA TO UNDER. EACH AND
CONCERNS THAT. VOCAL WILL BE TO
MAKE PROGRESS IN THE- ONE
SAFETY. ENDING AND HOW.
STEERING CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH WE WILL NOW
GO- GENERAL COMMENT WE'RE ASK
YOU TO STAY. SIMPLY YOUR NAME
OF PHILLY OF- AND EUROPE IS ON
THE- NOW- LOOKED SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE. TO TESTIFY SUPPORT OF
THIS. AND THE SENATE CHAMBERS
SEEING NO ON- AND I ALSO SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE. SO WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
UP SUPPORT TESTIMONY FOR S. B.
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT. SORT MR SURE.
VOTE IN THE CAR OF- PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THIS TIME THE
PEOPLE PRESS ONE ZERO KEEP UP
AND OUR- THANKS BYE ONE ZERO
SECOND. WITH FROM THE QUEUE AND
BECAUSE I KNOW TO DO A SUPPORT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE US KNOW HOW
ARE CUTE UP. TO AT YOUR AND I'M
WITH REAL HAPPY TROUBLE AND
CALLING GAIN STRONG. ON KIND OF
S. B. SIX SEVEN EIGHT. THANK
YOU. MY IN Q. WITH ON A OF THE
TWO FOUR TO GOING PLEASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN RAN MARTIN I'M THE
HALF THE HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
AND TELL HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
TO FIX OR. SHE MICHAEL. ERICA
COMMITTEE POINT THANK YOU.
TWENTY FIVE IT'S GOING. TO ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ZERO. I MEAN DO ME
HAPPY CAL CAL OF BEHAVIOR
AGENCY SUPPORT. ONE TWO GO
AHEAD. EXACTLY- ON BEHALF OF
HOW OUT OF AT LEAST. SIX
SEVENTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
EUROPEN THE. YEAH THIS IS DAVID-
AND- I'M OPPOSED AND THERE'S
FOR GENDER. WHAT SAID NINE
MILLION. THE NEW MEN UNITED WAY
GREATER LAST INSTRUMENTS. THE
LAST ONE CHOOSE FIFTH SO PLEASE
GO. YEAH MY NAME IS DON GRAMMAR
IN THE ALLEY I AM SUPPORT. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS
WHO WANTS TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION. SAYING NONE I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE PHONE LINE
FOR OPPOSITION SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT. CERTAINLY FOR
OPPOSITIONAL SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAD ONE ENGINEER BUT
THEY LOSE THEMSELVES AND THEY
ARE BACK ONE ADELINE TO A LAB
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR OPEN.
HI THIS IS DAVE I CALLED IN THE
WRONG THE- OPPOSE AND TELL US
HOW FOR GENDER. THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN FROM PRESS ONE AT THIS
TIME. AND SURE WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL CALLS INTO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING A SIX
ABOUT TO THE TO CALL ARE
QUESTION OR. OKAY SEEING ON-
CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE GREATER.
TO USE DATA TO HELP. WIN THAT
ARE STE. TO GET SIR. IN WITHOUT
I ASKED YOUR I. THINK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER. A NUMBER
CAN AND I HEARD ON THIS BILL-
MADAM WE PLAY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SERRA THIS IS SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHT BY OF THE
RUBIO THE MOST IS TO PASS
FOUGHT. WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION
AT OUR MOST. MOTION BY CENTER
W. NOT L. A. LA L. A SHOW ABOUT
HI THE TROUBLE I SKINNER HI
SKINNER I NUMBER. FIVE NUMBER I
WOULD CASKEY HI PATELS THE ICE.
SEVEN OKAY THAT HASN'T VOTES SO
I WILL PUT. YES THE MEMBERS
BEFORE YELTSIN ARTS A LOT I
WANT TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- WHICH COMPRISES OF
THREE BILLS- ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FIVE EIGHTY ONE BY CENTER
ATKINS. I ITEM TENDS SB FOUR
THIRTY TWO BY CENTER BY CAL
SKI. AND ITEM ELEVEN S. B. TWO
THIRTY FOUR- BY YOURS TRULY ON.
A MOTION BY CENTER CABALLERO ON
THE CONSENT. AGENDA AND METAM
SODIUM WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS TO TEN
AND ELEVEN SENATOR WIENER.
WINNER I'D BATES. KARAPIRO HI
CABALLERO- CORTESE. MCGUIRE
WHAT'S AVAILABLE HI THE TROUBLE
I SKINNER SKINNER BY NUMBER
NUMBER FIVE WITH CASKEY CASKEY-
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MORE THAN. SIXTY SENATOR BATES
SENATOR CORTEZ. SEVEN REQUIRE.
OKAY SIX BUT HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT I WILL PUT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL
MEXICO- TO ITEM THREE SB THREE
NINETY TWO BY CENTER OUR TOYOTA
CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY AFTER
FLEXIBILITY WITH CENTER RUBIO
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO REGARDING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION DOCUMENT DELIVERY.
AND WEBSITE. THREE SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY TWO WILL IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY TO IMPROVE TO
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS. AND REDUCE
DELIVERY COSTS BY REQUIRING
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA
EMAIL UNLESS A RESIDENT CHOOSES
TO OPT OUT. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO ALSO REQUIRES
ASSOCIATION CONSISTING OF FIFTY
OR MORE UNITS TO MAINTAIN THEM.
INFORMATIONAL WEBSITE.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE THAN
TO ATTEMPT TO MORE THAN FIFTY
TWO THOUSAND COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS MADE UP OF FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION HOUSING
UNITS ACROSS THE STATE. THESE%
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
ARE GOVERNED BY THEIR
RESPECTIVE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS WHICH ARE WHICH
ARE REQUIRED TO FOLLOW THE
REGULATIONS AND GUIDELINES
ESTABLISHED IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
BY LAWS UNDER THE STATE'S DAVIS
STERLING COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT ACT. UNDER THE
DAVIS STERLING ACT ASSOCIATIONS
MUST PROVIDE MEMBERS WITH
NECESSARY DOCUMENTS INCLUDING
ANNUAL BUDGETS POLICY
STATEMENTS OR NOTICES VIA FIRST
CLASS MAIL UNLESS. ELECTRONIC
DELIVERY IS OTHERWISE REQUESTED
BY THE INDIVIDUAL. PREVIOUSLY
LEGISLATION HAS SOUGHT TO
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
MEMBER FROM EXORBITANT FEES AND
LIMITING THE AMOUNT
ASSOCIATIONS CAN CHARGE FOR
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PROCESSING PREPARING AND
DELIVERING OF THESE DOCUMENTS
ADDITIONALLY TO FURTHER
INCREASE INFORMATION
ACCESSIBILITY THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SENATE BILL THREE TO
THREE AND TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH
REQUIRED HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
TO DELIVER MEMBERSHIP BOARD
ELECTION RULES. BY INDIVIDUAL
DELIVERY OR BY POSTING ON A
WEBSITE. IN THE MIDST OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WHERE MAIL
DELAYS ARE COMMON COST SAVINGS
ARE CRUCIAL AND INFORMATION
ACCESSIBILITY IS VITAL.
UPDATING THESE PROCESSES TO BE
ELECTRONIC IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER THE MORE THAN EVER.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY TWO
MANDATES HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
TO ELECTRONICALLY DELIVER
DCUMENTS TO ITS MEMBERS
BEGINNING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IF A VALID EMAIL
ADDRESS HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. A RESIDENT CAN CHOOSE TO
OPT OUT OF ELECTRONIC DELIVERY
BY NOT PROVIDING AN EMAIL
ADDRESS AND THE ASSOCIATION
WILL CONTINUE TO DELIVER THESE
DOCUMENTS BY MAIL. SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY TWO ALSO REQUIRES
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
OVERSEE FIFTY OR MORE UNITS TO
MAINTAIN A WEBSITE FOR THEIR
MEMBERSHIPS TO ACCESS UNDER
THIS PROVISION HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ARE GIVEN
FLEXIBILITY. AS TO WHO
MAINTAINS THE WEBSITE AND HOW
TO- STRUCTURE IT. HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION CAN ALSO CHOOSE TO
OPT OUT OF HAVING A WEBSITE OR
ELECTRONIC DELIVERY IT TWO
THIRDS OF THEIR MEMBERS VOTE IN
FAVOUR OF OPTING OUT. FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS TODAY I
HAVE JENNIFER SETBACK.
REPRESENTING OUR BILL SPONSORED
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
WITH THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR FIVE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR- WILL NOW GO TO OUR
THE- SUPPORT WITNESS JENNIFER
SMACK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS-
MISDIRECT YOU MAY PROCEED.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER STACK ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. UP ONTO THE BEST
BETWEEN NINETY TWO EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES PROPERTY OWNERS TO
ANNUALLY PROVIDE AN H. AWAY
UPDATED CONTACT INFORMATION BUT
DOES NOT REQUIRE HOAS TRANSMIT
INFORMATION TO HOMEOWNERS VIA
EMAIL EVEN IF THAT IS THE
HOMEOWNERS PREFERRED DELIVERY
METHOD. SB THREE NINETY TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE BY
PERMITTING PROPERTY OWNERS TO
DEFINE THEIR EMAIL ADDRESS AS
ONE OF THEIR TO PREFERRED
COMMUNICATION METHODS WALL
COMPELLING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION TO COMMUNICATE WITH
HOMEOWNERS VIA EMAIL. UNDER THE
MEASURE PROPERTY OWNERS CAN
CHOOSE NOT TO PROVIDE AN EMAIL
ADDRESS TO THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND MAY REVOKE
THEIR CONSENT TO RECEIVING
COMMUNICATIONS VIA EMAIL AT ANY
TIME. WE GO TO GIVEN THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS AND IN
RESPONSE TO THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC
WHICH HIGHLIGHTED THE
DEFICIENCIES IN OUR PHYSICAL
MAIL DELIVERY SYSTEM. EMAIL
DELIVERY MUST BE AN OPTION
DRIVEN BY HOMEOWNERS. NOT THE
H. O. A.'S PREFERENCE. BUT
THREE NINETY TWO WILL IMPROVE
AS OF THE BILL TO. DOCUMENTS
REDUCING DELIVER COSTS
REQUIRING A CHILI'S COMMUNICATE
WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA EMAIL. WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW GO
TO THE- EXCUSE ME TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY SUPPORTERS HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS AND AGAIN GOING
FORWARD PLEASE TO STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION OF ANY AND
YOUR SUPPORT. I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS-
WHAT I'M LOOKING AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
THERE SO WHEN I GO TO THE PHONE
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR
FOR SUPPORT- FOR- S. B. THREE
NINETY TWO. YES A RESEARCHER TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. EVEN A LINE
NUMBER THE SECURE LINE NUMBER
TO BE CALLED AND THEN WE'LL
OPEN THELINE TO SPEAK AND- WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE COMING IN NOW
ONE MOMENT PLEASE ALL TOGETHER
THE INFORMATION. SHOULD BE JUST
A FEW MORE SECONDS. ONCE AGAIN
THE SPEAKING SUPPORT PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING
TO NUMBER THIRTY FIVE WILL HAVE
THIRTY FUNDING LINES OF. HEY
MORNING I'M NOT A PART OF THE
TEMPLE I'D LIKE THOSE SPORTS.
SB THREE NINETEEN. NINE FIVE.
THE PROVISIONAL SUPPORT
COMMENTS PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME MISTER SHERMAN
HAVE NO ADDITIONAL CALLERS AND
KEEP. GREAT WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO LEAD
OPPONENTS- LISTED- ELAINE LET
LOVE PLANTS FROM THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA. HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW AND MARJORAM
MERRY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS-
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES-
WE'LL START WITH YOUR NAME LOVE
LOVE PLANTS.
ONE IS OPEN I'M
GOING TO PLACE.
MISTER
MODERATOR- WHAT'S THE SITUATION.
OUR SHOWROOM IS LITTLE FONG IT
WAS IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM WITH
AN OPEN LINE AND AVAILABLE TO
SPEAK. ON THE CALL. BUT NO
AUDIO COOLEY COOPER PHONE. AND
I'M TOLD THAT MISS MERRY IS NOT
ON. SO IS THERE ANYWAY WE DON'T
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPONENTS ONLINE.
MISS MERRY WE'LL SEE. AND FOR
OPPONENTS LOOKING FOR A LARGER
VERY EARLY ON ONE THAT WE HAVE
ON THERE IS ELEVEN LET'S LOOK
PLANTS. IS NOT WORKING OPEN TO
CONNECT WITH ONE. RIGHT IT
MIGHT BE ON HER EMBARRASSED
SAID WHICH WHICH IS FULLY OPEN
WITH NO. I'M SORRY IT LOOKS
LIKE WHAT. LARA AND IT LOOKS
LIKE SHE'S FULLY OPEN AND AN
ACTIVE CONNECTION AND HIS
FRIEND WERE READY FOR HER TO
SPEAK AND DIFFERENT THINGS BUT
THERE'S NOTHING BUT THE COMING
UP WE'RE SORRY. TRY A COUPLE
THINGS HERE MIGHT BE ABLE TO-
HER ATENTION ON SOMETHING
YOU'RE JUST MOMENTS. SO WHAT
ABOUT. BOTH THE. SHE IS IN AN
ACTIVELY CONNECTED WITH HIS
LAWYER BUSINESS IS THERE'S
NOTHING COMING FROM HER PHONE.
HELLO OKAY- HELLO ARE YOU ABLE
TO HEAR ME IT IS THIS- IS THIS
MAN'S LOVE OF PLANT OR MS
MURRAY. NO THIS IS MISS MURRAY
THERE WAS. A GOOD BIT OF
DIFFICULTY INTERACTING OKAY
WELL IT'S BEEN HEARING IS VERY
YOU OF TWO MINUTES SO YOU MAY
PROCEED TO TESTIFY. ONE MOMENT.
I ONE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOR RETIRED AMERICANS. THE
LABOR SENIOR ORG. AND ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL FOUR THREE
REASONS WHY. IT BY LAKE COUNTY
LAWS ON EMAIL PRIVACY. LEVEL NO
COST SEVENTEEN YOUR HOMEOWNERS
AND THE REQUIREMENT TO BUILD
AND MAINTAIN WEBSITES WILL BE
TECHNICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
COMPLY WITH HIM SENIOR
COMMUNITIES IN RURAL AND SEMI
RURAL AREA. I NEED TO POINT OUT
THAT THE COMMITTEE AMOUNT OF
THE SAYS THAT THE BILL REQUIRES
DELIVERY OF CERTAIN SPECIFIED
DOCUMENTS BY EMAIL UNLESS THE
MEMBER HAS REQUEST DELIVERY BY
OTHER MEANS. THIS WOULD ALLOW
DELIVERY OF THE LEGAL DOCUMENTS
LIKE WE NOTICES WHICH. ARE
GOVERNED BY STATUTE THERE.
THERE ARE SPECIAL WAYS STOCK
THAT BE DELIVERED. I FEEL I
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE THAT THE
IS RESPONSE. EMAIL DELIVER
ITHOUT THE AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT
OF THE OWNER. WHAT WITH ALL
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS
GOVERNING THE PRIVACY OF
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS.
REQUIRES BUT THE PERSON WHO
OWNS THE EMAIL ACCOUNT. IN
ORDER GREEN FOR THE USE OF
EMAIL AS A COMMUNICATION TOOL
BUT NOT THE CONSENT. SAID IN
NUMBERS BUT GOING FORWARD
DOCUMENTS SHALL BE DELIVERED BY
EMAIL. I WANT TO TAKE ONE
MINUTE TO TALK ABOUT HOW THIS
AFFECTS SENIORS LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION STANFORD
UNIVERSITY AS A WHOLE LOT OF
STUDIES DONE. ON A LOT. AND ONE
OF THE MAIN WAY. SHARPSHOOTERS
TO GET A HOLD OF SENIORS AND
THEIR VULNERABILITY IT BY THE
INTERNET AND BY EMAIL. THE
CENTER REPORTS OF ALMOST 45% OF
GLOBAL FINANCIAL ABUSE IS NOW
THROUGH EMAIL. THE BILL HAS A
MIDDLE GUARD RAIL WHAT CAMPER
ON THE EMAIL DATABASE. THAT
ACCUMULATES. VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT. THE YOUR EMAIL ADDRESS.
THERE ARE NO SECURITY MEASURES
WHATEVER IN THE BILL. AND LET
ME ALSO POINT OUT ABOUT THE
WEBSITE REQUIREMENTS MANY GOOD
RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES ARE
LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA RURAL
AREAS WHERE THEE IS METAL OR
LIMITED INTERNET INFRASTRUCTURE.
SEVEN THIRTY COMMUNITIES IN SAN
BENITO LAST THURSDAY AFTER KERN
COUNTY ARE EXAMPLES. IT'S
SEPARATE FROM WHAT IS CALLED
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE SO JUST FROM
A TECHNICAL STANDPOINT IT'S
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO COMPLY
WITH THE REQUIREMENT OF ASKING.
FINALLY YOU KNOW SENIORS ARE
PERCEIVED AS SOME KIND OF DEEP
POCKETS. CAN FINANCE ALL OF
THINGS THAT WE THREE NINE TWO
HAS NOTE TODAY NO. NO SHINING
THING OF WEBS. WHATEVER SENIOR
HAVE ALL KINDS OF CALLS
INCLUDING MEDIC COSTS MANY HAVE
NO TEN. WILL BE ANOTHER BURGER
OF THE. TO DEAL WITH ASSESSMENT
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE REALLY
URGE VICTIMS. REFORM VOEPEL THE
MEASURE THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER ARE YOU TOOK OVER
THREE SO IF I MISS AND LOVE
LOVE PLAN IS PRESIDENT SURE.
ONE THERE'S A LOT OF TIME ARE
YOU. SHE IS COMMITTED TO PLAY
FOR THE PHONE. EXCUSE ME. I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD MA'AM I
APOLOGIZE NOT PLAN IF YOU'RE
NOW. YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE. HE
OKAY I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR A
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE NINETY
TWO IT IS NOT A MODERN AGE
PROSTRATING AMERICANS MECHANISM
BUT IF YOU'RE A COMPANY THAT
CAN DICTATE HOW COMMUNITY
HOMEOWNERS MUST COMMUNICATE IN
ORDER TO MAIN TAIN ANY CONTROL
OVER THE YEARS MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM MALAKAL EMAIL. ACCOUNTS
BURKE RIGHT. THE PERSONAL NON
PUBLIC IN. A MAJORITY PRO RIGHT
THIRDS OUR PROMO ASSOCIATION
MEMBERSHIP CANNOT DICTATE HOW.
GIVE ME AN EXTENSION WILL BE A
STATEMENT WHICH- AS MISS MURRAY
HAS POINTED YOU THERE ARE
NUMEROUS. OBSTACLES SENIOR
CITIZENS NOT ONLY ENVIRONMENTAL
BUT ALSO. LET IT BE LIKE HEAT
AND- ACCEPTANCE OF USE
ELECTRONIC. DISPUTE THIS BILL
IS A KNOCKED OUT BILL IT SHOULD
BE AN OPT IN BILL. WHICH ISN'T
INCOME WHICH WOULD THEN BE MORE
MORE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION STATE
AND FEDERAL PREDICTIONS LOS
THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE NOW ON
OPPOSITION IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS SO I SEE NO ONE. I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- AND
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND THIS IS AGAIN
OPPOSITION- TO SB THREE. NINETY
TWO PLEASE SET YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THAT YOU
OPPOSE. HELLO THREE MILLION
GERMAN FOR OPPOSITION PLUS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE'RE
CALLING THAT A LINE NUMBER.
ELEVEN TO ELEVEN- HAS ALREADY
LEFT THE MOMENT. SOMETIMES
REFRESH RATE IS A LITTLE BIT
BEHIND. JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE NINETEEN ONE YEAR OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. MY NAME IS TOM
SIR I AM A RESIDENT OF THE
THREE THOUSAND UNITS COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT FIFTEEN
YEARS IN SOLANO COUNTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HELLO AN EXCELLENT NUMBER TWO
THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE
OPEN. YES THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD
AFTERNOON. SHERMAN WIENER AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE MY NAME
IS ADRIAN QUITE CHOW SKI AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF A THIRTY
UNIT HOMEOWNERS. CHATTANOOGA
CALIFORNIA- I. RICHARD THE
SPIRIT OF THIS BILL BUT I SEE
TREMENDOUS UROLOGIST. HAVING
FUN THANK YOU HAVE A
MINIMIZATION PRIZE THANK YOU
YOUR OPPOSITION IS NOTED.
ANOTHER LINE TO TWENTY
HEADPHONES. TWENTY TWENTY YEAR
OPEN HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU GOING OUT YES I
AM POSTED- FOR BECAUSE IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO COMMUNITY
THING SHOULD BE WRITTEN WORK ON
BRANDING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR OPPOSITION IS NOTED AGAIN-
PLEASE LET YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY AND
YOU'RE AND THE FACT THAT YOU
ARE OPPOSED. I UPLOADED IN
MOUNTAIN. THANKS TO A LINE TO
ELEVEN TO ELEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI THIS IS DAVID I
OPPOSE THIS BECAUSE IT HASN'T
BEEN TAUGHT THROUGH FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE. ONCE
AGAIN FOR. COMMENTS OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHATEVER STRUCTURE WE
HAVE NOTED CALLER IN Q. THANK
YOU FOR YOU VERY MUCH GROWING
UP THE BILL TO THE COMMITTEE-
SENATOR A MEMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THE BILL BUT THERE ARE TWO
ISSUES THAT REMAIN OUTSTANDING
I KNOW THE BILL'S COMING
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ONE IS.
THAT SIMPLY PROVIDING ONES
EMAIL ADDRESS MAY NOT. ALERT
THE PERSON PROVIDING THAT EMAIL
ADDRESS AT THE SAME TIME
THEY'RE PROVIDING THAT
ADDRESSES THEIR ALSO CONSENTING
TO OF FUTURE EMAIL DELIVERY SO
THAT'S ONE ISSUE WE WANT TO
WORK ON JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
OTHER ISSUE IS AS WAS
ILLUSTRATED THE USE OF AND OF
THE DATA THAT IS COLLECTED IN
THE PROVISIONS TO SAFEGUARD
THAT DATA- I'M HOPEFUL THAT
THAT YOU REMAIN FLEXIBLE TO
WORK ON THOSE TWO ISSUES IN
PARTICULAR. SO THAT WE CAN-
MAKE SURE THAT THE THAT THE
BILL. OF BOTH PROVIDES FOR
EFFICIENCY BUT ALSO FOR
SECURITY. YOUR NAY I COMMENT
MEASURE UP YEAH SURE OR YOU CAN
TAKE IT IN YOUR CLOTHES- CAL
POLY TO THE CLOSE ANY OTHER-
CENTER MICHALSKI. MISTER MISTER
I'M GOING TO BE STAYING OFF THE
BILL RIGHT NOW I HAVE SOME OF
THE SAME CONCERNS- THAT THE
CHAIR JUDICIARY HAS AND I KNOW
I'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO VOTE ON
IT AND A COUPLE OF WEEKS SO I'M
LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE THE MMC
BEING TAKEN TODAY. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. GREAT SEEING THE- OF
CENTER CABALLERO THANK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM I ALSO
SIT ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT THERE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY LOOK AT THIS
BILL AGAIN I WILL- OUT OF
DIFFERENCE TO THE AUTHOR A. B.
IN SUPPORT TODAY BUT I HAVE
SOME CONCERNS I WANNA MAKE SURE
IT'S FLEXIBLE ENOUGH FOR THOSE
A CHOICE. THAT WERE THERE WHO
ARE WERE IN OPPOSITION TODAY
TO- I FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
THERE ARE SOME OPTIONS FOR THEM
THEY DON'T HAVE TO JUST USE THE
EMAIL THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO A
WEBPAGE OF IF- IF THEY DON'T
WANT TO I HAVE A LOT OF RURAL-
HOAS IN MY DISTRICT AND QUITE
FRANKLY INTERNET ACCESS IS A
JOKE SO TARA REQUIRE THEM TO
HAVE A WEB PAGE AND TO REQUIRED
THEM. TO ONLY USE EMAIL
ADDRESSES IS A PROBLEM BUT AS
LONG AS WE CAN OFFER SOME
PROTECTION FOR PRIVACY
PROTECTION I'M- I'M WILLING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. EIGHT HUNDRED
ASSURE COMMITTEE TO SO WE HAVE.
GOING TO SING A LOT OF US
AGAIN- CENTER- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- AND DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. MOTION BY
CENTRE GUERRERO- CENTER
ARCHULETA YOU MAY CLOSE AND
PERHAPS- ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
THANK YOU MR AND IT LET ME SAY
THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO CALLED
IN- TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS- ARE
LOOKING VERY MUCH INTO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- CENTER AMBERG
HAS BROUGHT UP AND THE CONCERN
IS CENTER TO BROUGH AND
MENTION. AND THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL GO FORWARD AS WE GO TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE- BUT AGAIN THAT
REMEMBER WE'RE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FIFTY UNITS OR MORE FOR
INFORMATIONAL WEBSITE WHICH
ISN'T EXPENSIVE AT ALL- WHEN WE
THINK OF WEBSITES WE THINK IT'S
SOMETHING VERY ELABORATE BUT
THIS IS JUST AN INFORMATIONAL
WEBSITE. THE OTHER THING IS
THAT REMEMBER EVERYONE CAN OPT
OUT IF THEY WISH NOT TO GIVE
THEIR EMAIL ADDRESS. AND THE
OTHER THING IS REMEMBER THAT IF
THEY VOTE THREE QUARTERS OF
THE- OF THE ASSOCIATION VOTE
AND NOT TO DO IT AT ALL DID IT
WILL APPLY SO FLEXIBILITY IS IN
THE BILL. AND BELIEVE ME WE
WILL BE WORKING- FOR THE
AMENDMENTS TO GO FORWARD AND
COME TOGETHER AND I'M SURE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WILL BACKING ON THAT
AND IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT. FROM THE SPONSOR IS
SHE STILL ON THE LINE WE DON'T
NEED HER THEN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
FOR THE CLOSE SENATOR- I AM
RECOMMENDING- AN I VOTES ON-
THIS BILL AND- NOTING THAT WE
DID NOT ADDRESS THE PRIVACY
ISSUES. AND HOUSING COMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDING THAT- THAT WOULD
BE ADDRESSED AND- JUDICIARY
WHICH IS WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEE- TO ANALYZE ON THE
PRIVACY. ISSUES AND SO WITH
THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER CABALLERO AND SOME-
CONSULTANT IF YOU'LL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS BILL
THREE NINETY TWO BY SO ARE
ALETTA THE MOTION DO PAY. BUT
FIRST BE RIVER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY SENATOR WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE BATES HI BATES HI
CABALLERO I CABALLERO- CORTESE.
MCGUIRE OCTOBER SKINNER HI
SKINNER NUMBER NUMBER FIVE
CASKEY. BECAUSE THE NOT BURDENS.
FIVE OKAY THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES
BUT WE'LL PUT OUR ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER TO LEAD OFF THANK YOU
MISTER WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB SIX TWO ONE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN WHO IS- I SAW
HER SOMEWHERE THERE SHOWS-
WELCOME CENTER EGGMAN. HELLO
SIR OR DOUBLE OR TROUBLE
SHOOTING THAT LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THAT GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING CLOSELY WITH US
ON SB SIX TWENTY ONE WE HAVE
THE AMENDMENTS READY TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS HOWEVER BECAUSE THE
TIMING ISSUES THEY WILL BE
PROCESSED THROUGH THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD TODAY. A QUICKLY THOSE
AMENDMENTS WOULD EXTEND THE
VACANCY PERIOD REQUIREMENT A
BILL FROM SIX MONTHS TO ONE
YEAR. AND STATE THE INTENT TO
ALLOW A RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PURCHASE PROPERTIES. THE
PROJECT COUNTY. THE BILL
CREATES EXPEDITED PATHWAY FOR
PROJECT DEVELOPERS TO TURN ON
INHABITED MOTELS AND HOTELS AND
A MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
TRANSITION HOTELS AND MOTELS.
HAVE SEVERAL ADVANTAGES AS WE
ALL KNOW WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY
IN CITIES WHERE IT'S OF THE
SIDEWALKSARE IN THE STREETS OR
IN. AS OFTEN ALREADY PARKING.
IN OTHER WORDS ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HUMAN
HABITATION IS ALREADY IN PLACE
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO RURAL
REPRESENT PARTS OF RURAL
CALIFORNIA WHERE. THE AT THE
IT'S ALWAYS EASIER TO GO BUILT
ON GREENFIELD THIS IS ALWAYS A
GOOD IDEA TO BUILD IN CITIES
WHERE THESE ARE ALREADY EXIST.
IT REDUCES THE IMPACT ON WATER
QUALITY AND SEE WHICH- THE BILL
WILL ONLY APPLY TO HOTELS AND
MOTELS THAT ARE NO LONGER IN
OPERATION THEY DON'T THE TWO
DID NOT PROVIDE SHELTER AND
WILL NOT BE DISLOCATING
EVERYBODY IS OFTEN A CONCERN.
THIS EXPEDITED PROCESS WILL NOT
ONLY CREATES MORE MARKET RATE
HOUSING. BUT IN EXCHANGE FOR AN
EXPEDITED MINISTERIAL PROCESS.
WOULD MAKE PRIVATE PROJECTS
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO
INCREASING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE STATE. PRESIDENT
OF THE DEVELOPERS USING THE
CURRENT PROCESS THE PURCHASING
INTERNEES HOTELS AND MOTELS
INTO HOUSING THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY AFFORDABLE. THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE 10% OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SET ASIDE.
IT ALSO MAKES CLEAR. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH THE GREATER
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT.
WOULD APPLY IN ITS PLACE OF
THIS TEN PERCENT. I KNOW
HOUSING PRODUCTION HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND
COURSE THIS CHAIR AND
PARTICULAR AND WE CERTAINLY
HEARD FROM THEM ON THESE BILLS
ALREADY TODAY. I THINK THIS
BILL STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
KEEPING PEOPLE ON HOTELS HOUSED
PROVIDING A PATH FOR QUICK.
HOUSING PRODUCTION ENSURING
THAT THE SUCCESS THE PROJECT
COUNTY REMAINS UNHINDERED. WITH
ME HERE AND TODAY I HAVE
DEBORAH CARLSON FROM THE
SPONSOR ORGANIZATIONS.
DEPARTMENT ASSOCIATION. AND
JOSHUA BUTLER FROM THE
LENDERMAN HOUSING LANDS. THANK
YOU CENTER TO START THERE WAS-
I THINK OF SOFT MIGHT ISSUE A
TO BE GETTING OF YOUR- WEAPONS
ASIDE SO I THINK I HEARD YOU
GUYS IN TERMS OF THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS ANALYSIS
THAT YOU WILL TAKE THOSE AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE THAT IS CORRECT. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THOSE.
OKAY WILL NOW GO TO THEIR LEAD
SUPPORTERS DEBRA CARLTON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND JOSH BUTLER
pALLIANCE. ARE YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES SO MISS CARLTON IF YOU
COULD BE MINDFUL OF THAT SO
THAT YOU DON'T- AND INFRINGE ON
MR BOTTLERS- TWO MINUTES WE
APPRECIATE THAT- SO WITH THAT-
MISS CARLTON. THANK YOU VERY
INTEREST AND- DEMOCRATA ACCOUNT.
APARTMENTS WE REPRESENT BOTH
AFFORDABLE- DEVELOPERS AS WELL
AS MARKET RATE. YOU KNOW IN
SPONSORING THIS BILL OUR INTENT
WAS ALWAYS TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL AN EXPEDITED.
PATHWAY FOR THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- WHEN WE
STARTED THIS PROCESS- IT WOULD
BE FOR KOBE AND IT WOULD BE
FOR- THE SUCCESS THAT WE'VE
SEEN WITH- PROJECT HOME KEY. AS
A SENATOR EGGMAN INDICATED THE
INTENT IS TO NOT INTERFERE WITH
THE SUCCESS OF THE PROJECT-
HOME KEY. BUT TO ADD TO THE
SUCCESS OF THAT PROGRAM- WE
OBVIOUSLY ALSO INTENDED TO
PROVIDE- AN EXISTING SOURCE OF
HOUSING- THROUGH. HOTELS AND
MOTELS THAT HAD NOT BEEN
UTILIZED IN THE RECENT PAST. SO
AS YOU KNOW WHO TOOK THE MOTELS
ARE OFTEN LOCATED NEAR PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE WORK AND WANT TO
LIVE. THERE BY SERVING AS AN
IDEA IDEAL LOCATION FOR
DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING WE
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH AND I WAS ONLY
ONE MINUTE SO YOUR ACTS ARE
KINDS OF MISTER- BUTLER WHO. BY
NOW HAS A UP TO THREE MINUTES
ALTHOUGH YOU DO NOT HAVE TO
TAKE ALL THREE MINUTES SO
MISTER BUTLER. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
THE EXPEDIENCY AND YOUR
COMMITMENT TODAY. AS A LONGTIME
HOUSING ADVOCATE. THIS IS
INDEED AN HONOR TO BE SPEAKING
BEFORE YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS
JOSH BUTLER I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LANTERN IN
HOUSING ALLIANCE. L. HA IS A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVES AS A CATALYST. FOR THE
CREATION OF AFFORDABLE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIANS BUT INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WE BRING TOGETHER BUILDERS
REGIONAL CENTERS AND
POLICYMAKERS AS WELL AS OTHER
KEY STAKEHOLDERS. INCREASE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
IT D. COMMUNITY. THIS
LEGISLATION CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INCREASED
INDEPENDENT LIVING FOR MEMBERS
OF THE IDT COMMUNITY AND THAT
IS WHY WE ARE IN SUPPORT THE
SUPPORT THE SUCH AS LITTLE
LEGISLATION AS WELL. THAT THE
DAUGHTERS OF SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
POPPING BILL SROS WHICH MAKE
THE MOTELS OFTEN HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
CONVERSION INTO HOMES FOR THE
COMMUNITY. AS WELL A PROJECT
HOME HE HAS PROVIDED A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF HOW THEY CAN MOTELS
CAN BE REPURPOSED TO MEET
CURRENT NEEDS. I HAVE MANY
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
IN FAR GREATER NEED- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR ANY HOUSING AS
COMPARED TO THEY CAN HOTELS. WE
HAVE MANY MEMBERS WHO ARE ON
STANDBY DO YOU COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY.
SB SIX TWO ONE WOULD CREATE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS TODAY
WHEN A MAN HOUSING ALLIANCE HAS
USED TO VOTE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT. WOULD LIKE TO
THINK THE STANDARD EGGMAN. FOR
BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OKAY WE WILL NOW GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
GALLERY- I SEE MISTER HAN.
THANK YOU ERIN MY HAND ON
BEHALF OF THE NEARLY HALF A
MILLION MEMBERS OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY.
SAYING NINE I'M LOOKING AT ROOM
ONE TWELVE AND SEE NO ONE
THERE. SO NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ARE MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP.
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. FOR SB SIX
TO ONE AGAIN LIMITED TO NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND SUPPORT.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR TO COMMON
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY
ONE. PRESS ONE ZERO ON THE
PHONES KEEPING UP WITH THE
ALIGNMENT RETURNED ACCUMULATING
THIS CALL PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND TO SEE WITH
YOUR COMMENT PLAN LAUDABLE TWO
LINE NUMBER. TWO FORTY TWO FOUR
ZERO ZERO. YEAH REMEMBER RANDOM
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE. OKAY FOUNDATION AND
IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT IMPLEMENTED AS
DESCRIBED IN THE LETTER WAS
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE NUMBER.
TWO THIRTY SIX YEAR OLD GIRL
AND SHE- MOVES WHERE MEMBERS
ALL STATEMENTS OF. S. SIX NINE
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN FOUR
COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO WE'RE
GOING ON A ONE TO FORTY THREE
PLEASE. HI I'M KAREN BYRNE WITH
THE MONITOR THIRTY ASIAN WE
HAVE A HAND ACROSS THE STATE
OPEN WITHOUT REACH PROJECT AND
IF IT MAKING A LOT OF USED A
PARTY GREEN KEY REALLY SUPPORT
HELP LIKE THIS I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE BECAUSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH. THE
YOU- TO GET NAME PHILLY. AND
THE FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT WE
ALREADY HAVE A TESTIMONY BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY.
WE WILL NOT A LINE TO FORTY ONE
TO FORTY IS WHAT THE QUEUE THE
QUEUE IS CRIMINAL. CALLERS INTO
CERTAIN. I'M SORRY THERE ISN'T
THERE IS ADDITIONAL ARE NOT
ADDITIONAL. THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IN THE
CUTEST TIME OKAY GREAT WILL NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION. WE HAVE TO.
THE OPPONENTS WHO WILL EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES- SHERRIN
REPORT FROM THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND CIVIC
XTO FROM THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY BUT WE'LL START
WITH THIS REPORT- THE SUPPORT
YOU HAVE. TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THE SHERIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT WORKING TO SOLVE
BULLISHNESS. WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE INTENT OF THE BILL AND THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IN THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US. AT THIS TIME WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. SB SIX
TWO ONE UNLESS AMENDED. MR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OUT SB SIX
TWO ONE REVERSES THE INTENT OF
EXISTING LAWS THAT REQUIRE
LOCAL TO STREAMLINE PROJECTS.
THAT ARE SHELTERING IN HOUSING
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THE STATE IS
FUNDING ACQUISITION OF MOTELS
FOR PERMANENT HOUSING THROUGH
HOME SHE WHICH IS INTENDED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE LOW COST
OF DISTRESS MATERNAL. PROPOSED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
CURRENTLY I STREAMLINE THE
MISTER REVIEW PROBLEMS FOR THE
METALS. THE PROPOSAL. SIX TWO
WOULD INCENTIVES MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS TO PURCHASE THESE MY
PAL WHICH WILL DRIVE UP THE
COST OF THESE PROPERTIES AND
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER STANDARDS
FOR THREE QUID EXEMPTION
DIRECTLY UNDERMINING THE INTENT
OF HOMES. ADDITIONAL WE STILL
THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN A CLASSIC MATTEL'S
NOW USE THAT SHELTERS HAVE NOT
HELD OWNERS WOULD EFFECT
FAMILIES SHELTERING TO SUFFER
GREATER PROFIT MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS EVEN IF THEY HAVE TO
WAIT A YEAR TO DO SO. IN A
CONFLICT WITH THE STATE PROJECT
ROOM KEYS. TO SHELTER PEOPLE
VULNERABLE TO APPROPRIATE.
THEREFORE READ FOR IN THE-
LIMIT THE STREAMLINED REVIEW
HELLO HER CONCLUSIONS AND WHICH
IS SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
UNITS. WILL BE AFFORDABLE TO
HOUSEHOLDS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. ENSURE THE BILL
DOES NOT SUPERSEDE EXISTING OR
FUTURE LOCAL MOTEL CONVERSION
ORDINANCES THAT REQUIRE DEEPER
LEVEL OF AFFORDABILITY. AND
ENSURE THE BILL DOES NOT
UNDERMINE HOME KEY OR THE
LEGISLATURES PREVIOUS
STREAMLINING PROVISIONS AROUND
PRO FERRIER SHELTER. WITHOUT
THESE AMENDMENTS SB SIX TWO ONE
WILL IMPEDE STATE EFFORTS BY
DRIVING COMPETITION FOR
DISTRESSED MOTEL. AND
POTENTIALLY DISPLACE THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH- WITH SENATOR
EGGMAN SOB TO PREVENT NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THOSE EXPERIENCING.
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU IN A TO SEND VEHICLES FROM
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- AND YOU HAVE A MINUTE
AND FORTY SECONDS. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON HEARING NUMBER.
HERE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
U. S. B. ONE UNLESS MILLION TO
AVOID UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT UNDERMINE THE- ONGOING
EFFORT TO HELP VERY LOW INCOME
AND VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
HEALTH CRISIS AND BEYOND.
WESTERN CENTER SUPPORT THE
AUTHOR INTENDED BOTH UTILIZE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
MAXIMIZE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
BUT CERTAIN DRAFTED SB SIX TWO
ONE. THREE NINE PROFIT FOR
DEVELOPERS WHO AGREED TO
INCLUDE ONLY 10% OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS. CIRCUMVENT THE BACKSLIDE
FROM THE BILL CREDIT BETTER.
MOTELS AND HOTELS OFTEN PROVIDE
SUBJECT ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL
TRANSFERRED HOMELESSNESS AND
ARE UNABLE TO FIND TEMPORARY OR
PERMANENT HOUSING ELSEWHERE FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS INCLUDING.
FOR THE CRIMINAL RECORD
INABILITY TO AFFORD A SECURITY
POP AND MORE. SB SIXTY ONE
INCENTIVIZE DEVELOPERS TO
REMOVE CRITICAL HOUSING OF LAST
RESORT FOR PEOPLE WITH
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME IN ORDER
TO RESTORE THE. PROPERTY AS
MOSTLY MARKET RATE HOUSING. SB
SIX PROVIDES A SUBSTANTIAL
BENEFIT. WITHOUT ANY REQUIRED
AFTER MORE THAN 10% OF THE UNIT
THAT ARE ORDER AND REQUIRED
RIGHT. TO WITH THE LOW IN.
PEOPLE FACING HOMELESSNESS. THE
LITTLE AND REDUCING RATTLING.
AFFORDABLE HEALTH OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCING. WHAT
HE WILL TELL THEIR LOCATED IN
LOWER IN THE THAT ARE SENSITIVE
JUDGE FOR AND DISPLACEMENT
PRESSURES THAT CAN COME CREATES
THE ESPECIALLY IF THE BALLOT
DON'T PRIORITIZE EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME RIGHT. SO WE TO THANK
YOU FOR MEMBER I AND STAFF WELL
AS THE FOR HERE OR AND
RESPECTFUL APPROACHED THE
INCREASE ABOUT IF YOU WANT
TODAY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER. ABOUT ORANGE THAT
COMPLICATED. GREAT THANK YOU
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVES TO THE
GALLERY FOR OPPOSITE. I SEE-
AWARENESS PLEASE THANK YOU.
MARKS DIVERSE THE CAL HEALTHY
PARTNERSHIP. AND WE'RE RISK
OPPOSE UNLESS. TO GROW YOUR
LABOR A WAY THAT ALSO PUT IN
PLACE REASON GARBER. TO THE-
FOR HOUSING CAN ACTUALLY BE
BUILT AND WE HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THAT RESPECT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
WILL NOW GO TO ROOM I SEE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY. SO NOW
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING NO
ONE THERE WHEN I GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. IT'S A MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE. QUEUE UP
OPPONENTS TO SB SIX TWO ONE AND
AGAIN AS A REMINDER. PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY.
AND THE. SIMPLE FACT THAT YOU
OPPOSE. MISTER MISTER CHAIR
ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO TO
THE POLLS. AND WE'RE GONNA GO
NOW TO A LINE NUMBER FIFTY NINE
FIFTY GOING TO USE. ONE FIFTY
YOUR LINES OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ANOTHER ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT
POINT THIRTY ACRE AT. ONE TO
THIRTY EIGHT OPEN WITH IT
PLEASE. CHECKERING ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO AT LEAST EXPLAIN
ONE UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU
ONE TWO FORTY FOUR LINES OPEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. YOU KNOW WHY
AND WHAT THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM WHERE OPPOSE
ELECTION MANAGEMENT ECHO THE
REMARKS BY MY COLLEAGUE JUST
DIVERT. TWENTY TWO FORTY FIVE
GOING TO PLEASE. TWENTY FORTY
FIVE REAL LINES OPEN G
TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE
THE LINES OPEN TO TWENTY NINE.
HI MY NAME IS VERONICA CON AND
THEN ADVOCATE FOR SMART AND
PRACTICAL HOMELESS HOUSING AND
AYE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. ONE
FIFTY YEAR OPEN GOVERNANCE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON THE REST ON
THE DOES ONBEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. ONCE
AGAIN FOR ALL POLLUTION PRESS
ONE ZERO AN OUTLINE TO FORTY
FIVE ONE TO FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD.
TWENTY TWO FORTY FIVE A LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN Q. NO
ADDITIONAL CALLS ACUTE UPS.
OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER ON BURKE- THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS AND THANK YOU-
CENTER EGGMAN FOR YOUR
FLEXIBILITY WITH RESPECT TO THE
RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL. THAT
THAT'S A CONCERN WITH RESPECT
CONCERNING- WHETHER THERE'S ANY
CONDITIONS PLACED UPON LOCAL.
GOVERNMENTS OR OTHER ENTITIES
BEING ABLE TO EXERCISE THAT
RIGHT FOR SIX REFUSAL FOR
EXAMPLE WHETHER THE- ACTUAL
FUNDS NEED TO BE ESCORTED THE
TIME WHETHER NEEDS TO BE
APPROVED. AT THAT TIME AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH US TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE DON'T CREATE
OBSTACLES FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR NONPROFITS ACTUALLY TO
PARTICIPATE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
YEAH THAT THAT IS NOT THE
INTENTION THE INTENTION IS TO
OFFER- OF LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
A RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL AND WE
DIDN'T PUT IN THE TIME I JUST I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE. THEY HAVE
THAT TIME TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
THAT IS TO ACQUIRE THE MONEY TO
THE MONEY DOESN'T HAVE TO BE AT
HAND THROUGH ESCROW. WHEN ONE
DAY AND NOTIFY HD THAT THEY
WANT TO GET IT. I COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WHEN I WAS IN
THAT CITY COUNCIL I WOULD DRIVE
UP AND DOWN. SOME OF OUR
STREETS AND HAVE SOME CLEAR
PROBLEMS WITH SOME HOTEL MOTEL
AND LIVING AND USED TO THINK
THEN WHY DON'T POINT WHERE CAN
WE JUST MAKE HOUSING OUT OF
THIS SO IT'S A LONG TIME COMING
AND I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND.
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TAKE A
BIT LONGER SOMETIMES TO GET THE
FINANCING TOGETHER. WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE FOR THAT TIME. THE TO
THE- THEY YOU SIR I GO LOOK
FOR. TO WORKING. YOU TO. MAKE
SURE THAT WE'VE CLARIFIED-
WHATEVER CONDITIONS MAY EXIST
IN TERMS OF ACCESS TO RUN FIRST
IF USE OF THANK YOU. A SIMILAR
COMMENTS- RECOMMENDING AND I'D
VOTE ON THIS AND I APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS- I ASSUME THAT-
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL BE
FULLY CONSULTING WITH HOUSING
COMMITTEE STAFF ON HOUSING
ISSUES- IN THIS. IN THIS BILL-
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S A GOOD ONE I AGREE THAT
WE- THERE ARE A LOT OF MOTELS
AND SHOULD BE CONVERTED TO
HOUSING- I AM SENSITIVE TO THE
ARMED OPPOSITION OUR ARGUMENTS
EXCEPT FOR THE ARGUMENT THAT
MARKET RATE HOUSING ISN'T
CURRENTLY- GENDER FINANCES
THINK ABOUT IS- INACCURATE-
HOWEVER. WE DID CREATE A RIGHT
OF FIRST REFUSAL PRODUCTS HOME
CAN APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AGREED TO THAT AMENDMENT- IF WE
HAD UNLIMITED. PROJECTS GOING
TO MONEY. AND THIS BILL
WOULDN'T EVEN BE- YES IN SOME
WAY- BUT THERE MORE OF THESE
MOTELS WHEN THERE'S FUNDING TO
ACQUIRE THEM FOR PROJECTS HOME
KEY WHAT I DON'T WANT IS FOR
BECAUSE IT'S TO SIT THERE FOR
AND THE SECURITY TIME WHEN THEY
COULD BE TURNED IN THE HOUSING
AND UNDERSTANDING THE 9090% OF
THE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
LIVE IN MARKET RATE HOUSING THE
IDEA THAT WERE GOING TO SOLVE
OUR HOUSING CRISIS WITHOUT A
MIX OF SUBSIDIZED BELOW MARKET
RATE ON MERCURY HOUSING THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT I- THAT I
AGREE WITH. I WILL SAY THAT- IN
TERMS OF THE ANTI DISPLACEMENT
PROTECTIONS WE HAVE A ONE YEAR
PROTECTION- I WOULD LIKE TO
CONSIDER CONTINUE TO GIVE
THOUGHT TO HELP MAYBE THAT
COULD BE STRENGTHENED BECAUSE
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO SEE IS
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY FULL
TIME LIVING THERE GET CLEARED
OUT- IF EVERY IF THE ENTIRE
STATE OF WAS- SUBJECT
AFFECTIVELY SUBJECT TO THE
ELLIS ACT I WOULD SAY WE WOULD
JUST SAY NO ELLIS ACT
EVICTIONS- WHEN THIS IS
UTILIZED BUT THAT WOULD ONLY
REALLY EFFECTIVELY PROTECT
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN RENT
CONTROLLED- JURISDICTIONS- SO-
WITH THAT. SAID I AM
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTES- AND
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. BY CENTER
WHERE SKI. CENTER AND MANY MANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND AS A
AND HE KNOWS AND HAS WORKED ON
COMPLICATED. IS VERY CALM.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU START THE
NEEDLE TO GET POKED IN THE EYE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM CENTER BY CAL SKI.
BETTER CONSULTING CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE BATES. CABALLERO
CORTICES HI CORTESE AYE MCGUIRE
BUT SHOW A BOOK. SKINNER AMBER
HI AMBER I WILL CASKEY HI
CASKEY ARE FOR. OKAY WE'LL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB SIX SEVENTY
NINE- BY SENATOR COM LONGER
CENTER WELCOMES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS IS MY FIRST SENATE BILL
PRESENTATION. WELCOME TO THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE I'M AFRAID. I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SIX
SEVEN NINE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY REGIONAL HOUSING FINANCE
ACT WHICH WILL CREATE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SOLUTIONS AGENCY ALSO
KNOWN AS LHASA TO FUND OUR WHAT
CASA I'M SORRY TO FUND OUR
COUNTY WIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS. L. A. COUNTY HAVE
STRUGGLED FOR DECADES TO CREATE
AND PUSH A COHERENT COUNTY WIDE
APPROACH TO PROTECTION
PRESERVATION AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION SOME CITIES
HAVE HISTORICALLY DONE A LOT
AND OTHERS HAVE DONE NOTHING.
IN THE COUNTY HAS TRIED TO FILL
THE GAPS AS A RESULT
UNFORTUNATELY ARE COUNTY RANKS
LAST IN THE NATION AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY OVERCROWDING AND
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS. THIS
HAS RESULTED IN A RAMPANT
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THE RACIAL
SEGREGATION IN OVERCROWDING OF
HOMES AND LOWER INCOME BLACK
AND BROWN FAMILIES BEING PUSHED
OUT OF THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES AT AN ALARMING RATE.
79% OF EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN L. A. COUNTY ARE
SPENDING MORE THAN HALF OF
THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING
COMPARED TO JUST 3% OF MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THE PANDEMIC
HAS ONLY FURTHER EXACERBATED
THE HOUSING CRISIS PARTICULARLY
FOR BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES
AND IT HAS MADE EVEN CLEARER
WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW TO BE
TRUE. THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING FORCED TO MAKE UNTENABLE
CHOICES IN WHERE AND HOW THEY
LIVE. WE ARE CLEARLY NOT DOING
ENOUGH TO PRESERVE AND CREATE
HOES FOR WORKING CLASS AND
LOWER INCOME PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTY. THE HOUSING CRISIS IS
REGIONAL IN NATURE. IN FAR TOO
GREAT TO BE ADDRESSED
INDIVIDUALLY BY THE COUNTY'S
EIGHTY EIGHT INCORPORATED
CITIES. SO ORIGINAL CHALLENGE
REQUIRES A REGIONAL SOLUTION.
SB SIX SEVEN NINE OFFERS A WAY
FORWARD FOR A UNIFIED
COORDINATED COUNTY WIDE
APPROACH. TO CREATE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF ALL
RENTERS IN EVERY JURISDICTION.
SB SIX SEVEN NINE WHICH IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF ACTIVISTS ORGANIZER'S UNIONS
AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS WILL
CREATE A HOLISTIC COUNTY WIDE
APPROACH. TO SUPPORTING RENTERS
PRESERVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND CREATING NEW HOUSING FOR
WORKING IN LOW INCOME PEOPLE AT
A MUCH LARGER SCALE. IT IS ALSO
AN L. A. COUNTY DELEGATION
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY THIS YEAR.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A NEW
INDEPENDENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS
AGENCY FOR L. A. COUNTY WITH
THE POTENTIAL TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE OUR DEDICATED
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT CREATION
OF NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND RENTER PROTECTION
AND SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES THE NEW AGENCY TO
GENERATE LOCAL TAX REVENUE BY
PLACING A MEASURE ON THE COUNTY
WIDE BALLOT FOR A PARCEL TAX
GROSS RECEIPTS BUSINESS LICENSE
BUSINESSES. FOR A DOCUMENTARY
TRANSFER TAX. THIS BILL ALSO
ELEVATES NON TAX STRATEGIES
LIKE ISSUING BONDS IN BRINGING
IN PRIVATE CAPITAL FOR. AT
LEAST 50% OF THE REVENUES
GENERATED MUST BE SPENT ON NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
AND OWNERSHIP FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS WHICH IS DEFINED AS
EARNING LESS THAN 80% OF AREA
MEDIA INCOME WITH ADDITIONAL
SET ASIDES. FOR VERY LOW INCOME
AND EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS 3240% MUST BE
ALLOCATED FOR IN A PROTECTION
AND SUPPORT PROGRAMS LIKE A
COUNTY WIDE RIGHT TO COUNSEL
AND NO MORE THAN 10% CAN BE
SPENT ON ADMIN AND OPERATIONS.
I THINK THIS BILL MEETS THE
MOMENT. AND BILLS ON THE GOOD
ORK OF THE BAY AREA- WITH ITS
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. AND
OFFERS A WAY FORWARD FOR L. A.
COUNTY AT A SCALE WHICH WE
DESPERATELY NEED. WITH ME AND
SUPPORT OUR ELISE BUKE CEO OF
THE UNITED WAY OF GREATER LA.
SHE'S THE PRESIDENT. AT SPONSOR
ORGANIZATION OF THIS BILL AND
JOSIE CLAIRE FOND OF TRUST
SOUTH LA. THANK YOU SENATOR
OKAY WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR LEAD
SUPPORTERS WHO EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES- POLICE PUKE AND THEN-
JOSIE OUR CAR FUND. MISTER
FIFTY WOULD BE MINDFUL OF YOUR
TWO MINUTES SO THAT YOU DON'T-
TAKE TIME AWAY. FROM JERSEY CAR
FUNDS SO. ABSOLUTELY ADD THANK
YOU SO MUCH- WE ARE SO PROUD TO
BE SPONSORING SB SIX SEVENTY
NINE. WHICH WE FEEL IS AN
INNOVATIVE SOLUTION TO BRING
COORDINATION EFFICIENCY AND
FOCUS OUR HOUSING EFFORTS IN L.
A. COUNTY. EVEN AS WE HAVE
COLLECTIVELY DOUBLE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE LEAVING HOMELESSNESS
AND L. A. COUNTY ARE
HOMELESSNESS IS NEVER THE LESS
INCREASE. AND WE KNOW WHY WE
ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH TO SUPPORT
RENTERS TO PRESERVE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WE HAVE
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'RE NOT
CREATING NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. OVER THE LAST DECADE
WE HAVE LOST TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS THAT RENT FOR
LESS THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH IF EVER THERE WAS A
CRISIS THIS IS IT. WE FEEL THAT
SB SIX SEVENTY NINE BRINGS WHAT
WE DESPERATELY NEED WHICH IS A
REGIONAL APPROACH WE CANNOT
CONTINUE THE PATCHWORK AND
FRAGMENTED APPROACH WE HAVE
HERE IN THE COUNTY AND OUR GOAL
IS TO CREATE A FRAMEWORK THAT
BRINGS THE MANY GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES TOGETHER. TO FOCUS ON
THE CHALLENGE WITH THE
RESOURCES- TENSIONS THAT IT A
MAN. WHO WERE DEEPLY PROUD TO
BE STANDING WITH ORGANIZATIONS
YEAR SUPPORTING THIS BILL FROM
LABOUR PUBLIC SERVICE PROVIDERS
DEVELOPERS AND JUSTICE
ADVOCATE. TO YOU ALL AGREE THAT
THIS IS A SYSTEMIC CHANGE WE
NEED I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
COM LONGER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
AND URGENCY RIGHT OUT OF THE
GATE AND THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. AND WE ARE COMMITTED
AT UNITED WAY TO DOING OUR PART
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS- IN
THE UPCOMING WEEKS AND MONTHS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE ARE NOT HERE FOR JERSEY
CHOSE CLOUGH FUND- FROM TRUSTS
SOUTH LA. SENATOR IS MY NAME IS
JESSE CLEAR FIND AND THE
COALITION IS AN EXTERNAL
RELATIONS MANAGER WENT. AWAY
OUR ORGANIZATION IS PROUD TO BE
PART OF THE COALITION THAT
ACCORDING SB SIX SEVENTY NINE.
BY THE WAY IS A COMMUNITY BASED
EFFORT THAT WORKS AT THE WHITE
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OUT THE
DOWNTOWN LA. INCREASED PROPERTY
VALUES AND RENTS HAVE PUSHED
OUT MANY LONG TERM RESIDENTS.
OUR MISSION IS A THIRD OF THE
ELECTORATE COMMUNITY CONTROLLED
LAND. WE WORK WITH SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
THE COUNTY AND ARE COMMITTED TO
THE LIBERATION OF BLACK AND
BROWN ANGELINA'S FROM THE
HISTORICAL FACTS AND RACIALIZED
REDLINING AND DISINVESTMENT. I
CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH HOW MUCH
PUBLIC ITS INVESTMENT HAD HURT
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD. NOT ONLY HAD
WE NOT INVESTED ENOUGH IN
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
L. A. COUNTY OR CREATING ANY
COUNTY WIDE APPROACH. WE ALSO
HAVE NOT CREATED BURDENS OF
MONEY THAT ARE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH
TO SUPPORT THE LESIONS LIKE
FRANCHISE. AND THE WORK WE DO
TO ACQUIRE AND PROTECTED
HOUSING. THE ANSWER TO OUR
HOUSING CRISIS ARE NOT JUST
TRADITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCING WE MUST SUPPORT
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS LIKE
COMMUNITY OWNERSHIP WHICH
PRVENTS LOW INCOME HOUSING
FROM ENTERING THE SPECULATIVE
REAL ESTATE MARKET. ESPECIALLY
IN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY TRAUMATIZED.
AND DISPLACED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. CHECK OUT THE LATEST
AND JOHN REPORT OF B. SEVENTY.
BECAUSE IT BRING COUNTY.
FOCUSED THE PRO TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN HIT
THE HARDEST BY AND I'M- IT
WOULD BRING THE- DEDICATED
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED FOR OUR
PEOPLE TO DRIVE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
I URGE A YES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND- WE WILL NOW GO TO.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENTS- IN
THE GALLERY I SEE MISSILE IN
WALKING UP.THIS IS SUPPORT
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU- IN
MY HAND ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU- I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE ELSE. IN THE GALLERY
WILL THEN GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I. PLEASE QUEUE UP.
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVENTY NINE
AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE SIMPLY
SEND YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION
IF ANY. AND THE SIMPLE FACT OF
YOUR SUPPORT. CERTAINLY MISTER
CHAIR TO MINISTERS SUPPORT FOR
S. B. SIX SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CRYSTALLINE NUMBERED SIXTY ONE
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD WILL HAVE TO
USE. FIVE SIXTY OAKLAND. ALL
GOING ON THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE TO SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SERRA
FLOCK REPRESENTING UNITE HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN REPRESENTING
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND WORKERS IN
HOTELS AND RESTAURANTS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THE LION TWO FIFTY THREE YOUR
HEAD PLEASE. HELLO THANK YOU MY
NAME IS ERIN ACCOUNTS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY-
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX SEVENTY
NINE. ONE TO TWENTY THREE GO
AHEAD PLEASE- AFTERNOON-
SENATORS MY NAME IS DANIEL HAMM
CHAIR OF THE INTERFAITH
SOLIDARITY NETWORK FIFTY
PORTRAYED COMMUNITIES IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY OF LOS
ANGELES WRITING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE COLLECTED MORE
REGIONAL APPROACH OF SB SIX SIX
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. BLIND
TO FIFTY NINE YEAR OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SO WE HAD TO
LEAVE SHALL I ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. A LINE TO
FIFTY FIVE YEAR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. K. BAN ON BEHALF OF
BRIDGE HOUSING AT THE PORT
THANK YOU. ONE ONE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AMY SURE WOULD BE COMMUNITY
GROUP AS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
TWENTY TWO FORTY NINE LINES
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS ACTUALLY
WANT NOT BE HALF THE DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER A PROUD MEMBER
OF THE OUR FUTURE LA COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVEN. THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN TO
THE MEASURE SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO WE'RE GOING
ADELINE TO FIFTY TWO LASSEN
KEUCHEL HAS LONG TO COME TO
EUROPE. IT DIDN'T HAPPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON BETTER GET GOING WITH
FIGURE OUT INTERESTS AND ALSO A
PROUD MEMBER OF OUR FUTURE LAKE
POLLUTION AND CALLING IN
CONCORD. WE DID GET ONE MORE IN
LINE SIXTY TRYING ONCE AGAIN TO
GET YOUR LINE IS OPEN AGAIN
GOING TO PLEASE. BUT THE ONE
HUNDRED. AS AMENDED HOUSING LA
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU DON'T
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
CONSPICUOUS QUICKER. OKAY THANK
YOU- WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO- THE
OPPONENTS- IS OR ANYONE THE
GALLERY YES PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
LATE APPOINTMENT YOU'RE WELCOME
TO TAKE. THE REMOTE CONTROL
EXPLAIN YOUR POSITION AT THE
BOTTOM OF A BRIEF MARC STIVERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION YET. BUT WE WILL BE
EXPRESSING CONCERNS THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THE MINUTES THAT WERE
TAKEN JUST LAST WEEK. YEAH THE
UNION ONLY A LANGUAGE AND- YOU
KNOW UNLESS REASONABLE
GUARDRAILS ARE PUT IN PLACE TO
PREVENT EXCESSIVE COSTS
INCREASES THIS LANGUAGE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERMINE THE
BILL'S INTENT WHICH IS TO
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THAT REGARD. THANK
YOU. TO REVIEW COULD GO OUTSIDE
AND WORK THIS OUT SO WE CAN
HAVE A GROUNDS. RESOLUTION
CENTER CALLER WELCOME THE
HOUSING. HOUSING COMMITTEE-
OKAY- I SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY- I SEE NO ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AS THE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX SEVENTY NINE. STE
SERVICE TO ENSURE SEAMLESS
OPPOSITION ON SIX SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE
ZERO PROPOSITION PLEASE. AND
WITH THOSE TRIALS MISTER
CHAIRMAN NO RESPONSE HE WAS
EMPTY GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- YES.
SOME TO THINKING. VETERANS BOTH
I'M SORRY SENATOR TELEGRAM
THINKING RIGHT NOW. WITH
REGARDS TO YOUR- TO YOUR BILL
I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS DO WE
ALREADY HAVE IN MY CONCERN IS
THAT THIS IS ANOTHER OVERSIGHT
OR ANOTHER LEVEL OF. GOVERNMENT
AND OVERSEEING THE- THE ISSUES
AT HAND WITH HOUSING IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IN ONE OF OUR
VERY FIRST COMMITTEE AT ON
HEARINGS ON I BELIEVE IT WAS
HOMELESSNESS OR HOUSING I THINK
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN HOMELESS AS
THEY DISCUSS THE AND WIDE ARRAY
OF ORGANIZATIONS IN DEALING
WITH AT. THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. AND- THE LACK CAN.
THAT NOT EVERYBODY KNOWING
EXACTLY WHAT EVERYBODY'S DOING
SO I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS AS
TO WHY DID YOU FEEL COMPELLED
TO CREATE ANOTHER YET ANOTHER
AGENCY TO OVERSEE- THIS ISSUE-
DO YOU BECAUSE I THINK- SENATOR
YOU ALMOST ANSWERED THE
QUESTION WITH A QUESTION. THE
REALITY IS THAT NOT EVERYONE
KNOWS WHAT EVERYONE IS DOING WE
IN L. A. COUNTY WE HAVE EIGHTY
EIGHT CITIES WE ALSO HAVE THE
LARGE A CITY THAT IS LOS
ANGELES AND WE HAVE THE COUNTY.
AND TO BE QUITE HONEST EVERYONE
IS DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE- OR A LAKE
CITY WE HAVE LOST SO WHICH
FOCUSES ON HOMELESSNESS BUT IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DO A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS HOUSING AUTHORITY. THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO AND SO THIS
ISN'T CREATING ANY OTHER FORM
OF GOVERNMENT BUT IT IS
CREATING AN AGENCY TO HELP
COORDINATE THE DESPERATE
EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING ON IN
OUR COUNTY. AS IT RELATES TO
HOW WE'RE ABLE TO ACCELERATE
PRODUCTION HOUSING PRESERVATION
AND SUPPORTING RENTERS- WE NEED
AN ENTITY THAT CAN CONVENE- ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS. WE NEED AN
ENTITY THAT CAN STREAMLINE ALL
OF THE PROCESSES THAT ARE IN
PLACE- AND WE NEED TO BE MORE
TETHERED TO ONE ANOTHER AS IT
RELATES TO FINDING THE
SOLUTIONS RATHER THAN HAVING
EIGHTY EIGHT DIFFERENT-
RESPONSES TO THE CHALLENGES
THAT ALL OF US ARE FACING AS IT
RELATES TO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS SO. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE- THAT
KIND OF TETHERING AND MORE
COORDINATED AND STREAMLINING
APPROACH SO IF I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY YOU'RE SAYING IS THIS
IS THIS WOULD BE THE OVERSIGHT.
AGENCY THAT SEASON EVERYBODY
ELSE AND PUTS IT ALL TOGETHER
WELL I ALSO WANT TO INVITE AT.
LEAST TO- HELP. RESPOND BECAUSE
I TO MAKE THAT YOUR- GETTING
THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION. I
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY SAY THAT
THIS AGENCY WOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO TELL THE CITY'S
WHAT TO DO- BUT AS IT RELATES
TO PROCESS SEES AS IT RELATES
TO MAYBE HOW TO MAKE POLICIES
MORE EFFICIENT AS IT RELATES TO
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE
RAISE MORE REVENUE. AS IT
RELATES TO HAVING A COORDINATED
RESPONSE TO RENTER PROTECTIONS
AND THE RIGHT TO COUNSEL THIS
WOULD BE AN AGENCY THAT WOULD
ABLE BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW HOW
THE- THE ANSWERS TO SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES OR- THE
OPERATIONAL POLICIES FOR A LOT
OF THOSE CHALLENGES- I DON'T
KNOW IF THE LEASE IS STILL ON
THE LINE AND MAYBE SHE WANTS TO
ADD. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
OPERATE THE COMMON. YES THANK
YOU- YOU KNOW I WILL TELL YU
WE ARE IN ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS
RIGHT NOW WITH- MANY COUNTY AND
LOCAL CITY GOVERNMENT AND
THEY'RE- VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY AND I THINK CENTER
CALL MUNGER REALLY SPELLED IT
OUT. WHILE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FOCUS. ON THE HOMELESS
HOUSING. REALLY ALLOWS US TO
LOOK AT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SIDE AND- TO REALLY NOT THE WAY
TO THE ISLAND AND OURSELF BUT
LOOK AT A REGIONAL APPROACH OUT
OF THE- EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES WE
HAVE LESS THAN TEN ARE REALLY
FOCUSING LOCAL REVENUE ON
THESE- RENTER PROTECTION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN CREATION.
AND THEY ARE READY TO GO AND SO
THIS VEHICLE REALLY WILL ALLOW
THEM TO COME TOGETHER WE CAN
STRATEGICALLY AND THEN UP TOP
AWAY ACCESS ANY PUBLIC REVENUES
AND ALSO PRIVATE REVENUE LIKE
BALL AND- TO- I THINK IT'S
REALLY FEELING FILLING A GAP
THAT IT THAT IT FEELS LIKE
LABOR OR COMMUNITY GROUPS
BUSINESSES AND. GOVERNMENT ARE
ASKING FOR RIGHT NOW. THREE IN
ORDER WHAT'S I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION- WITH REGARDS TO THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD AT THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS- WITH IS THIS.
HOW DOES THE- FIRST OF ALL LET
ME JUST GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER. WELL I WOULD
SAY THAT- WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT CONSTRUCTION IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT BUILDING ANYTHING
THAT WE ARE PAYING A DIGNIFIED
WAGE IN THAT WE ARE PROTECTING
THOSE THAT ARE DOING THE HARD
WORK OF CONSTRUCTING HOUSING.
AND I THINK I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THERE'S A LARGE COMMITMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE EITHER
UNIT USING. UNION LABOR WORKING
WITH PLA'S. ULTIMATELY THE GOAL
IS TO BE ABLE TO- ADD MORE
UNITS- TO BUILD HOMES THAT
PEOPLE. WHO BUILD THEM CAN ALSO
AFFORD TO LIVE IN- AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE- CHURNING
EIGHT A VERY PRODUCTIVE- YOU
KNOW ECONOMIC RECOVERY AS IT
RELATES TO JOBS. OKAY SO THIS
WOULD BE RESTRICTED TO ONLY.
UNION IT PROJECT UNION LABOR
CONTRACTS IS THAT WELL SO I
WILL SAY THAT- MOST AGREEMENTS
THAT ARE ENTERED INTO- IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY- EITHER ARE DONE
WITH- LABOR SUPPORT- EITHER
USING UNION LABOR OR SPECIFYING
LPLA AGREEMENTS AND THIS
WOULDN'T BE ANY DIFFERENT. FIVE
IT IS CLEAR FROM THAT THE BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE UNION IT
REQUIRES A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE AT A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THE- OF THE
WORKERS COME OUT OF- THE
SKILLED APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM-
AND I WILL OFTEN BE IN A UNION
SHOP. BUT IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE SO JUST
TO CLARIFY THAT. SO EVERYONE
HAS AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO BE
A DENTIST JOBS AND WORK AND
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK. IS
THAT CORRECT YES. OKAY THE IDEA
IS TRYING TO AND WE WANT TO
HAVE. THE IDEAS IS TO HAVE
SKILLED APPRENTICES- THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE YEAR THE HIGHEST
CALIBER COMMUNITIES
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS- AND TO
HAVE. YOU KNOW AND. NOT HAVE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS LIVING IN
POVERTY. I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BID ON THE
SHOPS- I JUST JUST. VETERANS. I
WILL ADD THAT THE I WAS ALREADY
THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THE
AUTHORITY IS TO GET A HARNESS-
REVENUE OPPORTUNITIES TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESSES BY
WHICH THE CITIES ARE LOOKING
TO- A CONSTRUCT THEM AND ALSO
TO SUPPORT RENTERS IT THE
AGENCY WILL NOT BE IN THE
BUSINESS OF ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
BUILDING- HOMES OR UNITS
ITSELF- BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT. THE
TRUSTS AND OTHER ENTITIES THAT
ARE INVOLVED THAT WOULD BE
DOING SO I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
THAT CLARIFICATION TO THIS IS
IN A CONSTRUCTION AGENCY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NINE- I AM RECOMMENDING
AN AYE VOTE ON WAS GOING TO
FIND. OUT OF THE AUTHOR- AND
HER SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH
OUR COMMITTEE- TO BUILD OUT THE
USES OF. THE FUNDS WHICH HAVE
NOW BEEN AMENDED INTO THE BILL
ALSO THANK YOU FOR THAT I WANT
TO SAY A FEW YEARS AGO- WE-
AND- THE BAY AREA LA WE WILL OF
FRIENDLY RIVALRY BUT IT'S A
LOVING- FROM THE RIVALRY AND-
WE LEARN FROM EACH OTHER SO LA
A FEW YEARS AGO. MASSIVE
TRANSPORTATION MEASURE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO NOW DO IN THE
BAY AREA TWO YEARS AGO WE IN
THE BAY AREA PASS WE WILL PASS
LEGISLATION HERE TO AUTHORIZE
THIS KIND OF MODEL. FOR THE BAY
AREA AND IT'S TERRIFIC THAT LA
IS NOW MOVING FORWARD. ON THE
GOVERNANCE ASPECTS WILL BE
DEALT WITH IN THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE- COMMITTEE IT'S
MORE COMPLICATED FOR LA. AND
THE BAY AREA IN THE BAY AREA WE
WERE ARE CONTIGUOUS WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF THEIR
GOVERNMENTS IN THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. SO
WE HAD AN EXISTING GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE BECAUSE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS OF GOVERNMENT IS
NUMEROUS COUNTIES NOT JUST L.
A. COUNTY ON A SEPARATE
STRUCTURE WILL HAVE TO BE
CREATED- TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE. DIVERSE REPRESENTATION
AND ACCOUNTABILITY- AND STRONG
LEGAL STRUCTURE- TO IT SO
THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE A SEPARATE ENTITY AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WORKING. WITH
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND HIS-
TALENTED STAFF WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH. THOSE ISSUES- SO
I'M RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL- AND WITHOUT CENTER
YOU MAY CLOSE. SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR YOU SAID MUCH OF WHAT I
WAS GOING TO SAY IN MY CLOTHES
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT
THERE ARE ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH ALL LEVELS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON THIS BILL-
HAPPENING IN REAL TIME. AND THE
GOAL IS TO HAVE- ALL OF THE
ISSUES RESULT AS A REAL TO THE-
STRUCTURE OF THE BEEF. OUR
DEADLINEWITH THE AND HAVE BEEN
IN. TALKS WITH THE- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT
I ALSO WANT TO ADD THAT ON TO
YOUR POINT- WE ARE LEARNED FROM
THE OBSTACLES THAT WERE FACED
WITH AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN-
IN THE BAY AREA- AS WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH SB SIX SEVEN
NINE. AND WE ARE GRATEFUL- FOR
WHAT THE BAY AREA WAS ABLE TO
STEP FORWARD AND DO. TO MAKE
THEIR HOUSING AUTHORITY A
REALITY- SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE- AND I'VE
GOT THAT'S THE RIVER MOTION ON
THIS BILL. CENTER CORTEZ HE
OKAY MADAM CONTROL CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR CALL BLOCKER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WIENER HI WIENER HI BATES.
CABALLERO CORTESE ALL RIGHT
CORTESE I'D REQUIRE LET'S SHOW
ABOVE HI THE CHORE BOTH EYES%
SKINNER BY SKINNER I NUMBER.
WOOD CAL SKI WITH HUSKY I. FIVE
THREE FIVE VOTES WHICH IS
SUFFICIENT BUT WE'LL PUT OUR ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SO- I HAVE TO
GO TO GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE TO
VOTE. BEFORE THEY SHUT THE
COMMITTEE DOWN CENTER BATES IS
NOT HERE SO I CAN WHICH IS
GOING TO TAKE LIKE A LIKE A
THREE MINUTE- RECESS- AND THEN
WE BACK- TO DO SB SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE SO- GOT MOMENTARILY NOW'S
A GOOD TIME TO USE THE
FACILITIES ARE GOING TO DRINK
OF COFFEE OR WATER- WAY BACK
JUST IN A COUPLE OF MINUTES.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA AND THE
RECESS. AND I'LL GO BACK TO
ARIZONA AND HOUSING COMMITTEE-
THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN SB SEVEN SIXTY FIVE I
CENTER STERN- AS I NOTED AT THE
BEGINNING. WE WILL NOT BE
VOTING ON SB SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
TODAY AT THE REQUEST OF THE
UTHOR. THIS WILL BE A HEARING
ON THE BILL SO CENTER STERN
WILL. PRESENT THE BILL- WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS. AND THEN
THE BILL WILL BECOME A TWO
YEAR- BILL SO WE APPRECIATE-
CENTER STERN. BY TAKING THAT
STEP- AND WE ARE JOINED BY
SENATOR STERN I BELIEVE YOU'LL
NEED TO IDENTIFY IF YOU HAVE
ANY STAFFERS. WITH YOU IN YOUR
OFFICE WALKING SENATOR. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. I MEAN JUST
MICHAEL IN MY COMING THROUGH
OKAY YEAH YOU'RE FINE OKAY
GREAT- MY DISTRICT DIRECTOR IS.
NOT THE ROOM IN MY OFFICE-
JERRY WALLS SO YOU'RE ON SITE
AND I APPRECIATE YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN YOUR STAFF BUT NOT
JUST FOR TAKING A HARD LOOK AT
THIS LEGISLATION- BUT ALSO FOR
ACCOMMODATING YESTERDAY DID TO
PRESENT THIS BILL- AS WE DO
MAKE IT TO YOUR BILL AND
HOPEFULLY TRY TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES
AND MOVE. THIS ISSUE FORWARD
THIS YEAR- DID. THIS THIS MAN
IS WAS IT. INTENDED TO BE A
VERY NARROW FIX OF OUR
UNDERLYING- ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNIT LAWS. TO ENSURE THAT-
WHILE WORKING IN SMALLER.
PROPERTIES ARE STILL ABLE TO
PURSUE BOTH JUNIOR EIGHTY YOU
SAY THE GARAGE. FOR A BACKYARD
EAGLES THEY HAVE SPACE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND AMEND ALL TO THOSE
KINDOF OPPORTUNITIES. IN MY
DISTRICT IN OUR DISTRICT STATE.
SEN LARGER CLIENTS. WORLD MORE
SUBURBAN AREAS. WE THOUGHT IT
IMPORTANT PUT FORWARD MEASURE
YOU TRY DOING GOOD BEHAVIOR SO-
EVERYONE CAN REALLY EMBRACE THE-
THIS GROWTH IN IT HE AROUND
STATE AND I THINK IS REALLY
CREW TO BE HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE NUMBER. COST EFFECTIVE MAY-
SO THE BILL WILL BE GIVE SOME
SLACK- TO GOVERNMENTS LOOK AT
SET- IN CASE. WHERE ARE TO PUT-
THAT NEWLY YOU- RIGHT DO THEIR
NEIGHBORS THEY MAY HAVE A
BETTER IT THEY'RE JUST- NOT SO
A LA. THAT DOES THE USING WE BE
THIS IS- STOPPED. OR LIMITED IN
ANY WAY BUT TRYING TO SAY THEN
IS- IT IS NAY. AND IS-
CONFORMING OF A MAN IS I THINK
WOULD WOULD DO BE. FOR HOUSING
PRODUCTION- INTO PREVENTIVE
ENTITY QUAN CONCERT FROM AND OF
BILLS HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED YEARS- AS A
MEMBER FRIEDMAN ACTUALLY
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE TO ME WHO'D
BEEN CARRYING A SIMILAR
LEGISLATION I DELETED YOU
PRODUCTION BUT IT'S SEEN IN IN
HER COMMUNITY- SOME OF THESE
ISSUES ALREADY STARTING TO POP
UP- SO. YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT TO
SAY FOR THE RECORD AND ONE OF
THE REASONS WE WANT TO SLOW
DOWN HERE- AND TAKE SOME TIME
IS THAT. FOR SMALLER LOTS WE
RECOGNIZE THE BILL DOESN'T
REALLY DISTINGUISH MEANS SMALL
AND LARGER LOTS AND WE DID NOT-
NEEDS TO BE SEEN AS SOME
SIGNAL- TO. STOP EVERY FOR
PUTTING A THEIR BACKYARDS- MORE
VERY. TO AMENDMENTS OR J. TO
DISLODGE- OVER THE NEXT. YOU
KNOW OVER THE COURSE OF THIS
TWO YEAR SESSION THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO CITY LIMIT THE
APPLICATION OF THIS BILL TO
LARGER LOT SIZES- IF YOU HAVE A
HALF ACRE OR AN ACRE OF
PROPERTY. AND YOU'RE PUTTING
ANY TO YOU RIGHT UP AGAINST THE
FENCE LINE- AND SAY- YOU KNOW-
IMPEDING. YOUR NEIGHBORS
ENJOYMENT OF THEIR PROPERTY-
THERE'S THERE ARE TO BE A
BETTER OPTION THAN THAT SO-
THAT'S SORT OF WHERE WE'RE
HOPING WE CAN LAND THIS- BUT I
RECOGNIZE THIS IS. A SENSITIVE
ISSUE AND HE'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME ON MORE CONSIDERED
NEGOTIATING SO- THAT'S WHY
WE'RE STILL IN THE MEASURE DOWN
TODAY BUT I DO APPRECIATE- THE
ENGAGEMENT FROM A LOT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS A-
HOUSING PROPONENTS OUT THERE I
THINK WE'VE GOT. A LEGAL CITIES
AND- A NUMBER OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT HERE
BUT- BUT WE DO NOT INTENDED TRY
TO GIVE A STATE FARM OR IN ANY
WAY ROLLOVER. FOLKS WHO WANT TO
SAY YES IN THEIR BACKYARDS
BECAUSE I AGREE WE SHOULD BE
SAYING YES IT'S JUST A WE'RE IN
THAT BACKYARD ARE WE SAYING YES
AND IF YOU PICK THE BEST SPOT I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE GOOD FOR
OVERALL HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA SO. WITH THAT I'LL
TURN IT BACK TO- THE LINES I
THINK- WE HAVE. TO READ WRITE
LETTERS AND LETTERS
ARCHITECTURE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE MECHANICS THE
LEGISLATION'S WAS ACTUALLY
TEST- WHO'S WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LINES OF LOCAL ELECTED.
TESTIFYING REMOTELY HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES OF TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES. BY JULIE
TODD. FROM THE CAL LINE OF
LOCAL ELECTED. AND RYAN LEVEL
FROM LEVEL PARK. EACH OF YOU
WILL HAVE MINUTES WE'RE GOING
TO WITH MISS. AND HIS TEST OF
YOUR BE MINE OF THE TWO MINUTES
IT YOU DON'T- REDUCE THE TIME
THAT MR LOVE US. HAVE SO START-
TO STUFF. AS A MATTER- TO BE
JUST ON THE LINE. LET ME CHECK
WHAT LASTING LOOK I'M MORE. I'M
HERE OKAY THANK YOU FOR EMAIL
PURSUED. THANK YOU HELLO I'M
TRULY. THINK DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA LINES LOCAL SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF THIS SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE AND ON BEHALF OF THE MANY
CITIES REPRESENTED IN THE MANY
SUPPORT LETTERS WE URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE DOWNSIDE OF
UNIFORMS OWNING IN THE STATE
THE CHAIRS IS CHARGED FOR THAT
ITS INDIVIDUALITY AND THE-
DIVERSITY. EIGHT PORTLET
MICROSAT ACT WHICH IS FROM YOUR
ELBOW TO YOUR HAND SHE WAS
ALWAYS ONLY INTENDED URBAN
PARCEL. AS IT IS LOGICAL ONE
DOESN'T BUILD A LARGE STRUCTURE
ON THE FENCE LINE WITH ACRES
CONSIDER A TEN ACRE ROBOT IN
KERN COUNTY A TWO ACRE SUBURBAN
LOT IN SAN DIEGO. ONE ACRE LOT
IMPACT OFTEN HAVE ALWAYS HAD
BURIED SETBACK BASED ON FIVE
COMMONSENSE IMPROVING TO
PENETRATE ALL GOOD COMMUNITY
PLANNING NOT TO MENTION FIZDALE.
BALANCE AND RATIOS. WE'LL HAVE
NOTHING TO DO JUNIOR EIGHTY YOU.
WOULD NOT BE AND- L. PRINT CO
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY FREE. ON TECHNO
EIGHTY YOU BUILD THAT LAW AND
HAVE BEEN. FOR SETBACK. EVEN
THOUGH MOST READ FOR THIS-
OVERSIGHT HAVE DAY TO MIDDLE.
TO WALK IT. MICHAEL BACK WITH
HEAVY NEGOTIATED THIS CAT
CATEGORICALLY UNTRUE WE COULD
NOT FIND WORLD FIRST OF
BERKELEY CITY WITH LARGE LARGER
THAT WORKING. AND A LITTLE CAL
CITIES OPPOSED. TELL WITH THIS
TIME HE SAID. WAS THE FOR
CITIES WHERE WHERE OF THE
INTENSE OF THE LEGISLATION TO
EVEN SEVENTY AND NOT TONIGHT
OUR STATE WE ARE PAYING
ATTENTION NOW. EMPLOYMENT AND
CITY THANK HELLO NOT ONLY. THAT
CELEBRATE EIGHT YOU PUT. AND
HARSH CAL AT THE PARTIALLY
TOWARD OUR HOW THE NUMBERS. NO
EVIDENCE THAT ANY LARGER LOT
IMMUNITY. BACK YOU. SEE THE
COURT LETTER YOUR PACKET AND
EIGHT BUT IF WE A FEW AND IT
WHY NOT. ANOMALY AND A
DISALLOWING. THAT BEHAVIOR
RATHER THAN A MONTH TONIGHT
EVERY PARCEL IN OUR GREAT STATE
BUT NOW WE FOUND THAT BURKE
URBAN. NOT ONLY THAT THE NAY BY.
FOR EIGHTEEN TWENTY ARE NOT.
WHICH ARE NOT NOVEL THEY'VE
BEEN ALL YES HOW FOR DECADES IN
OUR LAW LOT SHOULD NOT THEM
DOWN. IT IS CLOSE CURRENT LONG
FORCE PEOPLE TO BUILD THE THEIR
LINE FORTY FIVE. AND SET BACK
INTO THE- BUT BUILDERS AND
FRIENDS NEIGHBORS TAKE THE TOP.
SHOULD NOT SUPPORT ONCE GROWING
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN A LOT A
LOT HOMEOWNER WILL TAKE EIGHT I
CAN'T IMAGINE WHY HAPPEN ISSUE
CHANGING. PARDON GROUP MADE A
MAYORS. COUNCIL MEMBERS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SIXTY FIVE.
OKAY THANK YOU I MISS TESTED
TOOK ABOUT THREE AND A HALF
MINUTES SO THAT LEAVES- THIRTY
SECONDS FOR RYAN LAVIS- WORLD
FOOTBALL. RUNNING HERE'S HI I
AM BRIAN. BY ALL MY- OWN
ARCHITECT FIRM OUR WORKED ON
HOUSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MANY MANY YEARS BUT
IT ALSO SERVED AS A COMMUNITY
ARCHITECTURAL CONSULTANTS. TO
OFFER MY EXPERTISE IN OPEN I
CAN EXPLAIN TO THE COMMITTEE Y.
LARGER SETBACKS ARE GENERALLY
PAIRED WITH LARGER LOTS AND
SMALLER SETBACKS WITH SMALLER
LOTS AND WHY YOU WOULD NEVER
WANT THE IDENTICAL SET BACK
OPTION FOR ALL LARGE.
INTERSTATE DURING THIS WOULD BE
THE ANTITHESIS OF GOOD PLANNING
AND WOULD BE SAD FOR
CALIFORNIA. MY EXPERIENCE LAND
USES IMPACT ALL THINGS THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH SAFETY
ENVIRONMENT LIVABILITY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE. THERE ARE HUGE
VARIATIONS WITHIN CITIES FROM
COMMUNITY TO COMMUNITY. EVEN
STREET TO STREET. MOST CITIES
AFTER ANSWER BACK THROUGH.
CONSIDERED. TO LARGER SAID
GREATER PLAN DALY IN OUR THERE
TO CHECK THE OF BEST OF THE
MAINTAIN A STEADY. IF YOU'RE
ATTACK FIRST YOUR KIDS%
DENTISTRY VERY CLEARLY WHAT YOU
WOULD NOT TO PUT IT ORDER TO
STRUCTURE THANK YOU SO CLOSE TO
THE- AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO- ANY- PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE GALLERY THE
SUPPORT TEAM NINE ORDER ROOM
ONE TWELVE I DON'T SEE ANYONE A
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHEN I GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
SIMPLE FACT. OF YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. FIRST GO TO
LINE UP TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TERASA
BEING UP IN THE CITY IT'S A LOT
OF BEACH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NEXT WEEK NOT A LINE OF ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DIDN'T THE NICKEL GOLD AS AN
IMMIGRANT HOMEOWNER I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE DEAL THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE WILL GO TO LINE UP
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN MEXICO TELL WHAT KIND
OF TWO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ELISABETH HIGHER ROSE
BETTERMENT OF CALIFORNIA FIRM
SUPPORT OF. SEVEN SIXTY FIVE.
CONNECTION GOT WIND FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO ME THAT'S
ONE FIVE LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS RECALL WITH
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY YEARS SB SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE GOOD SENSE
MODIFICATION TO ALLOW THEM TO
SIT BETTER WITH THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS- PLEASE BE. SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE. NEXT THING ON THE
LINE OF TWO SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO SEVENTY
THREE AIRLINES OPEN. YOUR WIND
UP TO SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS TERRY GET FULL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
FORGIVENESS MALIBU COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS CALLING IN SUPPORT.
AND NEXT WEEK I'M GOING TO LINE
UP TO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI KIMBERLY PRESNEL I'M A
MEMBER OF LIVABLE CALIFORNIA.
AND REPRESENTING LONG BEACH
RANCHO SOME CARS ARE CALM HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE HAVE
BLIND OF TWO SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER TERRY NUMBER
SO THE AT THE LATEST ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CONNECTIONS
LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALIANTE FORM A RESIDENT OF
REDONDO BEACH AND A MEMBER OF
UNITE MEMBERS NEIGHBORS SUPPORT
OF. SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. NEXT WEEK
NOT A LAND OF TWO SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY
THANK YOU PORT- TURKEY GEAR-
WITH THE TELEPHONE CALL COMING
IN SO- SUPPORT ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO SUPPORT IF IT'S ALREADY BEEN
DRAWN UP IS A COVER OF THE SP
FOUR NINETY ANYTHING WE CAN GET
MORE HOUSING. NEEDS TO BE
SUPPORTED THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE ZERO IS OPEN.
WE GO ONLINE UP TO EIGHTY TWO.
LINES OPEN. THE CONCERN BY WITH
THE MONITOR THIRTY WITHTHE
PRACTICE AND THANK YOU CAN
DISCERN. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FORTY GRANT YES HELLO
HI A MAJOR SETBACK REVERE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND IT'S
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED HOMEOWNERS
AND A MEMBER OF THE UNITED
NEIGHBORS- SB SEVEN SIX FIVE
EIGHT CITIES AT CRUCIAL SPACE
BETWEEN HOMES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT AND FIXING SO THAT
HOUSING CAN BE OFFERING A VERY
MUCH NOTTHANK. YOU VERY THANK
YOU. ANNEXES TWO EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS A
GENTLE MEREKA CITY OF LAFAYETTE
AND HEY WE ARE EXPERIENCING A
FABULOUS SURGE IN ANY DO YOU
GROW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUIETLY HAPPENING TOMORROW
THANK YOU WILL KNOW YOUR
SUPPORT. NEXT IS BLIND. TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
ONE MOMENT HERE. SENATOR STERN.
WE HAVE. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AND AGAIN
FROM LOS ANGELES A FRANKLIN
COURT OF COMMUNITIES UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND- AND ALSO I
SUPPORT LITTLE. WE SUPPORT THIS
WE WANTED KELLY WE'VE DO WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. GREAT
THANK YOU ABOUT MOVED
OPPOSITION WE HAVE. FIFTY TO
LEAD UPON WITNESSES MATT REGAN
FROM THE BAY AREA COUNCIL ANTI
DAVID FROM THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES- WILL GO TO MISTER
REGAN FIRST MISTER REAGAN IF
YOU'LL PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF TWO
OF YOUR TWO MINUTES OF IT YOU
DON'T REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
MISTER DAVID CAN SPEAK- SO
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
MATT REGAN FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I WOULD NOT DARE STEAL
ANYTIME FROM MY FRIEND TODD BUT
THAT. IS NOT MEGAN FROM THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL I'M ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CRISTINA
COALITION A STATEWIDE ISSUE
ADVOCACY GROUP I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF BOTH GROUPS TODAY.
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
IDENTIFIED TO ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS OF THE POTENTIAL
SCALABLE SOLUTION TO THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS. WE WORK
WITH THEM AT THE WHITE HOUSE P.
BACKGAMMON THAT'S BE TEN SIXTY
NINE. A BILL THAT REMOVED
BARRIERS TO HOMEOWNERS THAT
HOMEOWNERS WERE FACING WHEN
THEY TRIED TO BUILD A BE USED-
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT- WE'VE
WORKED ON SB THIRTEEN WITH THE
SENATOR AND AB SIXTY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHANGE. OF
REMOVED FURTHER BARRIERS- THE
NUMBERS ARE COMPELLING- IN
TWENTY. THE CITY ABOUT A. ISSUE
EIGHTY EIGHT PERMITS ONE. OF
THEIR HOUSING PRODUCTION. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ISSUE FOUR
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE PERMITS. BUT 20% OF
THE CITY'S PRODUCTION THE
NUMBERS AND THE BAY AREA ARE
SIMILAR. AND TWENTY FOURTEEN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIVE EIGHTY
YOU PERMITS WHERE ISSUED. SEVEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALMOST SIXTEEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY YOU PERMITS WERE
ISSUED. A DIRECT RESULT OF THE-
YOUR- CALL AT. THAT ALMOST
TWENTY THOUSAND USED BEEN DONE
OF THOSE THE REFORM. IT
PROBABLY ALSO THING WE DATA-
THE STAFF. ZERO THAT-
TRADITIONAL HOME COAL ARE DYING
ON YOU TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO. 24% ON A SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES 41% ON THE MULTI FAMILY
HOMES THE ONLY GOOD STORY WE
HAVE THE TALENT HOUSING RIGHT
NOW AND AGAIN CRISIS ARE EIGHTY
USE THAT WE WOULD URGE YOU NOT
TO REVERSE. THE REFORMS THAT WE
HAVE- WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
PASSING WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK
BUT BALLOT OR STERN ON ON
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL THAT
WOULD NOT- RESTRICT A NEW
CONSTRUCTION PARTICULARLY FOR
LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS WHO LIVE
ON SMALLER LOTS WE DON'T WANT
EIGHTY USED TO BE- THIS.
OPPORTUNITY FOR WEALTHY
HOMEOWNERS IN LARGE FLOCKS WE
URGE- YOU'RE NOT VOTING BUT WE
WOULD URGE THAT- THAT THIS BILL
NOT PASSING THIS. CURRENT FORM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH ORDER
TO DAY. FROM THE HOUSING. CALL
IS DAVID. ARE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO. ADD TO ALL OF
THAT SAID WE ARE LOOKING WE
NEED TO TAKE ABOUT THINK ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THAT VERY ARE NOT
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE BY THE-
ALBANIAN. AT SEVEN ARE HAVING
TARGETED FOR THE THIRD IN HOW.
QUESTION OF THE IRISH. ABOUT
FOR THE OUT ADAM NOT TO
PRESERVE THE BATTERY AND TARGET
THEM TOWARDS MULLIN COLUMN AND
LEVEL COME OUT. ME. TO RIGHT AS
FOR THE BAR TO THE MIDDLE
INCOME HOW. AND SO MANY. THAT
CAN MEAN REGISTERED THE START
AND- THE LONG BRANCH OPEN
GOODNESS MORE NOTING THAT
UNITED HOW TO THE GENTLEMAN'S.
THAT THOSE ARE GOING TO BE.
SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN YEAR
ADVOCATE. ALTHOUGH ORDERS MANY.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL
NOW GO TO THE GALLERY SO ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
SAYING NINE ONE I'LL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ARE MISTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY IT'S YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION OF ANY AND THE
SIMPLE FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IT IS ONE ZERO. FIRST
WE WILL GO TO LINE UP TO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANK. YOUR OPEN YOU MAY
PROCEED FOLLOW UP. HE SAID HI
JACK WILLINGLY REPRESENTING IN
THE ACTION- WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO THE. THE NEXT WE'VE
GOT LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DEFINITELY NOT A
BIPARTISAN CAMPBELL CERTAINLY
OPPOSE AS YOU SEVENTY FIVE
THANK. AND EXPENSE TWO EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT OUT
OF THE MARCIANO CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES ON BEHALF OF SANTA
MONICA IN THE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NICK SABAN. SIXTY
SIX ZERO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOLLY
COMMITTEE DAVID ON BEHALF OF
BURKE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
STOCK. AT THE END OF ONE AND
THEN ZERO OUR NEXT ONE WILL
COME FROM LINE TO SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SERRA WILL BE REGIONAL
ORGANIZER WITH SAN FRANCISCO
YUCKY ON BEHALF OF THE IN THE
ACTION OPPOSE. B. SEVEN SIX
FIVE. ARE AT THIS POINT WE HAVE
NOT FURTHER. WE DO HAVE ONE
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIDE OF IT.
I DIDN'T LOSE MY CAN BE HAVE A
CALIFORNIAN THE OPPOSITE SHOULD
BE SEVEN FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
AND THEN LOWER TO EIGHTY ONE.
THE PROPOSAL AVOCADO CALLED ON
BEHALF OF THE BABY LEAF HANNAH
CREWS IN OPPOSITION. AND ONE
ZERO TWO- SUPPORT TO OPPOSE.
AND THEN FURTHER AT THIS TIME.
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM A
MODERATOR- WELL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON SB
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. K. SEEING
NINE YEARS OR JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS BY SERVERS- CENTER
STAR AND THANK YOU FOR. MAKING
THIS A TO YOUR BILL- I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK. EIGHTY
IT'S HARD TO OVERSTATE HOW
IMPORTANT EIGHTY USE ARE FOR
THE FUTURE OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ISSUES WILL NOT
SOLVE THE CRISIS ON THEIR OWN-
BUT IT IS A POTENTIALLY HUGE
AMOUNT OF ADDITIONAL HOUSING
THAT IS LESS EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD. THAT IS ON IN GENERAL
GOING TO BE MORE AFFORDABLE AND
THAT DOES NOT. MEANINGFULLY
IMPACT THE LOOK AND FEEL OF
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SO- IT IS-
AND WE'RE SEEING SUCCESS AS WE
HEARD FROM MR REGAN'S ACTUALLY.
WORKING AND IT'S WORKING- DUE
TO THE HARD WORK ON A LOT OF
ADVOCATES SOME OF WHOM WE HEARD
FROM BUT ALSO CENTER BY CAL SKI
CENTER SKINNER- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING- SOME
MEMBER FRIEDMAN THAT'S IT'S
BEEN A REAL GROUP EFFORT- AND
IT'S- AND IT IS STARTING TO
MOVE THE DIAL ON A TO YOU-
PRODUCTION. THIS BILL I KNOW
HEARD A LOT ABOUT LARA LOT.
THIS BILL IS DRAFTED AS NOT A
LARGE LOT BILL IT APPLIES TO
EVERY LOT WHETHER IT'S A TINY
LOT. MORE MASSIVE LIVE
UNDERSTAND FROM THE AUTHOR AND
ALSO FROM THE CO AUTHOR THE
DOES THIS CONCERN ABOUT MEDICAL
LOTS AND- AND I YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO CALL
DESPITE EIGHTY YOU. SOMEONE
BUILDS A ON THE LOT LINE WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE TO AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION- BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS BILL BEFORE US TODAY-
DIES IN A AND IF THIS BILL WERE
VOTED ON TODAY I WOULD NOT BE
ABLE. TO SUPPORT IT WHICH IS
WHY I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE SOME MORE
TIME- TO LOOK AT THIS- IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND WHY
WE HAVE A FOUR FOOT SETBACK.
THERE WAS ENORMOUS WE IT'S BEEN
A LOT CALIFORNIA FOR FORTY
YEARS. THAT CITIES HAVE TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO PUT EIGHTY
USING AND IT WAS A DEAD LETTER
AND CITIES USE ALL SORTS OF
TOOLS TO MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
PUT EIGHTY USE AN- AND ONE OF
THEM WAS. BIG COULD SEPARATE
FORM AND THAT MADE IT LITERALLY
PHYSICALLY IMPOSSIBLE.TO BUILD
ANY TO YOU AND THAT'S WHY
CENTER BY CAL SKI IN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING BOTH PUT
SETBACK LIMITS AND THEIR BILLS.
AND ULTIMATELY IT WAS-
NEGOTIATION AND COMPROMISE
THERE WERE OTHER PIECES OF
THOSE BILLS THAT COULD NOT MAKE
IN THE LAW. THIS ONE DID AS
PART OF THAT PROCESS AND IN ITS
CURRENT FORM SB SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE WOULD UNDO- THAT
RESOLUTION- SO- IT'S GOOD THAT
WE'RE TAKING A MORE TIME- SO I-
APPRECIATE THE ALL TO WORKING
WITH OUR COMMITTEE- AND I ALSO
WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR IS
COLLISION- TO REALLY- WORK WITH
CENTER BY CAL SKI CENTER
SKINNER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG-
OVER THE REST OF THE YEAR
BECAUSE HE'S REALLY ARE. PEOPLE
WHO HAS SPENT AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME DIGGING INTO
THIS ISSUE AND WITH THAT-
SENATOR AYE STERN I WILL GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY- TO CLOSE.
BEFORE WE MAKE THIS A TO YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
YOU HAVE A BUSY SO I'M WILL NOT
BELABOR THE- BUT YOU HAVE MY
CAN GET AND THAT'S A- THE-
RATIONALE FOR- FIRST LONG IS
LEGISLATION THAT IS TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND TO NOT.
TRY TO UNDO CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED ISSUES- DUE RESPECT
DEEPLY THE WORK OF. ALL MEMBERS
YOU JUST MENTIONED AND- BUT I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS
THAT DOES POINT OUT- THAT THE
BILL DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAND
UNLIMITED CALLED UNLIMITED
AUTHORITY TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO IMPOSE ALTERNATIVE
SET BACKS. BUT I RECOGNIZE THAT
WERE REOPENING A CONTENTIOUS
ISSUE WHERE WE PICKED A NUMBER
NOW WE WILL- TO GET OPEN AND
INDISCRETION WE RECOGNIZE WILL
BE PROBLEMATIC FOR. THE
REASONS. CREDIBLY ARGUED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND NOW I DO WANT TO
SEE THOSE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION AND MILLION NEW UNITS
THAT YOU REFERRED TO- WITH
EMPHASIS ON AFFORDABILITY SO-
IN ORDER TO FURTHER FACILITATE
THOSE GOALS BUT ALSO TRYING TO
FIND SOME. KIND OF SWEET HERE
IF AS YOU. THROUGH EIGHTEEN
CITING AND- AS WE SORT OF
LEARNED MORE FROM DOING I'M
HOPING THIS VEHICLES HERE IS A
PLACE THAT. CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT ALL THAT
BUT- DEEPLY RISK YOU'RE WORKING
REST IS COMMITTEE. AND- THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I CENTERS TO- I'M
ASIDE- THE BILL- ONE WILL BE
COMING TO YOUR BILL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION-
GREAT SO- WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB FOUR NINETY BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. CENTER YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR DESK IF YOU'D
LIKE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB FOUR NINETY AN
IMPORTANT BILL TO HELP ACQUIRE
AND PRESERVE MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THIS BILL CREATES
HE ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WITHIN EIGHT
CD. THE PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
EXPECT EXPERTISE AND BUILD THE
CAPACITY FOR MISSION DRIVEN
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL HOUSING
AGENCIES ENGAGED IN ACQUISITION
REHABILITATION ARE ACT REHAB IN
ORDER TO GROW AND STRENGTHEN
LOCAL ACT REHAB PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THE
LARGE MAJORITY OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN ON
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HOUSING WHICH IS PRIVATELY
OWNED AND SOMEWHAT MORE
AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS. DUE TO A VARIETY OF
REASONS SUCH AS A LACK OF
SUPPLY AND GROWING DEMAND THIS
UNSUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS RAPIDLY DISAPPEARING AND
THIS TREND IS LIKELY TO
CONTINUE PUSHING PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR HOMES AND OUT O THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AS THIS HOUSING
STOCK DISAPPEARS THERE ARE
FEWER AND FEWER PLACES FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS TO LIVE AND
NEW HOUSING PRODUCTION IS NOT
PRODUCING ENOUGH UNITS TO
ACCOUNT FOR THIS LOSS. IN
RESPONSE TO THIS DISPLACEMENT
AND LOSS OF AFFORDABLE HOMES
LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE BECOME
BEGUN TO ACQUIRE UNSUBSIDIZED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND PRESERVE
IT AS PERMANENTLY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS
STRATEGY IS KNOWN AS
ACQUISITION REHABILITATION.
ACREE HAVE INCREASES THE SUPPLY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING QUICKLY
AND IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY HI
EVEN EVEN HOWEVER EVEN FOR
EXPERIENCED DEVELOPERS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THIS
NEW TYPE OF PRESERVATION
PRESENTS A VARIETY OF NEW
CAPACITY CHALLENGES. BUILDING
ON THE SUCCESS OF OTHER STATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
SB FOUR NINETY WILL ADDRESS
THIS CHALLENGE BY PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY EXPERTISE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING FOR ELIGIBLE
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST LOCAL
HOUSING AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND HELP ADDRESS
QUESTIONS A COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
ARE THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL
JUSTIN MARKETS WITH ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND JACK
AVERY WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
GREAT THANK YOU SO WE HAVE TO
BE RENDON SAYS DANIEL EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND FOR THE FIRST
SPEAKER YOU JUST E MINDFUL
BECAUSE IF YOU GO OVER TWO
MINUTES TO TAKES TIME AWAY FROM
THE SECOND WITNESS. WE WILL
START WITH IJUSTINE MARCUS FROM
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
YOUR TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEFF
THE MARKET THE STATE LOCAL
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. ENTERPRISE
IS A NATIONAL NONPROFIT THAT
DEVELOPS PROGRAM ADVOCATE FOR
POLICIES THAT DELIVERS CAPITAL
TO CREATE AND PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WIRING
HOUSING OFF THE SPECULATIVE
MARKET AND PRESERVING THE
ACCOUNTS OF THE PORTABLE HAD
DEMONSTRATED A POWERFUL PROOF
OF CONCEPT LOCALLY. IT DIRECTLY
PREVENT THE PLACEMENT WELL
QUICKLY GROWING THE SUPPLY OF
PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ENTERPRISES BOTH THE TECHNICAL
AND FINANCIAL PARTNER WITH
ORGANIZATIONS DOING THIS WORK
ON THE GROUND AND WE'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND. THE CAPACITY
CHALLENGES SPEAKING
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES. TO
HELP ORGANIZATIONS NEED TO SET
UP A NEW SYSTEM TO COMPETE TO
ACQUIRE HOLDS ON THE PRIVATE
MARKET AND IT CAN BE
CHALLENGING TO ASSEMBLE AND
COMPETE FOR FINANCE. THEY ALSO
NEED TO DEVELOP NEW INNOVATIVE
ASSET MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES TO
EFFECTIVELY STEWARD BUILDING
THAT RANGE IN SIZE CONDITION
AND H. MOREOVER ORGANIZATIONS
NEED TO DEVELOP PRACTICES FOR
EFFECTIVELY AND COMPASSIONATELY
ENGAGING RESIDENTS. REQUISITION
COMMITTEE REHAB STARTED. TO
ENSURE A SMOOTH TRANSITION. THE
BUILDING THE COUPON OF MISSION
DRIVEN OR- AND LOCAL. THIS
FACTOR TO SCALE ACT HAVE ACTIVE.
AND EQUITABLY ACROSS THE STATE.
HOW TO CO SPONSOR THE FOUR
NINETY WHICH WOULD BUILD ON THE
STATE LAW TRACK RECORD OF
INTENTIONAL INVESTMENT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITIES
SEIZE THE OPPORTUNITY OF
ACTUALLY HAVE ONE NOTHING IN
THE LONG TERM CAPACITY OF
ORGANIZATIONS DOING THIS WORK
OFTEN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LED BY SERVING
PEOPLE OF COLOR. FOR
EFFECTIVELY URGE YOU TO VOTE I
IN SUPPORT OF AB P. FOR NINETY
DAY AND HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL
NOW GO TO- JACKIE VERY FROM
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. HI EARNING
CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACK
AVERY I'M APPALLED THE
ASSOCIATE WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA OF IN CALIFORNIA
YEAH- THE VOICE IN THE CAPITAL
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. AND OUR MISSION
IS TO REALIZE AN EQUITABLE AND
JUST CALIFORNIA WITH HOMES FOR
ALL. HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR CO SPONSOR AT
PEOPLE NINETY. WHICH INCREASE
THE HOUSING ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
EXPERTISE AND GUIDANCE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MISSION DRIVEN
ORGANIZATIONS. ENGAGED IN
ACQUISITION ME AND
REHABILITATION AS THE AUTHOR
SENATOR KABIR NOTED. ACREE HAD
INCREASES THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT A LOWER
COST AND I'M VERY QUICK TIME
MINE COMMITTEE NOTED SENATE-
CHAIR WIENER WE MUST ENGAGE IN
MULTIPLE STRATEGIES IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE OUR STATE HOUSING
CRISIS AND CAN'T RELY ON NEW
PRODUCTION ALONE. I WANT TO
STRESS THAT THE ACREE HAVE THAT
BEFORE NINETY WITH SUPPORTING
THE NEWER TYPE OF HOUSING
PRESERVATION DOES NOT CURRENTLY
SUPPORTED THE STATE PROGRAM. IT
TARGET EXISTING PRIVATE MARKET
HOUSING IMAGE OF LOW INCOME
FOLKS RT LIVE. BLOG LISTING ACT
WE HAVE PROGRAMS SUCH AS THAT.
AT THE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM ARE TARGETED TO
PRESERVING EXISTING DEED
RESTRICTED HOUSING THAT WILL
SOON EXPIRE. THE AUTHORS
SENATORS HOW THEY ARE SHARED
MAJORITY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS LIVE AND PRIVATE
MARKET RENTAL HOUSING. IS
UNFUNDED AND- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDE INCREASINGLY
DISAPPEARED OVER THE PAST
DECADE A NEW PRODUCTION IS NOT
KEPT. UP WITH THE LAW THE
PROBLEM. ACTUALLY HAVE OF UNDER
THAT I A PORTABLE THE CRITICAL
AND UNTAPPED PRESERVATION.
PATINGGI FOR PROVIDING HOME
BETTER AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR KIRBY- FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL. AND
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THE BILL
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS IN RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON IT BEFORE
NINETY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW GO TO SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY. TO CYBER. FORTY
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU- WHEN I GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE I DON'T DO NOT SEE
ANYONE STE- WHEN I GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORT. FOR SB
FOUR NINETY AGAIN PLEASE LIMIT.
YOUR COMMENT YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND YOUR
SUPPORT. BURKE THIS WILL BE
MOVING THE GENTLEMAN TO- AMID
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING
OUT TO LINE NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY
THREE TO EIGHTY THREE LINES
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU LINE TO NINETY FIVE PLEASE.
AND ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING
AT THE PARK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE NUMBER LINE TWO
SEVENTY FIVE GOING TO. CAN YOU
HEAR ME CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO
BOB THIS IS JEFF REGARDING YEAR.
SOME GENERAL WIENER- ORDER THIS
BILL ANYTHING THAT HELPS
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST BETTER
ABILITY. OF THE TECHNICAL BILL.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR PUTTING IT
OUT THERE AND- BUT NEEDS TO GO
FURTHER PLEASE LET ME KNOW HOW
I CAN SUPPORT FURTHER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANOTHER LINE TO NINETY
TWO BILLION. SEVEN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE.
FIFTY I'M FIFTY YEAR OPEN WELL
AT LEAST. THAT WOULD ALLOW HIM
TO NINETY SIX FLORIDA. I THE
DILLON MINOR I'M ON THE BOARD
OF SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY AM
TRUST AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY. WE
GOT A LINE TO NINETY THREE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ON US FROM ALSO ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR NINETY THANK YOU.
ANALYTICALLY ONCE AGAIN TO VOTE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO GOING ONLINE TO NINETY ONE
TO NINETY ONE YOU'RE OPEN TO IT
PLEASE. PLEASE. OKAY NO
RESPONSIBILITY ONE THOUGH THE
TIONAL- TRANSMITTERS IN HOUSTON
IS ONE OF THE STRUCTURE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL NOW
GOOD OPPOSITION TO US BEFORE
NINETY- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPONENTS- IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY. SAYING NO ONE-
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE I
SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
SP FOUR NINETY. THE PROPOSITION
BECAUSE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE. PRESS ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION PLEASE. YEAH I WILL
PROMISE WE HAVE NO CALLS IN
QUEUE SIR PLEASE CONTINUE GREAT
WE WILL BRING HIM BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE CALLING ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS IN A SPEECH FOR
NINETY. FEDERAL COUNCIL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AFTER THAT.
DETAILED DISCUSSION ON EIGHTY
USE I HAD AN IDEA I WANTED TO
RUN IT BY THE AUTHOR- SINCE
THIS IS. A PROGRAM THAT'S
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE COMMUNITY AND
LOOKING FOR. RESIDENT
ENGAGEMENT IN EDUCATION AND
THIS PROPERTY ASSESSMENT WITH
THESE THIRD PARTY CONSULTANTS
FOR THESE FUNDS SUBSIDIZE YOU
KNOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS I
THOUGHT THAT THE- OR- ALL OVER
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF UNPERMITTED.
EIGHTY USE THAT STILL EXIST IN
THE UNITED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS WONDERING
IF THE AUTHOR THOUGHT THAT
THERE MAY BE A PLEASE. IN THIS-
HARD CAP THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME OF THAT TECHNICAL
SERVICE ASSISTANCE ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS FOR HOMEOWNERS
THAT HAVE TENANTS IN THERE AND
DON'T REALLY WANT TO KICK HIM
OUT- IT'S A SMALLER- PURPOSE
BUT I THINK IT. IT IS IT FOR ME
AT THE BRACES THE GOAL IS VERY
GOOD A BILL THAT- SHE HAS.
THANK YOU CENTER CASKEY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY THE I'M RECOMMENDING THAT
WE PASSED THE BILL AND I CENTER
YOU MAY CLOSE OR- RESPOND
CENTER MY COUNTY WHATEVER YOU'D
LIKE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND I DID HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
HAVE A CONVERSATION I'M I THINK
IT'S A IT'S A VERY INNOVATIVE
AND INTERESTING OPPORTUNITY I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE IT BACK
TO THE SPONSORS OF WHAT WE KNOW
IS THAT MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE
NONCONFORMING USES- ON ON
PARTICULAR PROPERTIES WHETHER
IT'S BEE A GARAGE CONVERSION
OR- A SHED THAT'S BEEN
CONVERTED. THOSE ARE NOT
APPROPRIATELY THEY MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE FOR HUMAN
HABITATION BUT WITH SOME
UPGRADES THEY COULD BE MADE
CONFORMING BUT- BUT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE SOME SOPHISTICATION TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO THAT WHEN THEY
COME TO LIGHT THEIR PEOPLE ARE.
AND WHERE ARE YOU WORKING WITH
THE TENANTS IN ORDER BRING HIM
UP SO I THINK IT IT MIGHT WORK
OUT VERY WELL I WILL I WILL I
WILL PROMISED TO LOOK INTO IT
BUT- THE REALLY IMPORTANT PART
OF ALL OF THIS DISCUSSION IS
THAT WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT WE
HAVE. A NUMBER OF UNITS THAT
NEED- THAT THAT WE NEED TO SAVE
FOR THE FOR THE LOW INCOME
MARKET AND THE ONLY WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO COME UP WITH A
COORDINATED APPROACH AND IT AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL OFFERS
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU
SO COVERAGE- IS OUR MOTION.
SENATOR CHRIS HAS HE MOVED- AND
OUT OF HIS OWN WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE
BILL FOUR NINETY BY SENATOR
CAFIERO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER
I'D BATES. CABALLERO HI
COPYRIGHT CORTESE. CORTESE I'M
OF WIRE. WHICH- ABOVE HI
RICHARD BERG SKINNER HI SKINNER
HI I'M BURKE. NUMBER WOOD
COUNTY HI BECAUSE I. SEVEN IT
HAS ENOUGH VOTES PUT ON FOR A
AND NUMBER. A BEFORE WE HAD TO
OUR NEXT SORT OF SERGEANTS TO
JUST IMPORTANCE REQUIRE THAT
WERE ON OUR LAST BILLS. OKAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET OUR
FINAL BILL TODAY S. B. ITEM
NINE SB SIX FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR CORTEZ ANY- CENTER YOU
MAY PRESENT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS
SENT TODAY I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB SIX FORTY NINE. THE
BILL THAT ALIGNS TENANT
PREFERENCES WITH INTERNAL
REVENUE CODE REQUIREMENTS. TO
ALLOW HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THAT
USE TAX CREDIT OR BOND
FINANCING. TO REDUCE
DISPLACEMENT. BY USING TENET
PREFERENCES. COVERT NINETEEN.
AMONG OTHER ISSUES HAS
AMPLIFIED THE DISPLACEMENT
PRESSURES EXPERIENCED BY
CALIFORNIA'S. MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THROUGH REDUCE
INCOMES ARE RISING HOUSING
COSTS. THE BECAUSE LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE OF
COLOR REAL TANGIBLE ISSUES
INCLUDING MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS AND EDUCATIONAL
DEFICIENCIES TO NAME A FEW.
DISPLACEMENT PRESSURES ALSO
CAUSE US TO LOSE OUR NEIGHBORS.
A RECENT STUDY IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ALONE SHOWED THAT OVER
HALF THE DISPLACED LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS HAD TO LEAVE THEIR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. LOCAL CAN
PREFERENCES ARE CRITICAL TOOL
MANY CITIES HAVE USED TO
STABILIZE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
PRIORITIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR LOCAL RESIDENTS AT RISK OF
DISPLACEMENT. HOWEVER LOCAL
TOLD LIEUTENANT PREFERENCES
LACK THE STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT NECESSARY FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO CONFIDENTLY USE
THEM IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS FUNDED WITH TAX
CREDITS AND BOND FINANCING. SB
SIX FORTY NINE CREATES A STATE
POLICY THAT SUPPORTS HOUSING
FOR POPULATIONS AT HIGH RISK
FOR FACING DISPLACEMENT THROUGH
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES. CAN
USE TENET PURPOSES AND
THEREFORE BY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS TO PROTECT THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THESE
CHANGES WILL HELP US TARGET THE
BENEFITS OF SCARCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LIMIT DISPLACEMENT AND
REDUCE THE MANY HARMS THAT
RESULT FROM DISPLACEMENT. BUT
THE USE OF LOCAL TENANT
PREFERENCES CAN ALSO HELP
REDUCE OPPOSITION. TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ENHANCE THE PROJECT
PREDICTABILITY OF DEVELOPMENT.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION COMPLEMENT STATE
AND FEDERAL FAIR HOUSING LAW
BUT SUPPORTING LOCAL POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS THAT FOSTER
DIVERSITY IN HOUSING CHOICE. I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR. OF A
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT WORK. BUT WITH US.
EXTENSIVELY ON THIS BILL A TO
GET READY TODAY. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS GABI
HERNANDEZ FROM SOMEONE SO MOST
MAY FARE AND TODD DAVID FROM
HOUSING ACTION COALITION.
MISTER CHAIR THAT WOULD-
CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION AND
I'LL JUST SAY NOW THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR UNCLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
CORTEZ HE WILL NOW GO TO
SUPPORT OUR LEAD. WHEN THIS IS
OUR FIRST- GABRIEL HERNANDEZ
FROM SOMERS MAYFAIR FOLLOWED BY
TODD DAVID IN THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION EACH LIVE TWO
MINUTES- AND- WE'LL START WITH
MISTER HERNANDEZ. HELLO MY NAME
IS DEBORAH HERNANDEZ. I GREW UP
IN THE SIDE SOME OF THE AND
PICK STRAWBERRIES GRAPES
CONCENTRATORS BEFORE STARTING
CURRENTLY WORK AS A COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE FOR SOME MOST MAJOR.
ORGANIZING WITH LOW INCOME AND
MARGINALIZED FAMILIES DRESSING
HOUSING ISSUES LIKE
GENTRIFICATION. AND
DISPLACEMENT. RESTORED WE ARE
HAVE LIVED IN THE OF THE THAT
HAVE BEEN REDLINE BY THE
BANKING AND REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY. LITTLE WAS DONE TO IN
OUR LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND WE WERE
LEFT TO DEVELOP OUR OWN SOCIAL
MUTUAL AID NETWORKS AMONGST OUR
FAMILY TO RAISE OUR CHILDREN.
NOW THE CO WRITTEN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED ONE OR
MORE FAMILIES WITH OUR- WHICH
RENTS SOARING THROUGH THE ROOF
WE ARE EXPERIENCING. GOOD
EXPERIENCE SUPPORT FAMILIES
FROM OUR NEIGHBORHOODS. PASSED
SEVERAL YEARS WE HAVE WORKED
WITH THE CITY OF SAN JOSE'S
HOUSING DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
MANY STRATEGIES TO SLOW THE
DISPLACEMENT OF THE FAMILIES WE
WORK WITH. WE HAVE DEVELOPED AN
ANTI DISPLACEMENT LOCAL TENANTS
PREFERENCE POLICY THAT WE HOPE
WILL KEEP OUR FAMILIES IN
SENTENCING. YOU'RE ASKING THAT
THE STATE SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS
TO END THE DACA SB SIX FORTY
NINE THAT WILL ALIGN JANET
PREFERENCES WHICH INTERNAL
REVENUE CODE REQUIREMENTS. AND
WILL QUALIFY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS FOR TAX CREDITS
AND BOND FINANCING. ONE OF OUR
READERS AND LISTENERS THAT
PEOPLE SELL. HAS FOUR CHILDREN
HAS MOVED MORE THAN TEN TIMES
IN TWO YEARS TRYING TO STAY IN
THE MAYFAIR DISTRICT IN SAN
JOSE TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN IN
THE SAME SCHOOLS. ANOTHER
COMPUTER VIRUS MEDINA TESSA AND
LIVES IN SAN JOSE FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND HAD TO
MOVE SIXTY MILES SOUTH OF SAN
JOSE BECAUSE OF THE RATE HIKES.
SHE FOUND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RETURN BETTER LIVING CONDITIONS
RELATIVE TO OTHER FAMILIES
LIVING IN THE SAME HOUSE.
PLEASE NOTE THIS LEGISLATION
QUICKLY AS WE FIGHT. FIGHT TO
KEEP OUR FAMILIES AND SOME OF
THE AND THERE ARE SOCIAL
NETWORKS PLEASE. SUPPORT SB SIX
FORTY NINE. FIVE YOU. VERY MUCH%
AND WHEN I GO TO TIED THE FROM
THE OUSING I CALL. THANK YOU
MISTER. IN ADDITION IN ADDITION
TO WHAT MR KANNAN SAID. ABOUT
THE BILL. I'VE BEEN HAVING
ACTION COALITION ME ALSO NEED
TO THE ALL I HAD A QUICK THAT.
ME THE R. LABOR OPPOSITION
2100% OF. BOB AND WE THINK THAT
WOULD RATHER THE LEAST OF THE
COMBAT OPPOSITION IS A
NEIGHBORHOOD PROPERTY PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE NAY. L. A. R.
PRODUCTION OR PROTECTION OR
PRESERVATION. AB IS A- PROTECT
AND ABOUT DAHLE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FIVE THIRTY MUCH SIR
DAVID AND- CENTER BECAUSE I
APOLOGIZE IF I'M AS DID YOU
ACCEPT THE AND I'M ARE FOR THE-
YES I. OKAY POLICIES FOR
MISSING A- ON OKAY- IT IS- ANY
US- TESTING IN THE- THING NINE
A SUPPORT AND REMOTE TWELVE.
SAYING NINE- MADAM. IF YOU
COULD- TO UP SUPPORT THE PHONE
LINE. SUBMIT YOUR SHARE
RESTAURANTEURS ARE. SUPPORT
THAT'S WHAT I ANSWER WOULD NOT
COMMENT AND FOR ONES. AT THIS
WE'RE GOING THE TO LINE NUMBER
TWO NINETY. TWO NINE ONE ONE
THERE THE NEW THEMSELVES. LINE
THREE YOUR LINE IS A WATER
LEAKS. IT AFTER THAT NOTHING
ABOUT. LINE SIXTY YEAR OLD
SINGLE AND PLEASE. HOLLY FOR
MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF- IN
SUPPORT. THE NEXT ONE IN LINE
THREE OR ONE THREE ZERO ONE GO
AHEAD. APOLOGIZE THERE WAS A
GLITCH ONE MORE TRY. ONE THREE
ONE YEAR OPEN OUR POLICIES AT
LEAST. BOB MICHAEL AGAIN BEHALF
THE BOARD. SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. ONCE AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LINE THREE
OLD. REEL TO EUROPE WHAT MAKES.
SHARE MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION HANDS HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION- IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE QUEUES NOW
CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN
I GO TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPONENTS IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY.
THREE NINE ANY OPPOSITION IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. THIRTY NINE-
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU COOK
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINE PLEASE. CERTAINLY MISTER
TRIPLE OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT A PRESS
ONE ZERO TWO COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL PLEASE.
NO CALLS REPEAT UP FOR
COMMENTS. OKAY WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE OUR COLLEAGUES
OR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
SB SIX FORTY NINE. IN A ROW CAL
SKI HI I THINK IT'S GOOD BILL I
LIKE THE INSURANCE FOR THE BOND
HOLDERS HAVE. BE SUPPORTIVE OF
AND I'D MOVE THE BILL. THE
MOTION CONSENT LIKE HOUSING ANY
OTHER. OR COMMENTS. BY SEN
RICHARD OF. I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION- CENTER CORTESE WITH
REGARDS TO- THIS BAIL IN BEING-
I KNOW IS THAT IS A REAL TOUR
ONE OF THE YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT- THEIR HOUSING LAWS AND
SO FORTH HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND
TO THE ISSUE THAT THIS MAY BE-
IN VIOLATION OF THE EQUAL
PROTECTION CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION- THERE. WHEN THE
CASHIER ASKED ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS- WHY DIDN'T SPELL
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THE WORD AND-
PERHAPS I SHOULD HAVE DONE THAT
BUT ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT-
WAS BROUGHT FORWARD. COMMITTEE
STAFF AND OTHERS WAS TO CALL
OUT THAT. IF THE BILL IS
ENACTED THAT IT DOES NEED TO-
TO ABIDE BY. THOSE LAWS RULES
FEDERAL HOUSING LAWS THAT YOU
JUST IDENTIFIED. ANY OTHER
RESIDENTS ARE BOTH OF THE JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES SO
IT IT IS. STILL UP IN THE AIR
AS FAR AS WHETHER OR NOT IT IN.
REGISTER THOSE LAWS OR ARE WE
CLEAR ON IT'S NOT UP IN THE AIR
IT JUST GIVES DIRECTION TO
LOCAL SAID IF THEY'RE GOING TO
HOLD A HEARING. IN QUALIFY A
HOUSING PROJECT FOR EXAMPLE FOR
TAX EXEMPT BONDS ON THE BASIS
OF DISPLACEMENT THAT THEIR-
AUTOMATICALLY. GOING TO HAVE TO
GO FORWARD- IN ALIGNMENT WITH
FEDERAL FAIR HOUSING LAWS. SO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO DO THAT
THEY'LL HAVE TO DO THAT OR THEY
WERE ALSO WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
PROCEED PROCEED WITH THE TAX
EXEMPT BOND FINANCING WILL BE
OLD ENOUGH. AND DINNER BECAUSE
IF THEY I MATT I CAN ACTUALLY
ADD TO THAT. I'M SORRY WHEN I
WAS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. IN SAN FRANCISCO I
WAS PART OF THE EFFORT TO
CREATE A ON A LOCAL PREFERENCE-
ORDINANCE IN SAN FRANCISCO FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- AND IT IS
AN ISSUE THAT- YOU'RE THREADING
A NEEDLE. FOR SHORE. THE NEW
YORK THE LOCAL PREFERENCE THEY
WERE CHALLENGED IN FOR. A BOAT
WHEN WE WERE PURSUING THIS AND
SAN FRANCISCO- AND ACTUALLY OUR
MAYOR IT WAS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT. IF A
COMMUNITY IS GOING TO ACCEPT
AND FIND AND FIGHT FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE WANTTO
MAKE SURE THAT MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE. TO GET INTO THAT AND SO
ARE MAYOR MEMORY DOES SHE
TRAVEL TO WASHINGTON DC TO MEET
WITH HIDE. AND HEART
ALTERNATELY SIGNED OFF- AND I
THINK IT WAS WE HAD LIKE 40% SO
WASN'T THE ENTIRE. AMOUNT IT
WAS A PERCENTAGE OF IT AND HIDE
SIGNED OFF ON THAT- SO THERE IS
SOME MURKINESS ON THIS ISSUE-
BOOK BUT I THINK THAT THERE IS
A NEED ALL THAT COMMUNITIES CAN
THREAD AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT AMENDMENT. TO SAY IF
YOU'RE IMPLEMENTING THOSE JUST
MAKE SURE. YOU'RE VERY MINDFUL
OF FAIR HOUSING. RIGHT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FIRST
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
Y. KASKI FOR COLLABORATION HE'S
MY- OF ONE OF MY CO SENATORS
FROM THE SAN JOSE AREA WHO- AS
YOU HEARD WAS PRIMARY SPONSOR
THE BILL AND ALSO THANK GOD-
BY- BY COLLEAGUE COLLEAGUE TO
MY LEFT FOR. FINANCIAL BOTH
FOR- FOR THE GOOD QUESTIONING
IN HELPING US GET THAT ON THE
ECORD- IT WAS AN IMPORTANT
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL- WITH
THAT- I I'D BE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I CAN'T REMEMBER
IF WE HAD- MOTIONS IN ACCOUNTS
HE MOVES- AND WITH THAT MADAM
CONSULTANT IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
CORTEZ HE- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATOR
WINNER. WINNER I'D STATES HI
BATES HI CABALLERO HI
CABALLERO. PROTESTING PROTESTS
HE AYE MCGUIRE. BUT CHAU. I JOE
BURKE ICE. HI SKINNER HI NUMBER
AND- NUMBER WOOD COUNTY HIGH
THE CASKET I EIGHT OKAY IT HAS
ENOUGH VOTES WILL PUT CALL FOR
THE OP MEMBERS- WE WILL BE
THANK YOU WILL BE OUR AS SOON
AS- SENATOR MCGUIRE ARRIVES AND
HE HAS ONCE AGAIN-ONE OF THEM
MICHAEL DWYER HONORARY AWARD
FOR BEING LAST SURVIVING. A
NUMBER OF ISSUES HERE EYES WILL
OPEN THE ROLE AND- IF IT'S
GOING TO BE A WHILE I'LL DO IT
HOW DO TWO ROUNDS BUT DO WE
KNOW IF HE'S ON HIS WAY. OKAY.
IF IT'S NOT RIGHT HERE I MAY
JUST SO EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
WORLD. OKAY WELL WE'LL OPEN THE
ROLE SO OTHERS CANNOT. CAN
COMPLETE THE ROADS- SO WE'LL
START WITH S. B. NINE I ITEM
ONE SB NINE- MADAM CONSOLE OKAY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL NINE BY
SENATOR ATKINS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL BUG NO BUT CHAU ABOVE
NOW. SIX TO TWO WE WILL PUT ON
CALL- FOR THE NEXT TO THE
VICTIM. CALENDAR OPEN THE ROLE
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS
OF FILE ITEMS AT TWO TEN AND
ELEVEN SENATOR BATES OKA BATES
I PROTESTED. HIGH FOR TO THE
AYE MCGUIRE. NINE I WILL PUT
THAT ON A SECOND ON CALL OUR
NEXT ITEM THREE SB. THREE NINE
TWO. THIS IS SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
CORTEZ E. HI. COURTESY AYE
MCGUIRE. BUT CHAU AGO HI THE
CHORE BUG. THEY WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL. ITEM NUMBER SB. SIX
TWO ONE. SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
ONE BY SENATOR EGGMAN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
BATES. SENATOR CAFIERO HI
CABALLERO AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL
A BOOK. SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
THEY WILL PUT THAT ON CALL.
OKAY BUT IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT- SB SIX SEVENTY
NINE ITEM. FIVE SENATE BILL SIX
EVENTY NINE BY SENATOR CALM
WATER THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR BATES NAY BATES
NOW CABALLERO HI CABALLERO AYE
MCGUIRE- BURKE. SIX TO ONE.
OKAY WE'LL PUT THAT ON ALL VOTE
START NEXT WE'LL GO TO ITEM SIX
SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT. SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI COURTESY AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE MCGUIRE AYE. NINE
ZERO. OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT-
NEXT- WE'RE GONNA SPEND SCRIPT
AND SEVEN FOR THE TALK ABOUT
ITEM EIGHT- SP FOUR NINETY.
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY BY
SENATOR CAFIERO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR BATES.
SENATE MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE.
EIGHT ZERO. THE BILL- BUT
SENATOR BATES NOT VOTING ON THE
WTF OKAY SO A NOTHING YES OKAY
THAT BILLS OUT- NEXT- ITEM NINE
SB SIX FORTY NINE. SENATE BILL
SIX FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
PROTESTED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY SENATOR REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. NINE NOTHING OKAY
THAT BILLS ADULTS- OKAY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE- IS OPEN THE ROLE
AND ITEM NUMBER ONE SB. NINE
YES EVEN THOUGH I. SENATE BILL
NINE BY SENATOR ATKINS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BEEN REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
SENATOR REQUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE
IT UP THOSE ADULTS SEVENTY TWO.
BILLS OUT- NEXT SEVEN TWO SP
FIVE OR I'M SORRY FOR THE NEXT
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- WILL OPEN
THE ROLE FOR UP TO NUMBERS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS TO TEN
AND ELEVEN THE CENTER REQUIRE.
FOR AYE. TEND NOT NOTHING.
ARTICLE THIRTY IS A PRE- WILL
GO TO ITEM THREE SB THREE
NINETY TWO. THREE NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR ARTS A LOT OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY SEVEN A REQUIRE. HI
MCGUIRE I. EIGHT ZERO. AND THE
NUMBER NOT. SENATOR WOOD COUNTY
DID NOT OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
SET UP ILL IS OUT- MEXICAN FOR
SB SIXTY ONE. SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR EGGMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
TWO REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
SENATOR BATES. PAGE NOT VOTING
BOATING. NUMBER NUMBER NUMBER
ENDING MCGUIRE. CONSULTANT CAN
GIVE ME THIRTY SECONDS SURE.
UHHUH. I'M SORRY HOW MANY VOTES
TO ALLEN SIXTY ONE RIGHT NOW.
THREE SIX OKAY. SO WHAT THE
HELL. OKAY SO GOING BACK AT THE
CENTER MCGUIRE SAYS WANTS TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON SB SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN CONSULTANT ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SIX TWO ONE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SIX SEVEN NINE FIVE
GREENVILLE'S JUST DUE TO THE
FACT THAT WE ARE JUST IRONING
OUT SOME FINAL ITEMS IN REGARDS
TO GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. I'LL
BE LAYING OFF FOR TODAY BUT
AGAIN CENTER EGGMAN CENTER
KAMAGRA BEEN DOING GREW UP
REALLY WONDERFUL WORK ON THIS I
AIN'T IT WILL BE I'M SURE
SUPPORT OF IS IN GOVERNMENT
FINANCE BUT FOR TODAY IT'S
SIXTEEN TO GO SHE- WILL BE
LAYING OFF A MONTH. FOR THE
SUMMER. THE SENATE REPORT NOT
THE- OCTOBER. SHIKON SAID AS
SHE LEFT FOR THE DAY OKAY- SIX
ZERO OKAY- THAT BILL IS ALF'S-
AND I THINK FINALLY THE ITEM
FIVE SB SIX SEVENTY NINE YES.
SENATE BILL 679% OF THE PUBLIC
OR THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE CENTER MCGUIRE. WE
HAVE- FIVE VOTES. OKAY CONCERT
WITH SIXTY SIX VOTES- THAT BILL
IS HOUSE. I THINK DIRT
COMPLETES THE AGENDA THE RESULT
OF MY CORRECT YES. OKAY THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE
UNABLE TO TESTIFY FOR WHATEVER
REASON PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE VIA OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT EVERYONE INCLUDED
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION- IN THIS HEARING
TODAY- THAT CONCLUDES THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE AGENDA
AND THIS COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.